EVERYONE IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CAN TEN USED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING I ASK ALL
MEMBERS FOR THE COMMITTEE TO BE
PRESENT IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR HEARING. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS GIVEN
DID MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTINCT DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
TODAY FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO RIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ALL THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX. TWO
EIGHT THREE THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER AT THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE A NUDE AND YOU'RE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVEMAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WE HAVE ELEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA NONE OF THE BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT. S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE BY SENATOR JONES AND SB
NINE TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
GLAZERS. HAVE BEEN PULLED FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. LEYVA HERE LIVING. PHOTO ABOVE
HERE THE TROUBLED HERE COURTESY
YOUR CORTES A HERE DALLI. DALLI
HEAR GLAZER. AS OUR HERE MCGUIRE
PAN. THE COURT VERY GOOD WE HAVE
A QUORUM PRESENT AND WE WILL GO
TO OUR FIRST BILL WHICH IS
SENATOR PORTANTINO WITH SB NINE
OH SIX SENATOR BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. TODAY I AM
PRESENTING SB NINE OH SIX WHICH
WILL HELP TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF OUR CHILDREN BY ADDRESSING
THE TRAGIC INCREASE IN SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS ON CAMPUSES. EVERY
STUDENT EVERY TEACHER EVERY
ADMINISTRATOR EVERY STAFF MEMBER
AND EVERY VISITOR TO A SCHOOL
EVERY VOLUNTEER. SHOULD GO TO
WORK ON A CAMPUS IN THE MORNING
AND SAFELY COME HOME IN THE
AFTERNOON. SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY THERE BEEN A HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR SCHOOL SHOOTINGS IN
CALIFORNIA. HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR.
AND I'M HOPING THAT WE SEE IN
OUR LAST ONE. BUT IT'S BEEN SAID
THAT HOPE ISN'T A STRATEGY. IN
THIS CASE HOPE ISN'T A STRATEGY.
WE MUST DO MORE TO PROTECT OUR
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS ON OUR
SCHOOL SITES. WELL CALIFORNIA'S
ADOPTED STRONG FIREARMS STORAGE
SAFETY LAWS IN APPROXIMATELY 68%
60% OF FIREARM RELATED INCIDENTS
AT SCHOOLS THE FIREARM WAS TAKEN
FROM THE STUDENTS HOME FRIEND OR
RELATIVE. MANY PARENTS ALSO
WRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THEIR
CHILDREN DO NOT KNOW THE
LOCATION OF THEIR HOUSEHOLD
FIREARMS CHILDREN OUT. IN
NINETEEN SB NINE OH SIX WILL
REQUIRE THE DISCLOSURE OF
HOUSEHOLD FIREARMS AND INCLUDE
INFORMATION ON SAFE FIREARM
STORAGE LAWS. THESE MEASURES
WILL INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
AWARENESS OF SAFETY PRECAUTIONS
TO KEEP OUR CHILDREN SAFE.
NUMBER ANOTHER MAJOR PROBLEM IS
THE DISREGARD OF WARNING SIGNS
BEFORE AN INCIDENT AS WE'VE SEEN
RECENTLY IN THE TRAGEDY IN
MICHIGAN. IN ALMOST EVERY CASE
OF A SCHOOL SHOOTING THERE WAS A
CLEAR WARNING SIGNS. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT KNOWING THE SIGNS OF
GUN VIOLENCE CAN PREVENT IT. IN
93% OF INCIDENTS SCHOOL SHOOTERS
PLAN THEIR ATTACK IN ADVANCE.
MOST MADE THREATENING OR
CONCERNING COMMUNICATIONS TO
PARENTS FRIENDS OR EDUCATORS.
LET'S BE CLEAR WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT AN ROTC CLASS WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A GAMER. WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT ITER CHECK IDLE
CHATTER. WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS A CREDIBLE THREAT. THIS
BILL WILL AUTHORIZE CONCERNED
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS TO ACT ON
THESE CREDIBLE FIREARM THREATS
AND AGAIN LET'S BE CLEAR. WE'RE
NOT EXPANDING ANYBODY'S RIGHTS
OR PRIVILEGES WERE NOT GIVING
EXTRA SORRY THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT THEY DON'T ALREADY HAVE
AGAIN LET'S TAKE MICHIGAN FOR
EXAMPLE. THEY HAD THE AUTHORITY
TO INVESTIGATE THEY DIDN'T SAME
IN CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO INVESTIGATE WHAT
I'M SAYING IS THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY DO. THIS BILL WILL
AUTHORIZE AUTHORIZED. CONSIDERED
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS TO ACT ON
A CREDIBLE THREAT NOT GIVE THEM
EXTRA AUTHORITIES TO DO SO IT
JUST WILL AUTHORIZE THEM TO ACT
ON THOSE THREATS. PRIORITIZING
THE SAFETY OF STUDENTS BY
INCREASING TRANSPARENCY ENSURING
SAFE AT HOME FIREARM STORAGE AND
ALLOWING A PERCEIVED THREAT
THREAT TO BE PROPERLY
INVESTIGATED. IS CRUCIAL TO
LESSENING THE CHANCE OF TRAGEDY
LET'S ALSO BE CLEAR ON WHO WOULD
BE DOING THE INVESTIGATION WE'RE
NOT ASKING TEACHERS WE'RE NOT
ASKING ADMINISTRATORS WERE
ASKING THOSE. SWORN AND THOSE
TRAINED LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL TO DO THEIR JOB WHEN
THEY RECEIVE A CREDIBLE THREAT
THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE'S
LOTS OF FOLKS TO THE- WE'RE
GONNA FORCE TEACHERS TO GO
SEARCH A LOCKER NO WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THAT. I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE INDIVIDUALS AND THE
INSTITUTIONS TO ENGAGE IN THIS
ROBUST AND PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE
ABOUT THIS BILL. MY STAFF AND I
HAVE BEEN DILIGENTLY WORKING TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED AND TO TIGHTEN AND
IMPROVE THE BILL. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO ASSURE THOSE WHO WORK ON OUR
CAMPUSES. AS I SAID WE'RE NOT
INTENDING TO HAVE THEM DO THIS
WORK WE'RE ASKING THE TRAINED
AND SWORN OFFICERS TO BE TASKED
WITH THE INVESTIGATION. TO THAT
END SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS WE'RE
NEGOTIATING AND WE'LL BE TAKING
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE SHOULD THE
BILL ADVANCED OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. IS DOCTOR PAT RAISED
A VERY IMPORTANT POINT ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL STUDENTS. YOU KNOW I
DON'T CHATTER AND TEENAGERS
THREATENED SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE THIS SUPPLY. THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS. WE'RE GOING TO AMEND
THE LAND. TO DISCLOSE WHAT WE
WANTED TO FOCUS N UNREGISTERED
GUNS WE RECOGNIZE THE DOJ HAS
INFORMATION HAS A DATABASE.
UNREGISTERED GUNS SO WE'RE GONNA
LOOK AT THE UNREGISTERED GUNS-
AND WE'RE HOPING. TO WORK WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THAT PIECE AS
WELL- WE'RE ALSO GOING TO TAKE-
OUT THERE'S A LOT SECTION IN
THERE TO TALK ABOUT DISOBEDIENCE
OF SCHOOL RULES AND POLICIES WE
WANT TO FOCUS STRICTLY ON
CREDIBLE VIOLENT THREATS SO
WE'RE GONNA NARROW THAT LANGUAGE
AS WELL AS THIS BILL HOPEFULLY
MOVES OUT TODAY. I'M AGAIN I
WANT TO REPEAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT CONDUCTING
ANY INVESTIGATION NOT TEACHERS
STAFF AND ADMINISTRATORS. AND
WE'RE ALSO GOING O BE TALKING
ABOUT MAKING SURE WE'RE CLEAR.
THAT THIS IS ABOUT CREDIBLE
VIOLENT THREATS NOT ABOUT IDLE
CHATTER NOT ABOUT A CONVERSATION
BETWEEN TWO ROTC MEMBERS ABOUT
GUN TRAINING THIS IS ABOUT
THREATS I CONTINUE TO BE REMAIN
OPEN TO FUTURE IMPROVEMENTS AND
FRANKLY WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
ACCESS AND A NUMBER OF OTHER-
STAKEHOLDERS- AND WE BELIEVE AT
THE END OF THE DAY WE'RE GONNA.
MEET MOST IF NOT ALL OF THEIR
REQUEST FRANKLY IN THE WAKE OF
THE DETAILS RAISED IN MICHIGAN.
WE HAVE TO DO MORE. AS A DAD
ISN'T POLICY MAKER I DON'T WANT
TO WAKE UP TO MORNING NEWSPAPER
ACCOUNT OF ANOTHER TRAGEDY
KNOWING THAT WE COULD HAVE A
BOULDER TAKING BOLDER STEPS TO
INVESTIGATE CREDIBLE THREATS ON
OUR CAMPUSES AND THAT WE DIDN'T
DO IT. FRANKLY I COULD SEE AND I
UNDERSTAND AN ADMINISTRATOR
BEING HAMSTRUNG BY THE THOUGHT
THIS WON'T HAPPEN HERE THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN IN OUR COMMUNITY
WHAT IF WE'RE WRONG WHAT IF WE
OVER REACT. WILL ANGER PARENTS
IF WE INVESTIGATED CHILD AND
WERE WRONG. YOU KNOW AND THAT'S
WHAT I'M TRYING TO AVOID THAT
HESITATION WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDABLE I'D RATHER THEY
BLAME ME I'D RATHER THEY GET MAD
AT ME FOR FORCING THIS
INVESTIGATION IN THE WAKE UP AND
READ IN A NEWSPAPER THAT WE
COULD HAVE AVERTED A TRAGEDY. SO
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME TO TESTIFY
SUPPORT MARGOT BENNETT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF WOMEN
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONVERSE WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND HOPEFULLY THIS
BILL COULD MOVE TO ITS NEXT STOP
AND WE CAN MAKE THE IMPROVEMENTS
NECESSARY THANK. THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO WILL MISTER
WITH YOUR LEAD SOME- MORE
BENNETT MARGO ARE YOU CALLING IN
ARE YOU ONTHE LINE. I AM ON THE
LINE GREAT PLEASE PROCEED YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH SIX. MY
NAME IS MARCO BENNETT AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF WOMEN
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE AND ALMOST
THIRTY YEAR OLD GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION ORGANIZATION
HEADQUARTERED IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA. FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AS SCHOOL SHOOTINGS HAVE
BECOME MORE AND MORE FREQUENT
ADULT HAVE SHIFTED THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SCHOOL SAFETY
THE STUDENTS WE'VE PUT IN PLACE
PROGRAMS SUCH AS ACTIVE SHOOTER
DRILLS SEE SOMETHING SAY
SOMETHING. SIGNS OF SUICIDE OR
ESTO WEST WHICH IS THE PROGRAM
FOR MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO TEACHES THEM HOW TO
IDENTIFY SIGNS OF DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDE. IF THEY TRAINING PER.
TO LEARN HOW TO WITH THIS INJURE
HERE'S DURING A SCHOOL SHOOTING
. AND ALICE AN ACTIVE SHOOTER
DRILL THAT INCLUDES TEACHING OUR
CHILDREN HOW TO FIGHT OFF A
GUNMAN. AS A RESULT IN PARENTS I
AM EMBARRASSED AND ASHAMED WHEN
ARE WE THE ADULTS GOING TO
ASSUME THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT
IS OURS. THE SAFETY OF OUR
CHILDREN. WE NOW HAVE THAT
CHANCE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATOR
ANTHONY PORTANTINO HAS
INTRODUCED SB NINE OH SIX. A
STRONG AND COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE
OF ACTIONS THAT WILL HELP
PREVENT SCHOOL SHOOTINGS AND
HELP KEEP ALL OUR CHILDREN THREE
FALLEN. IT OUR TURN TO. IT'S
TURN ACCEPT RESPOND. PLEASE VOTE
YES SB NINE OH SIX OUR CHILDREN
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DEPEND ON US.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I WILL NOW
GO TO THIS ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN PERSON WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SEEING THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR FOR GO
AHEAD MA'AM. HI OF THE THIRTY
MARK WITH THE FTA A UNION OF EDU
AND CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS-
WHO JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR WE HAVE NO POSITION AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE A WATCH
POSITION BUT WE JUST WANTED TO
CREATE HIS. THOUGHTFUL AND
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS SCHOOL
SAFETY ON CAMPUS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THESE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS THAT. THEY MAY
PERCEIVE GREAT THANK YOU ARE WE
NOW GOING TO OPEN THE PHONE
LINES WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT
TESTIMONY ON THE PHONE LINES
TODAY TO TWENTY MINUTES FOR EACH
SIDE SO WE WILL START FROM WITH
THOSE IN SUPPORT. OF A MODERATOR
IF YOU CAN OPEN THE LINES FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO OH NINE. EXCUSE ME NINE OH
SIX DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT CAME
FROM. THANK YOU MEDICARE HIM
AGAIN- LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FEAR IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH SIX. AND
THE FIRST LITTLE LINE AT ONE
ZERO ONE ONE OF ONE PEOPLE AT.
READERS OKAY THIS IS FOLKS IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE OH SIX
THOSE IN OPPOSITION WILL HAVE
THEIR CHANCE AS WELL MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
BRING PEOPLE ON THE LINE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF NINE OH SIX. THANK
YOU AND UP NEXT LITTLE LINE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DON'T. ONE SEVENTY NINE ARE YOU
BORED OF ESPINO SAID. LET'S GO
TO THE NEXT CALL INCLUDING THANK
YOU YEP THANK YOU. AND WATERLINE
A ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. EFFECT ME I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING TO ME. YES YES YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YET OKAY OKAY ED ISSUES-
MY NAME IF YOU LAND I'M AT THE
ME ALL THESE YEARS AND THE-
FOUNDER OF INTERNATIONAL HEALTH
AND IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW THAT YOU
NEED FIFTH CENTER WHICH WE HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO ANY ECONOMIC WHO
DO. ONE MINUS AND NUMBER OF
KILLING AND SHOOT MA'AM ARE YOU
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL JUST. LET
US KNOW THAT YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. YES I MEAN SUPPORT
OF THE AND THANK YOU TO CONNECT
UP ON JAN FOR A- IMPORTANT
ISSUES WITH MAKE OTHER. TO FEEL
AND- THANK YOU THAT'S CALLER
PLAY. EDUCATION YOU. NEXT IN
LINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MATANCERA MEMBERS SITTING
ATOP ARE WITH THE CONSUMER
JOURNEY THE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT UP TO
LINE ONE TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LAST THANKS VERY THINK
THAT NEEDS BUT WE CAN HEAR YOU
WOULDN'T ANSWER PHONE NUMBER
FOR. OR- SUPPORT I'M NOT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU IN THE WRONG
LINE I DON'T KNOW HOW. THAT'S
OKAY WE'LL COME BACK TO WHEN WE
GO TO OPPOSITION NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND I'M ALSO. JOSE MAY HAVE TO
COME BACK TO ME OKAY WE WILL DO
THAT THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH SIX THIS
IS YOUR TIME. IN ORDER TO ONE
ONE ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN-
I'M ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
WILL GET YOU IN WE GO TO
OPPOSITION NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
IN THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE HAVE-
MEDICARE- NO FURTHER LINES IN
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR ART WILL MELT MOVED
TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO FOCUS
ON THAT ARE THELEAD OPPOSITION.
ROY GRIFFITH LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL. AND DEBBIE MCDONALD
A RETIRED SCHOOL TEACHER-
ADMINISTRATOR- WHEAT YOU BOTH
HAVE TWO MINUTES AND WE WILL
START WITH ROY PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CENTERS FOR THE REST
OF YOUR GROUP OF LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
MEETING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL NINE OF SIX. ALSO
REPRESENTING THE NRA WHO ARE
UNABLE TO CALL IN TODAY. I DON'T
PARENTS ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
PLAYING VERY CLOSE ATTENTION TO
THIS BILL SENATE BILL NINE OH
SIX VIOLATES THEIR FIRST
AMENDMENT BY COMPELLING SPEECH
THE FOURTH AMENDMENT BY ACTIVELY
CREATING UNUSUAL SURGE. AND IT'S
AMENDMENT RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS.
MOREOVER ADS. VALUE TO A SURGEON
AT THE RIGHT IT DOES NOT AND HE
DOES THAT IS. EFFECT TO EXERCISE
A ONE SECOND AND THE RIGHTS
WHICH I BELIEVE IS THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL. THE FARM IS A
PERSONAL CHOICE AND PER U. S.
SUPREME COURT. DISTRICT COLUMBIA
VERSUS HELLER. PROTECTED AS AN
INDIVIDUAL RIGHT UNDER THE
SECOND AMENDMENT REQUIRING GUN
OWNERS TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW THE EXERCISE THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT. IN ALL
PLACES THEIR HOMES WEAKENS THAT
RIGHT AND ALSO INVADES OUR
PRIVACY. THERE ARE ALSO MANY
LAWS IN PLACE ALREADY. THE
STATE'S STORAGE INSENSIBILITY OF
FIREARMS TO MINORS. MINOR GAINS
ACCESS TO FARM STORE IN THE
WHOLE NEWS AND STATE FOR ILLEGAL
MANNER THE HOMEOWNER MAY BE HELD
WHILE. HAS RE TALK PEACE OFFICER
THIRTY TWO YEARS I CAN TELL YOU
THAT SB NINE ONE SIX.
ENFORCEABILITY AND POTENTIALLY
SUBJECTS. EDUCATIONAL PERSONNEL
COMMITTEE DO. LITTLE SEARCH AND
SEIZURES. SB NINE ALSO IS NOT
OUR TO. STUDENTS OF NON HEALTH
THE HELP IS. WHO COMMIT ACTS
THAT. IN NASCO IN WHICH NOT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
STATE. WHAT'S NEXT PARENTS WERE
COMING CORNERBACK THE- AND
PRESCRIPTION. AND CABINET. WHICH
KILL MORE CHILDREN IN FARMS.
PUBLIC OPINION CONSTITUTIONAL OF
OUR CITIZENS TO USE FARMS
EUROPEAN BELIEVES DOES USE FARMS
IN THE COMMISSION VIOLENT CRIME
SHOULD BE PUNISHED THE PORTIONS
OF THE LAW. WE STAND WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT EDUCATORS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. TO PUT THE SAFETY OF
OUR CITIZENS FIRST SHARPAY WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT SOUND
LEGISLATION AIMED AT PROTECTING
OUR CHILDREN REDUCING CRIME
GETTING CRIMINALS OUT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS NO SUCH
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. I LIKE TO
REDUCING YOU'LL THE REMAINDER OF
MY TIME. TO THE STATEMENT ON A
RETIRED SCHOOL TEACHER MOST
HELPFUL PERSON I KNOW ON THE
SUBJECT. PLEASE OPEN MINDS TO
WEAR SHE HAS TO SHARE THANK YOU
FOR THIS. THANK YOU SIR- IS
WITHOUT YOU'RE A- TO MINUTES A
LITTLE OVER TWO MINUTES THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING AND JEFFERSON
SENATOR MY NAME IS MAC DONALD I
JOIN YOU TODAY REQUIRE. TEACHER
IN A MINUTE. WHO DEALT WITH THE
THAT THREE ASSESSMENTS IN MY
ROLE. AS WELL I WAS ON THE HIT.
OF THE- WHO BROUGHT A FIRE TO
SCHOOL. I HAVE LIVED YOU ARE
TRYING TO PREVENT LEAD THE WAY.
THE METHODOLOGY BEING AND- IN
THE- BUDGET. ON THIS. CREATE
DIRECT. READ STATE YOU NOTHING
THAT IS INVOLVED IN THE- OF
DISTRICT EMPLOYEES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AS I READ
NATIONALIZED LIKE. THE ALL THING
I CAN SEE IS THAT I WOULD HAVE
MORE WORK MORE TRAINING TO DO
WITHOUT BEYOND WHAT IS ALREADY
MANDATED IN ACCORDANCE WITH A
FULL POLICIES. AND I NOW HAVE
ANOTHER OFFICE. TO WHICH TO
RECORD DATA. THAT MEANS THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT ONE PERSON
AGENCIES AND THE OJ WILL ALSO
HAVE MORE PAPERWORK DATA TO
FILTER. I WILL NOT EXPRESS THE
COMPLEXITY BUT IF THE IF THE
COURT THE DATA ACQUISITION. WHAT
TRULY IS THE OBJECTIVE BEHIND
THIS LEGISLATION FOR I CANNOT
SEE THE TRUTH OKAY. BEING ON
PREVENTIVE MEASURES. BUT THAT
HAPPENS ON A RELATIONAL LEVEL
NOT A PAPER WORK OR BUREAUCRATIC
LEVEL. IN MY WORK WITH STUDENTS
AND STAFF MY DAYS WERE FILLED
WITH RED ASSESSMENT. RANGING
FROM DRUG ALCOHOL POMFRET FOR
MORE. TRAINING PREDECESSORS HAVE
BEEN MISSING FOR YEARS. WHAT
NEXT OF LEGISLATION NY
DIFFERENT AND WHAT WILL REALLY
CHANGE AND THE EFFECT AND THE
POTENTIAL FOR AT. THE ONLY THING
I CAN ASCERTAIN THE LEGISLATION
THAT THE FACT IT WILL TARGET
FIREARMS IN HOMES. LEADING ONE
TO QUESTION WHAT THE TRUE INTENT. OF THIS LEGISLATION WILL LOOK
AT. BOTH HAVE THEIR TO THIRTY.
IN NUMBER ONE NEWS. BURKE YEAH
THE LAND RULING BY THE U. S.
SUPREME REGARDING CERTAIN. OF
SCHOOL. BOOK WILL OFFICIALS MAY
THIRTY THE PROPERTY YEAH.
SUSPICION THAT A SCHOOL IT WILL
HAVE BROKEN NORTH. INTERNET
CEMENTING OUR HOUSE COMMITTED A
CRIME A CRIME. THAT MILLION SO
IT CAN GOING CAL. ONE INCIDENT
OF A CHILD A FIVE. TO SCHOOL.
HARM TO OTHERS ONE MANY YES
THERE ARE WEAPONS BEYOND
FIREARMS THAT CAN BE EMPLOYED TO
DO HARM. THIS LEGISLATION AS A
FURTHER ATTACK ON THE RIGHT THE
GOOD CITIZENS WHO FOLLOW THE
LAWS. HOW DO YOU REQUIRE OF. LOS
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR HOME THE
ANNUAL NOTIFICATION RELATED TO
SAY STORAGE IS ANOTHER LAYER OF
MANDATE. THAT WILL NOT CHANGE
THE ABSENCE OF A CHILD THANK YOU
I'M ISN'T DONALD. I DON'T IS THE
INVOLVEMENT OF PARENTS IN THE
CHILD'S LIFE. YEAH ALL THE LOVE
IN FLORIDA P. THANK YOU MISS
MCDONALD'S THEY'VE EXCEEDED.
YOUR TIME. BY THANK YOU VERY FOR
TESTIMONY ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
TO READ TWENTY ONE HUNDRED THERE
ANYWAY WHO TO OPPOSE THE BILL IN
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE COME FOR TO
THE MICROPHONE. RICHELLE CONNOR
ABOLITIONISTS WITH THE FREDERICK
DOUGLAS FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM ANYBODY ELSE
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
SEEING NONE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AND WE WILL TAKE
TWENTY MINUTES. OF TESTIMONY FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE SB
NINE OH SIX MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP OUR FIRST
SPEAKER. THANK YOU HERE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
OH SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN
THAT LITTLE LINE EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT WILL MOVE
TO LINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS JOHN WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUT REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF CITIZENS IN THAT
COUNTY AND WE AREN'T STRONG
OPPOSITION THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT LITTLE LINE SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CATHY
SURE FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION-
WE ARE LISTED AS BEING IN
OPPOSITION BUT I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US
ON OUR CONCERNS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING PROCESS
INVOLVING THEM THANK YOU. NEXT
ONE ALIGNED ONE THIRTY FOUR ONE
THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS JEFF TURNER I'M DEMOCRAT
FROM SEASIDE CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB NINE SIX AND
ASK THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE
ACCORDINGLY THANK YOU. NEXT
LITTLE LINE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS RACHEL
QUESTIONS UNANSWERED THE BILL.
NO WILL WIND TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS HEATHER
GIPSON AND I OPPOSE THE BILL.
NEXT TO ALIGN THE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN THE TO THE
TIME'S UP TO CUTE NETWORK LINE
AT ONE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS STEVE RODDA MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
. NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION AND
U. S. NAVY VETERAN AND I'M
STRONGLY URGING THE COMMITTEE TO
OPPOSE. BILL NINE ZERO SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NOW WITH THE WIND
ONE ELEVEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JAMES
FRAZIER FATHER FOR VENTURA
COUNTY RESIDENTS I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB NINE SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE THE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SCOTT I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE AND.
WELL WHY NOT ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD- GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU COMMITTEE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS DARREN
BEVELL AND OTHER TO SCHOOL AGE
DAUGHTERS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFE WITH BOTH OF THE
STATION AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED THE SB NINE OH SIX
ENERGY TO- VOEPEL. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE NINETEEN
ONE ONE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MELANIE
I AM A MOTHER- I AM A GUN OWNER
BUT I STILL OPPOSE THE WRONG WAY
I FEEL THAT THEIR CLEVERNESS
COLOR PLEASE. IT WILL GO TO LINE
SIXTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RESEARCHERS TO EXPAND ON THE
CHARM STYLE STARTS FROM CHAPTER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
SOCIALIZATION AND THEN ALREADY
MEMBER AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
SEVERAL OF OUR MEMBERS THAT
AREN'T ABLE TO- CALL AND THE
LINE OF THE LINES ARE FULL-
URGING A NO VOTE ON THIS
INFRINGEMENT ON THE FIRST SECOND
FOURTH AND FIFTH AMENDMENT
RIGHTS OF PARENTS. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DAN SCHOLES I AM ACR PA. THE
NUMBER AND- FATHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. YEAH BOTTOM LINE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING I BELIEVE THE
SKILLS FOLLOWING THE FALL OF THE
STUDENT K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY- IN MY I'M
IN A POSITION BECAUSE USING THE
CALIFORNIA MAKE YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE SOME. AND WE WILL
GO POINT ONE ZERO EIGHT ONE
AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS WALKER I'M A FULL FROM
RESIDENTS I'M A PARENT OF THREE
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. IT WILL GO
TO LINE ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING MY NAME IS MIKE
THE LAYERS FROM A RESIDENT OF
VENTURA COUNTY AND ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND A GRANDFATHER OF
. FOR SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN I URGE
YOU TO OPPOSE THIS. BILL AND
VOTE NO ON S. B. NINE ZERO SIX
Q. THANK YOU. IT WILL GO UP TO
ONE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ERICA VERSE
TWENTY AND I JUST WANTED TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL IT'S
INFRINGEMENT ON OUR RIGHT. THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PAT
BURTON MALL LIFE MEMBER OF THE
NRA LIFE MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
REFERENCES ASSOCIATION. CHAIRMAN
OF THE PAYMENT COUNTY GUN OWNERS
CHAPTER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
DISASSOCIATION AND A RETIRED
SERGEANT THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE OH SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. NOW TOTALING
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CANTIL BRIAN IN THE LIFE
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA. CALLING
TO OPPOSE SB NINE OH SIX AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
CATCHER WILLIAM. I'M A SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE AYE OPPOSED ZERO NINE
OH SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
WE WILL DECLINE NUMBER TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AMANDA NELSON
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
. WE'LL GO TO ONE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE FUNNY OF
ARTISTS I AM AT THE THIRD PARENT
AND I AM IN A POSITION OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THE LINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD OF ME
WE CAN THANK YOU MY NAME THE
FIRST OF A HAM AND I AM A
CONCERNED PARENT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
IT WILL GO TO LINUS THE ONE WE
DON'T HAVE. MY TO DO WHAT YOU
WANT IS OPEN. AND WE WILL MOVE
ON TO THE LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA LIVINGSTON I AM A
CITIZEN IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ANY MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION THE WELL ARMED WOMAN
AND THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION I ASK YOU TO
VOTE IN OPPOSITION S. B. NINE
ZERO SIX. IT WILL GO TO WIND UP
ONE TWO OR THREE PEOPLE I HAVE.
TAMMY'S AND THE MOTHER OF TWO
I'M A FORMER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
AND SCHOOL LAW ATTORNEY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. IT WILL BE ONE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN'T
. OKAY CARLENE ELLIS I AM A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION THE
NATIONAL RIFLE. STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THE URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON SB NINE OH SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND NEXT IN LINE TO
ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DAVID PARKER SELMA COUNTY
PROPERTY OWNER COLONISE- I
OPPOSED BY- SIX HE GOT OUT OF
OUR CAPSULES THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. IN LITTLE WIND ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SANDRA
YEAH AND I AM A MEMBER OF THE
COSTA COUNTY FREEDOM COALITION
AND MOTHER OF TWO- I AM CALLING
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL AND THANK MR
GRIFFIN AND MR MCDONALD'S FOR
SPEAKING UP- IN OPPOSITION THIS
THE FIRST WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. AND WE WILL
WIND UP ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF HIS MYSELF FULLER
WITH ERIN READ ENOUGH AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF FOREIGN AND
PHD CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROL AND IF AUTHOR
TAKES THE AMENDMENT REMOVING THE
REGISTERED KEEPER THAT THEY'LL-
PARK IN. LOOKING IN THEIR OP AND
COST MISTER FOR ONE WE FEEL LIKE
. THANK YOU THANK YOU. IN THE
BOTTOM LINE SIX ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME DEREK HUME IN
OUR MEMBER I THIS. NINE ZERO.
AND LITTLE WIND ONE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
STEVE A SOURCE I AM THAT THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY GUN OWNERSHIP-
CHAPTER AT THE C. RPA AND I
APPROACH THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IN MEDICARE AND NOT
FOR THEIR LINES IN OPPOSITION
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
ALL RIGHT WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NONE YES YES SENATE
ALI. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I. TODAY I'M GONNA BE
OPPOSE IN THE LEGISLATION THAT
IS HERE- AND I JUST WANNA SHARE
THAT- SOMEBODY WHO IS- PERUT AND
ALSO- NO MY WIFE SAID ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD FOR A LONG TIME AND
IN KEEPING STUDENTS SAFE IS. IS
A NUMBER ONE PRIORITY BUT I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL- IN
ITS FORM IS GOING TO DO IT IT'S-
THE AUTHOR THINKS IT'S GOING TO
DO NUMBER ONE I THINK IT
INFRINGES ON- GUN OWNERS RIGHTS
WE ALREADY HAVE LAWS ON THE
BOOKS THAT ARE. WE ARE REQUIRED
. SKEWS ME WE ARE REQUIRED TO-
HAVE THOSE IN THE SAFE OR
LOCKED- WE ARE FREE YOU'RE FULLY
BY A FIREARM IT IS REGISTERED WE
ARE FINGERPRINTED THERE'S A
BACKGROUND CHECK YEAH DONE IN
CALIFORNIA- SO THERE'S A LOT OF
ALREADY LAWS ON THE BOOKS ABOUT
PEOPLE KNOWING WHO HAS- FIREARMS
BUT THIS WOULD- I THINK IT
BRIDGE THE RIGHTS ON THE
STUDENTS AS WELL- I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR LAST. AUG
AWESOME BILL THAT- I THOUGHT
WILL DO ACTUALLY MORE FOR-
HELPING KEEPING STUDENTS SAFE IT
WAS THE BILL THAT- WE WOULD
EDUCATE THE SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS
THE- CAFETERIA WORKER. EVERYONE
THAT IS IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
THAT IS- DEALING WITH KIDS TO
IDENTIFY WHEN THERE'S MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. AND AND TO BE
ABLE TO SEE THAT THEY MAY NEED
COUNSELING AND THAT I THINK THAT
BILL WHICH I SAID HOLY SUPPORT
ELECTED I'M I'M REALLY SADDENED
TO SEE THAT IT IT GOT HUNG UP IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND GETTING GET OUT
AND GET SIGNED INTO LAW BECAUSE-
THAT BILL ACTUALLY. I BELIEVE
WOULD DO A LOT MORE THAN THIS
BILL AND SO- THIS BILL IS A LOT
OF WORK I THINK IT INFRINGES ON
THE RIGHTS OF- PARENTS AND
STUDENTS. AND FOR THOSE REASONS
I'LL BE OPPOSING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY CENTER
CHAU BOOK. SO VERY INTERESTING
BECAUSE I'VE ALSO BEEN IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR PASSED BILLS
WITH WITH REGARDS TO OUR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND I THINK AS
I'VE EXPRESSED IN PREVIOUS
COMMITTEES IS. THE ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW IS BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CONCERNS AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK WE'VE BEEN SUCH PARTNERS
ON ON LEGISLATION THAT. PROVIDES
RESOURCES- IN OPPORTUNITIES TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE AT HAND BUT I-
WAS VERY INTERESTING BECAUSE I
LIKE TO LISTEN TO WITNESSES VERY
CAREFULLY TO SEE WHAT SOME OF
THE CONCERNS ARE. AND I EAT I
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR HOW YOU WOULD
RESPOND TO THE CONCERNS THAT-
THIS BILL AND IN MIND YOU I
THINK THE TITLE IS VERY- WHAT'S
THE WORD- LET ME JUST GIVE YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT IT DOES VIOLATE
VIOLATE- MANY OF THE AT
CONSTITUTIONAL- VOIGTS RIGHT BUT
- FIRST OF ALL I DON'T THINK IT
IT IT DOES IN THE SENSE THAT I
AM COGNISANT OF THAT THE DOJ
ALREADY HAS. 80% OF THE DATA ON-
GUN OWNERSHIP REGISTERED GUNS-
AND SO THAT WAS ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I'M PROPOSING TO
TAKE IS THAT WE NARROWED THE
REGISTRY PIECE BECAUSE WE HAVE
80% OF THAT INFORMATION ON THE
SEARCH AND SEIZURE PIECE- WHICH-
I THINK. I WAS. SUBJECT TO SOME
OF THE PASSION WE'RE NOT
CHANGING ANY OF THE LAWS ARE
RIGHT TO PRIVILEGES THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE TO SEARCH
PROPERTY SO WE'RE NOT EXPANDING
THAT SO I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY FIRST AMENDMENT ISSUES
THERE- AND SO I THINK WE'RE ON
SOLID CONSTITUTIONAL GROUNDS AND
AGAIN I'M OPEN TO SUGGESTIONS
AND- TRYING TO WORK WITH FOLKS
AS YOU HEARD EVEN SOME OF THE
OPPOSERS WERE IN MY OPINION
QUITE SORT OF SOFT IN SOME OF
THEIR OPPOSITION BECAUSE THEY
KNOW WE'VE BEEN WORKING IN GOOD
FAITH- WITH THEM TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS. AND I
THINK IN THE END THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO ADDRESS ALL OF. SO I
THINK. EVERYBODY WAS SCHOOL
SAFETY AND IN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE IF THERE WAS
ANY SORT OF THREAT IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHY IN CALIFORNIA WHY
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS NEEDED- EVEN
IN A MODIFIED. VERSION DO YOU
HAVE ANY DATA THAT SHOWS THAT
THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY NEEDED IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
ALREADY PROTOCOLS IN PLACE. WHAT
WE HAVE AS HUMAN NATURE- AND
BEING AT. SCHOOL PARENT MYSELF
BEING A MEMBER OF MANY SCHOOL
ORGANIZATIONS I'VE BEEN IN ROOMS
WHERE PARENTS AND ADMINISTRATORS
SAID. WELL THAT'S A PROBLEM BUT
IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
A PROBLEM IN OUR COMMUNITY I
THINK THAT'S A NORMAL HUMAN
TRAIT THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
SAY. YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE THAT
ON OUR STREET OR WE DON'T HAVE
THAT IN OUR IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S THE PROBLEM. THAT
HESITANCY THAT I UNDERSTAND AND
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN
MICHIGAN. YOU KNOW YOU CAN
NEVER. YOU CAN NEVER PREDICT
WHEN YOU'VE PERFECTED SOMETHING.
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN PREVENTED. DO
I BELIEVE THIS WILL PREVENT HIV
YES IF I DIDN'T I WOULDN'T
PROPOSE IT. AS A PARENT OR
LEGISLATOR I DON'T WANT TO READ
A NEWSPAPER ARTICLE. THAT HAS
DETAILS SIMILAR TO WHAT HAPPENED
IN MICHIGAN. IS IT GONNA HAPPEN
TOMORROW I DON'T KNOW WILL
HAPPEN TEN YEARS FROM NOW I
DON'T KNOW. BUT THE POINT IS WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TODAY. TO
TAKE PRUDENT STEPS. TO SAY TO
ADMINISTRATORS. WE WANT TO
LESSEN YOUR BURDEN. BY
COMPELLING YOU TO INVESTIGATE
ONLY WHEN THERE'S A CREDIBLE
THREAT AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT PEOPLE ARE MISS.
INTERPRETING WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT. IDLE CHATTER. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THOSE THREATS THAT
WE KNOW TO BE REAL. THAT MIGHT
FOR SOMEBODY TO TAKE IN ACTION
BECAUSE IT WON'T HAPPEN
COMMUNITY. THAT'S THE PROBLEM
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS- TO
THE CHAIR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
FROM THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND-
THAT COULD ANSWER A QUESTION
WITH REGARDS TO. POLICY IN IN
ACTUALLY. PURSUING A POTENTIAL
THREAT AS I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
ANYONE HERE FROM NEOVIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH ACCESS- AND
THEY'VE GIVEN US A NUMBER OF
THEIR CONCERNS AND I BELIEVE
WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS- I THINK
WE'RE GONNA ACT OF EVENTUALLY
ADDRESS ALL OF THEM- SO. YOU
KNOW THEY DIDN'T COME UP IN
OPPOSE IT TODAY AND SO I THINK
THAT'S BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING IN GOOD FAITH I'M NOT
GONNA SPEAK FOR THEM BUT I'M
CONFIDENT
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS AND I
BELIEVE- CHECKED WITH MY STAFF.
ACCESS CONCERNS WERE VERY
SIMILAR THE ONES EXPRESSED BY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WHICH I KNOW
YOU REPRESENT YEAH AND THAT'S
YOU KNOW I HAVE A SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN MY THAT HAS
EXPRESSED CONCERNS AND I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER OR
NOT THIS BILL NEEDS A LITTLE
MORE TIME TO WORK WITH THAT-
THIS TIME AROUND OR SHOULD WE
COME BACK TO IT- MAYBE NEXT
YEAR- WITH SOME OF THE WORK
ALREADY IN PLACE BECAUSE I THINK
RIGHT NOW. THERE ARE A LOT OF
HESITATION FROM MANY
STAKEHOLDERS WITH REGARD TO THE
LANGUAGE WITHOUT SEEING AND I
KNOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT AND I'VE BEEN IN. YOU KNOW
PARTNER BEFORE IN TRYING TO GET
THINGS A LITTLE BIT MORE
WORKABLE I'M MOVING FORWARD BUT
JUST FROM RIGHT NOW- SO WE HAVE
ACTUALLY SOMEONE FROM. MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT HERE- THROUGH THE CHAIR
WOULD BE POSSIBLE TO HAVE THEM
WHERE ARE THEY JEFF BARKER. WHAT
IS THE SPECIFIC QUESTION YOU'RE
ASKING SENATE OF BOTH- WHAT THE
CONCERNS MAY BE THAT M. DO WE
ALREADY HAVE IN PLACE A PROTOCOL
TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF CONCERN
WITH REGARDS TO STUDENTS WHO MAY
SHOW OF- SIGNS OF. POTENTIAL
HARM USING A WEAPON- AT SCHOOL
OR GUNS IN THE SPECIFIC. MANAGER
WITH YOUR PERMISSION PLEASE
PROCEED- JEFF PARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
IN THE TWENTY THREE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SUPERINTENDENTS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. YES YOU DO
YOUR QUESTION SENATOR IT IS YES-
NOT LIKELY ANYTHING THAT GOES TO
THE LEVEL OF Y. CENTER
PORTANTINO IS PROPOSING AND HIS
BILL- HI. AS HE HAS NOTED- A WE
ARE WORKING WITH ACCESS- ON
THEIR CONCERNS AND- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN GOING
WELL. AND THAT IS THAT IS WHY
DID NOT COME UP TODAY BECAUSE-
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE- YOU KNOW
HOW HOW THESE CONVERSATIONS
CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD A FOUR
WEEK- ACTUALLY ADOPTED OPPOSE
POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HOPEFULLY THAT
HOPEFULLY THAT HELPS BECAUSE
AGAIN IT SHOWS THE GOOD FAITH
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
BOTH RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
ACCESS. OKAY AND MANAGER IF I
COULD COME IN ON THE OTHER ISSUE
IF THIS WAS THE FIRST YEAR OF A
TWO YEAR SESSION I WOULD TAKE
THAT OPPORTUNITY. AND SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT LET'S. LET'S WORK ON
IT BUT GIVEN THAT IT'S DOUBLE
REFERRED IN. THE TIMELINE AND-
FRANK I WAS HOPING TO GET. YOU
KNOW GET MORE SPECIFICS FEEDBACK
YOU KNOW TO THIS POINT. AND I
APPRECIATE THOSE THAT HAVE HAVE
HAVE GIVEN IT. SO THAT'S WHY I
WANT TO KEEP THE BALL MOVING TO
HAVE ANOTHER COMMITTEE THAT WE
HAVE TO GO TO- ACTUALLY TWO MORE
COMMITTEE SO THERE'S AMPLE TIME
IN THE SENATE. TAKE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION FOR YOU TO SEE THE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE. AS THIS
HOPEFULLY MOVES TODAY- SO IT'S
NOT GONNA COME TO THE FLOOR
TOMORROW SO THERE'S TWO MORE
COMMITTEES. IN THE SENATE ITSELF
. IF THAT HELPS THANK YOU
SENATOR JOE BOOKS CENTER GLAZER
AN INCENTIVE. THANK YOU- CENTER
PORTANTINO THE- THE CLARION CALL
FROM YOUR OPENING REMARKS- IT
CERTAINLY RAIN- WITH GREAT FORCE
FOR ME IS THAT THE STATUS QUO IS
UNACCEPTABLE. THE STATUS QUO IS
UNACCEPTABLE AFTER ALL THESE
TRAGEDIES YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS
SARAH HEARTS AND PRAYERS GO OUT
TO THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN HURT- AND
WE PLEDGE TO TRY TO DO SOMETHING
TO. MAKE IT NOT HAPPEN AGAIN- A
BILL LIKE THIS DOES HAVE A
DIFFICULT PATH THERE ARE MANY.
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
HAVE TO BE BALANCED AND I
APPRECIATE HOW HARD IT IS BUT- I
ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO GET INTO THAT BREACH. AND
CONSTRUCTIVELY TRY TO FIND THAT
THAT BALANCE IN THAT PATHWAY. NO
EVEN IN THE QUIET OF THIS.
HEARING ROOM. I CAN STILL HEAR
THE CRIES OF. FIVE MILLION
PARENTS- I CAN I CAN SEE THE
TEARS FLOWING DOWN THEIR FACES
AYE HI CAN HEAR THEIR MEMORIAL
PRAYERS ABOUT A YOUNG LIFE. CUT
SHORT- AND I AND I KNOW THAT WE
ALL SHARE THAT. GRIEF WE ALL
SHARE THAT GRIEF. BUT I WOULD
SAY TO MY COLLEAGUES THAT.
SENATOR PORTANTINO IS AT
CONSTRUCTIVELY TRYING TO FIND A
PATH I THINK WE SHOULD GIVEN THE
CHANCE TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT I THINK THAT WE WILL HAVE
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITIES TO SAY
THAT NO THIS DOESN'T DO ENOUGH
FOR GO AS FAR AS WE'D LIKE WE
HAVE PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITIES.
GOING FORWARD I WE KNOW ALL THE
HURDLES THAT EXIST IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. BUT I WOULD
NOT LIKE TO SEE. A YEAR LOST AS
WE TRY TO FIGURE THIS OUT. AS
DIFFICULT AS IT IS. AND SO I
WOULD- I WOULD URGE US TO GIVE
HIM THAT ROOM TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE. I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND TO
MOVE THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS
CENTER PAN. THANK YOU- SENATE
FORTINO- FOR- DRESSING THIS A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND- I
THINK I ALSO WOULD HAVE TO THE
WORDS OF SAN PLEASURE- THANK YOU
KNOW IS IT IS THIS THE RIGHT
SOLUTION- I THINK YOU'RE WORKING
WITH- YOU KNOW FOLKS BOTH IN
SCHOOL AND WE HEARD FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS IT'S A IT'S A
DIFFICULT PATH- BUT I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT- OF COURSE CERTAINLY
WE ARE- WE REMEMBER. THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE. THEN HARMED- AND THE
TRAGEDIES THAT HAPPENED. I
MYSELF AS A PEDIATRICIAN HAS
TAKEN. NOT TAKING CARE OF A
CHILD WHO WILL ACTUALLY COMPETE-
WELL TEMPTED SUICIDE WITH A GUN
AT SCHOOL. AT ANNOUNCED IT UP
PRIOR TO DOING IT AND- NO ONE
TOOK HIM SERIOUSLY. SO- AND
UNFORTUNATELY WASN'T QUITE
SUCCESSFUL AT TWENTY AND IT UP
HAVING TO TAKE CARE HIM- THE- IT
ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT. CERTAINLY
THIS ISSUE IS SERIOUS ENOUGH
THAT MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR
HAVING DRILLS. FROM MASS
SHOOTINGS RIGHT TO EVEN MY OWN
CHILDREN WHO ATTEND SCHOOL AND
THAT HAS ACTUALLY AFFECT ON ALL
CHILDREN RIGHT- WE'VE ACTUALLY
IN THIS VERY COMMITTEE. FOR
BILLS AROUND- YOU KNOW HER AT
LEAST ONE BILL AROUND THIS ISSUE
AND DON'T WANT TO CONCERNS WAS
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL HARM THAT
ACTUALLY CAN CAUSE CHILDREN WHO
HAVE TO GO THROUGH DRILLS WHERE
ESSENTIALLY- THE EXPECTATION IS
THAT SOMEONE'S. GOING TO SHOW UP
IN THEIR SCHOOL AND HARM THEM
WITH A GUN AND- THE IDEA THAT
CHILD HAS TO PREPARE FOR THAT.
POSSIBILITY IT IS THIS IS NOT
GOOD FOR THEIR MENTAL HEALTH SO-
I THINK YOU KNOW CERTAINLY WE
WANT TO EXPAND AND YOU'VE BEEN A
CHAMPION OF EXPANDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND- RESOURCES
FOR PEOPLE IN SCHOOL AND I KNOW
MANY OF US HAVE- BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO TRY TO GET. THE ROOT OF
SOME OF THIS RIGHT SO WHAT IS
CAUSING THE MENTAL HEALTH
DISTRESS INTO SO MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS. THAT'S REALLY DOESN'T
HELP WHEN YOU. HAVE CHILDREN WHO
HAVE TO GO THROUGH DRILLS. AND
FRANKLY FOR THEIR OWN SAFETY-
SO- TO. IT FOR THE POSSIBILITY
OF SOMEONE TO SHOW UP WITH A-
WITH A WITH A GUN AND- CERTAINLY
THERE ARE MANY WEAPONS BUT- GUNS
ARE. PARTICULARLY DEADLY AND THE
DESIGN TO BE SO. AND SO THAT IS
A YELLOW RIBBONS- WE HAVE TO.
CONFRONT THAT AS WELL- THE FACT
THAT- IT'S ENOUGH OF A
POSSIBILITY THAT MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FEEL COMPELLED. TO
ACTUALLY- PUT THEIR STUDENTS AND
STAFF. THROUGH THESE DRILLS.
THAT THAT THAT THE POSSIBILITY
OF AN EVENT LIKE THAT HAPPENING
IS SUFFICIET THAT THAT WOULD
HAPPEN THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO
DO THAT. SO YOU KNOW I THINK I
DO- AND I. THAT YOU KNOW. I
THINK THAT- CERTAINLY HEAR YOUR
COMMITMENT I KNOW YOU'VE SORT OF
GIVEN BEFORE READING I GIVE IT
AGAIN YOU'RE CLOSE TO CONTINUE
WORK WITH THE- WITH THE I GUESS
THE OPPOSITION AND ALSO. PEOPLE
EARNESTLY POSE RIGHT NOW BUT ARE
LOOKING FORWARD. I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF MOVING PARTS OF THIS
AND YOU KNOW WHO'S WHO TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COLLECTING WHICH
DATA AND TRACKING AND SO FORTH.
AND I'M SURE YOU'LL BE WORKING
ON THIS- SO- BUT I THINK THAT
THIS IS THE FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE- WHICH GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON THIS. AND
CERTAINLY WANT TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS BY THE TIME HE SHOWS UP
ON THE FLOOR AND ALL OF US WILL
BE EXPECTED TO CAST ANOTHER VOTE
ON THIS BILL AND- SEE TO WHAT
RESOLUTION YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO. BRING THIS BILL TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS OF THE FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOOD WILL WHO
WENT TO- TRY TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM BUT ALSO- YEAH. I
UNDERSTAND THAT- THERE THERE MAY
BE ISSUES THAT ALSO NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED IF WHEN I DO THIS
CORRECTLY. SO CERTAINLY WITH
THAT- I CERTAINLY GIVE YOU THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO AND- AND
APPRECIATE- YOU BRING THIS BILL
FORD- AND- LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
CONTINUED WORK ON IT THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU SENATOR PAN. CENTER
CORTESE. SO THINK ABOUT YOUR- OF
YOUR- ONE OF. THE FOR. TWO
MINUTES BODY OF WORK THAT I'VE
SEEN EVEN IN MY TIME HERE SHORT
RELATIVELY SHORT TIME YEAR
ROUND. OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES-
THAT'S NOT THIS BILL- THE END IF
IT WAS THIS BILL THAT WAS THE
APPROACH THAT WAS BEING TAKEN-
YOU KNOW PERIPHERALS THROUGH
WELLNESS CENTERS AND SCHOOLS
THAT WERE WERE WORKING SO HARD
TO FIND ESTABLISH OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT- I CERTAINLY WOULD
APPROACH IT MUCH DIFFERENTLY MY-
CONCERNS. WHICH ARE. VERY VERY
DEEP AND- REALLY RUN TO THE
COURT OF- OF. YOU KNOW MY
IDEOLOGY ROAD CIVIL LIBERTIES
ARE ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS. OF A PARTICULAR- I
WOULD SAY THESE ARE THE ONLY
AREAS OF CONCERN IF THEY WERE
THE- THERE ARE OTHER AREAS OF
CONCERN THAT I WOULD OTHERWISE
PROBABLY BE HAPPY TO SHARE WITH
THE AUTHOR IN. S. GOOD YOU KNOW-
THERE'S A COUPLE COLLEAGUES OF
THE PEOPLE WHO THE BILL ON BUT I
CAN'T DO THAT WITH SECTIONS LIKE
THIRTEEN A AND B. IN THE BILL.
OF THOSE GOES SO FAR BEYOND- MY. CORE BELIEFS IN CIVIL
LIBERTIES- THE I JUST CAN'T
ASSOCIATE AND I VOTE WITH THOSE
SECTIONS IN A I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN WHAT I WOULD DESCRIBE AS- A
NOT A TYPICAL A NOT UNCOMMON
SCRAMBLE THE LAST FEW DAYS TO
TRY TO WORK OUT SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES ON THE BILL BUT WE'RE
STILL HERE TODAY WITHOUT THEM A
DELETED OR WORKED OUT YOU KNOW
AND IT'S NOT IT'S ALSO WILL BE
ARMY WHO SEE THIS YOU KNOW WITH
RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR TO SAY.
YOU KNOW WILL TAKE UP TWO THIRDS
OF- SECTION OF YOUR BILL LEAVE
ONE THIRD LEFT LIKE THE
EDUCATION ON. COMPONENT HERE IN
THIRTEEN C. WHICH IS
OUTSTANDING. YOU KNOW SOMETHING
I COULD SUPPORT- BUT IT'S NOT UP
TO ME TO SAY TO GOT TO THIRDS OF
YOUR BILL AND LEAVE THAT IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE SOMETHING THAT
WAS PRESENTED I THINK TO ME AS-
YOU KNOW THAT THE DIRECTION IT
WAS GOING. CONJUNCTION WITH THIS
COMMITTEE OR THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
OF IN TERMS OF SOME WRITTEN
AMENDMENT SO- I'M SURE IS
DISAPPOINTING AS I'M SURE- THAT
SOUNDS TO. CENTER PORTANTINO TO
YOU BOTH IN A WORKING VERY HARD
ON THIS I KNOW THAT BECAUSE OF
CONVERSATIONS LAST FEW DAYS.
AGAIN I HOPE YOU RESPECT THE
FACT THAT- YOU KNOW THERE'S
CERTAIN PRINCIPLES I JUST CAN'T
CROSS- YOU KNOW. IN SLEEP AT
NIGHT IN TERMS OF MY OWN SENSE
OF CIVIL CIVIL LIBERTIES ON THE
BILL- SO I'M GONNA SPEAK STAIN
OFF TODAY. THANK YOU.
THINKCENTRE CORTESE THANK YOU TO
ALL OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. US
SENATOR PORTANTINO I TOO AM
OPPOSING THE BILL I WE HAVE NOT
HEARD FROM ANY SCHOOLS OR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OR SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
WHO WANT TO BE TASKED WITH
COLLECTING INFORMATION FROM
PARENTS ABOUT THE POSSESSION OF
THE FIREARMS. I'M GLAD THAT
YOU'RE OPEN TO ADDRESSING
CONCERNS FROM THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE BUT WE'RE VOTING ON
THE BILL BEFORE US TODAY. I
CANNOT SUPPORT A REQUIREMENT
THAT SCHOOLS INTERJECT
THEMSELVES INTO ISSUES. BEST
LOVE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE OR OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SCHOOLS ARE
STRETCHED THIN ON ON MANDATE
FROM US HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ARE STRESSED
OUT AND EXHAUSTED. THEY'RE JUST
TRYING TO HANG ON TO THE BEST
THEY CAN FOR OUR STUDENTS AND
THIS IS ONE MORE BURDEN. I
CANNOT SUPPORT A REQUIREMENT
THAT STUDENTS BE INVESTIGATED
FOR DISOBEDIENCE OF SCHOOL
RULES. WE HAVE SEEN THE DAMAGE
THAT OUR ZERO TOLERANCE APPROACH
HAS PERPETRATED. MORE LONG FIRST
FORSMAN AND LESS DISCRETION FOR
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES WHO KNOW THEIR
STUDENTS BEST CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
WILL BE HEARING A BILL LATER
TODAY BY SENATOR BRADFORD THAT
REMOVES MANY REQUIREMENTS FOR
MANDATORY REPORTING TO LAW
ENFORCEMET WHILE LEAVING THAT
DISCRETION TO EACH SITUATION. WE
ALL WANT TO ENSURE SCHOOLS ARE
SAFE AND TO PREVENT HORRIFIC
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS THERE'S NO
QUESTION THERE. I BELIEVE A
BETTER APPROACH IS BY ADDRESSING
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH AND I
THINK YOU'VE HEARD THAT FROM
ALMOST ALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TODAY. YOU YOURSELF ARE CARRYING
SEVERAL BILLS A MENTAL HEALTH
BECAUSE YOU KNOW HOW CRITICAL IT
IS THAT WE HELP STUDENTS
FAMILIES. AND SCHOOLS NAVIGATE
TRAUMA AND HARDSHIPS. WE SHOULD
PRIOR TO PRIORITIZE AND FUND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH AND COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS TO ADDRESS STUDENTS
UNDERLYING NEEDS. AND TO ENSURE
SCHOOLS ARE SAFE WELCOMING AND
INCLUSIVE FOR ALL STUDENTS. THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE BUT
THIS BILL IS NOT THE ANSWER I
WILL BE VOTING NOW. MISTER
PORTANTINO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE DO SO. I WOULD
THINK THAT. THANK YOU FOR THIS
ROBUST CONVERSATION- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO SEE IF THE
BILL COULD MOVE TODAY- AS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM A NUMBER THE
STAKEHOLDERS WE ARE WORKING IN
GOOD FAITH TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS I BELIEVE WE'LL GET
THERE I BELIEVE MUCH OF THE
STATE'S SOFT OPPOSITION WILL BE
RELIEVED- WHEN WE DO- TYPICALLY
DURING THE FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE. YOU KNOW WE WOULD BE
PRESENTED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
CONSIDER AND WE CONSIDER WHETHER
WE WANT TO TAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS
OR NOT I WAS HOPING TO HAVE THAT
WHICH IS WHY I'VE BEEN DEALING
INDIVIDUALLY WITH A LOT OF IT
THE INSTITUTIONS- AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID- NO ONE
WANTS TO READ ABOUT A TRAGEDY IN
THE PAPER. NOBODY WANTS TO. READ
AND I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT THOSE
FOLKS IN MICHIGAN OR THINKING
ABOUT TODAY'S THINKING IF I
WOULD HAVE COULD WE HAVE SAVED A
LIFE. WELL YOU NEVER KNOW IF YOU
SAVE A LIFE. BUT YOU KNOW DEEP
IN YOUR HEART THAT IF YOU DO
EVERYTHING YOU CAN. YOU WILL.
AND SO WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK. TO HAVE THIS
BILL MOVE TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE
SO WE CAN ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
WHICH ARE LEGITIMATE. AND WE
SAID ALL ALONG WE'RE HAPPY TO
ADDRESS THEM- SO WITHOUT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
DON'T. THINK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO. MEN CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE S. B. NINE ZERO SIX
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THAT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
LEYVA NO. LEYVA NO OTRO ABOVE.
PARTISI NOT VOTING. KELLY KELLY
NO GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE CAN
I CAN I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON
CALL FOR OUR ONE MISSING MISSING
MEMBER THANK. ALL RIGHT TO
EVERYONE WATCHING WE NEED AN
AUTHOR I AM LOOKING FOR SENATOR
BAKER SKINNER LA MON JONES
BRADFORD GLAZER DOLLY MISTER
DOLLY WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
YOUR BILL- YEAH I SAW YOU TO
ISRAEL SORRY ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO A CENTER GLAZER
FIRST SENATE ALL JUST BECAUSE HE
IS THE PERSON FILE ORDER. AND I
FORGOT ABOUT- CENTER BACKER.
LIEUTENANT THE LAST SECOND ALL
RIGHT SENATOR BAKER WHEN YOU'RE
READY WE WILL HEAR FIRST SB
EIGHT SEVEN SIX AND THEN S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING
MANAGER MEMBERS. LAST YEAR I
AUTHORED SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN. TO
CREATE THE DIGITAL EDUCATION
EQUITY PROGRAM. WHICH THIS
COMMITTEE PASSED IN A BIPARTISAN
VOTE. INSPIRATIONS YOU AGAIN IN
SB EIGHT SEVEN SIX IS EDUCATION
TECHNOLOGY IS ESSENTIAL FOR OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE DIGITAL
AGE. AND WHICH REALLY CENTRO
THAT EDUCATORS HAVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO MAKE USE OF THE
BEST TECHNOLOGY WHEN POSSIBLE.
AND THIS NEED IS NOT GOING AWAY
AT WORK UNFORTUNATELY PASSAGE
TOMB HOUSING CLASSROOMS FOR NOW
BUT I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
IT'S CRITICAL TO EDUCATORS BE
EDUCATED. THEMSELVES IN THE BEST
WAY TO USE TECHNOLOGY IN MANY
SCHOOLS THEY LACK ACCESS TO
SUFFICIENT INFORMATION
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT CONCERT
WITH PLAN FOR EMPLOYMENT CURRENT
AND EMERGING TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT
INSTRUCTION. WITH ACCORDING TO
STATE AND REGIONAL FOCUS ON
POLICY PROGRAMS AND FUNDING MANY
DISTRICTS DO NOT HAVE EQUAL
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY AND
RESOURCES. UP TO SELECT ACCESS
IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGY QUESTIONS
EFFECTIVELY AND PROVIDE STUDENTS
ACCESS TO THESE RESOURCES- FROM
HOMES. SO THIS IS STEP TOWARD
CLOSING DIVIDE IN OUR SCHOOLS
THE BILL IS COSPONSORED BY
VARIOUS COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. AND RECEIVE NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION THANK YOU
EXPECTWE URGE AND I THOUGHT
THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER ARE IT
WILL GO TO YOUR LEAD SUPPORT. OF
BARBARA NEMCO AND THEN LAURIE
OWENS LADIES YOU WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH WE WILL START WITH
MS NEMCO PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I'M BARBARA THEM COLORS AND
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
IN NAPA FOR THE LAST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT
AS A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC OUR
KIDS ARE BEHIND ME. AND WE HAVE
ALSO LEARNED THAT TECHNOLOGY CAN
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN HELPING
TO ACCELERATE THEIR LEARNING. IN
GAUGING ITS INTERACTIVE IT CAN
BE PERSONALIZED ACCORDING TO
STUDENT INTERESTS AND ALSO
ACCORDING TO THEIR READING LEVEL
AND THEIR LANGUAGE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT FEATURED KANSU.
WE HAVE AND WE THANK YOU YOU
HAVE GIVEN US MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR TECHNOLOGY AND WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL AND VERY
APPRECIATIVE. BUT REMEMBER THAT
TECHNOLOGY NEEDS A VERY
COMPETENT TEACHERS TO MAXIMIZE
ITS ABILITY TEACHERS ARE USING
EVERYTHING YOU'VE GIVEN US BUT
SOME TEACHERS ARE MUCH MORE
ADEPT AT THIS THAN OTHERS AND
THE RIVER IF THE ROAD IN THE
CLASSROOM CAN THE CLASSROOM
TEACHER USE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
ITS MAXIMUM ABILITY. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY TEACHER HAS ACCESS TO THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THAT
WILL ENSURE THAT THEY CAN DO
JUST THAT. WE WANT THEM TO BE
ABLE TO REALLY USE ALL THE MONEY
AND TECHNOLOGY THAT YOU SENT US
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN REALLY
ACCELERATE OUR STUDENTS LEARNING
MAKE THEM GAUGED IN THAT MAKE
THEM EXCITED ABOUT THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY CAN DO THAT. I URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU MS NEMCO. MS OWNS
EUROPE NEXT. MS OWNS ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. YES I AM I'M SORRY THE
NINETY. WE SURE CAN'T ALREADY
HAD. THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
LAURIE OWENS AND I'M THE CHIEF
TECHNOLOGY OFFICER FOR THE
CEMETERY- COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN MY TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS AS AN EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGIST I'VE LEARNED THAT
THERE ARE FOUR CRITICAL
COMPONENTS TO ENSURE THE
SUCCESSFUL USE TECHNOLOGY IN THE
CLASSROOM YOUR APPROPRIATE
DEVICES APPROPRIATE SOFTWARE
ROBUST BAND WITH AND TRADED
SUPPORTED TEACHERS. OF SB SEVEN
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX PROVIDE AVENUE
TO ENSURE EVERY TEACHER BOTH
FROM UNDER REPRESENTED OR UNDER
RESOURCE POOL AS WELL AS THOSE
WITH THE APPROPRIATE RESOURCES
AS WELL AS ADMINISTRATORS AND
OTHER RELATED STAFF MEMBERS HAVE
THE TRAINING AND ONGOING SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED TO USE THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT THEY PROVIDED TO
THEM TO ENHANCE LEARNING
EXPERIENCES. OF OUR STUDENTS THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IS ONE OF THE
ENTHUSIASTIC BOTH SPONSORS OF SB
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX AND WE HOPE
THAT WE HAVE YOUR SUPPORT AS
WELL ASKING YOU FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY PLEASE
COME RIGHT UP. STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
PLEASE HI MY NAME'S MARK EPSTEIN
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL TECHNOLOGY
EDUCATION NETWORK AND SUPPORTING
THIS WITH SOME APPREHENSION
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
EFFECTIVENESS IN THIS ROUND BY
BOTH THE DEPARTMENT AND COUNTY
AT OFFICES OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
WE BRING IN A IN A PRIMARY WITH
THE CSU SYSTEM. BECAUSE OF THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND STAFFING DEALING
WITH EMERGING TECHNOLOGY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE HAD MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS NICK ROAMING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA I. T. IN
EDUCATION PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED. SEEING NO ONE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE BRING
UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR. SB EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX. THANK MEDICARE YEAH
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF ITS P.
EIGHT SEVEN SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO WITH THE STORY. AND WITH
LITTLE WIND ONE NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING- I'M NOT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND
I'M A PART OF IT I ALTHOUGH I DO
pTHERE WAS A LOT OF CHILDREN THAT
WERE. ON YOUR OTHER DEVICES A
LOT AND GOT HIM WITH A LOT OF GO
THREE GREAT GOING UP. AND A LOT
OF EXTRACT THAT- SENATOR CAN
HAVE ON. ALSO WITH BOTH OF HIS
ARMS. HI GUYS ILLEGAL BILLS THAT
HE THOUGHT WORK- MAIL I JUST
MA'AM IF YOU WRITE IT YOUR NAME
ON SUPPORT FOR THE BILL PLEASE.
ARE YOU READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FRAZIER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IN THE
AMERICAN JOURNAL FOR THEIR
CLIENTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION IS THEY
WANT ANYONE HERE TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE THE
BILL. SEEING NO ONE YES COME
RIGHT FOR MA'AM. STEP RIGHT UP
THE STREET YES. YOU TELL ME OKAY
OKAY- SENSORS NO LEAD UP
OPPOSITION I'LL GIVE YOU TWO
MINUTES WELL THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME MY NAME IS LISA DESSE
BRO I AM A CONTRA COSTA PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER OF OVER THIRTY
FOUR YEARS- I TAUGHT IN MANY OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS HERE IN THE
COUNTY AND- I ALSO. EXPERIENCED
COVERED AS A KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER FROM MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO JUN AND THEN ALL OF
LAST YEAR- WITH KINDERGARTNERS
AND SO YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
DIFFICULTY OF DEALING WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN TECHNOLOGY AND DISTANCE
YEAH I'M I'M A VERY SKILLED
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER I'M
BILINGUAL I CAN TEACH KIDS TO
READ IN BOTH LANGUAGES IN THE
SCHOOL YEAR. AND THE ENORMOUS. I
DEFICIT FROM RELYING ON
TECHNOLOGY CANNOT BE OVERSTATED.
WHAT WAS MISSING WAS HANDS ON
WHAT WAS MISSING WAS PERSONAL
INTERACTION I JUST LIKE TO-
EMPHASIZE AND GOING TO PUT MY
HAND OVER MY MOUTH AS- I IMITATE
A MAST. TEACHER NOR- FOOL. WHAT
I JUST SAID IS NOW THE SOUND
YOU'RE HEARING IS AT AN APPLE.
IN A CLASSROOM FOR PRIMARY
STUDENTS WHERE ORAL LANGUAGE IS
ESSENTIAL YOU NEED TO HEAR AND
SEE YOU NEED ALL THE SUPPORT
SYSTEMS TO BE FUNCTIONING AT
MAXIMUM CAPACITY SO THAT YOUR
ENGLISH LEARNERS EVEN YOU'RE
VERY FLUENT STUDENTS CAN. LEARN
THIS NEW WAY OF THINKING ABOUT
LANGUAGE AND EXPRESSION AND
COMMUNICATION AND THE RELIANCE
ON TECHNOLOGY. IS OVERSHADOWING
ALL THESE VERY VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TOOLS THAT WE HAVE
USED FOR YOUR YOUR TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME FOR ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
ROUTE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WHICH
IS TO OPPOSE SEE NO ONE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE
WHO WHICH IT WISHES TO EXPRESS
OUR OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE. THANK YOU IN
FOR A LOT OF THE PHONE IF YOU'RE
IN A POSITION OF SB EIGHT SEVEN
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN
THE LITTLE LINE ONE TWENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HERE HI AGAIN
THIS. AS BOB PARKER COUNTY
RESIDENT. AND MEMBER OF THE
FREEDOM COALITION AND PLASTER
COUNTY. MOTHER OF TWO I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO ECHO- A LOT OF THE
POINT THAT THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
JUST MADE- I THINK. WE NEED TO
REALLY CONSIDER DYNASTY MANAGED
TARIAN IS AND THAT YOU CAN ONLY
GET FROM. US FROM TOUCH AND IN
FULL VISION. OF PEOPLE OF FACIAL
EXPRESSIONS THAT. IT GOING NOW
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. GO
TO LINE ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINES OPEN. BY ONE EIGHTY
SIX YOU ARE HELLO. PLEASE YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL RIGHT-
GET OUT GOOD MORNING CHALLENGER
MEMBERS MAINLY MY NAME IS
SHERLOCK JIM CALLING FROM BUDGET
COUNTY- I BELIEVE THAT. MA'AM DO
YOU MEMBER OF TRIPLE MA'AM DO
YOU TO OPPOSE THAT BILL WHICH
YEAH WE JUST NEED YOUR NAME AND
IF YOU OPPOSE THE BILL PLEASE.
OH I'M SORRY- MY NAME IS RON A
LOT AND I AM AND STRONG
OPPOSITION THEY'LL GRADING
FIGURE BECAUSE I THINK IT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IN
MEDICARE ONE MOMENT WE HAVE ONE
LINE COMEDIAN. AND LITTLE WIND
TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS MOVE THE LOCUS
OPERAS I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND THE NRA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. AND AGAIN
MEDICARE WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE
COMING IN BE JUST ONE MOMENT.
AND WE WILL LINE TWO OH ONE TWO
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
THEY'VE TAKEN SOME SEVENTY Q.
OUT MEDICARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR OKAY WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS SENATOR
DOLLY. JUST REAL QUICK SO IS
THIS. PART OF FUNDS COMING OUT
OF PROP NINETY EIGHT OR IS THIS
COMING OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND.
BUT WILL BE OUT OF THE ADDRESS I
WANNA JUST COMMENTS WERE MADE
EARLIER BUT MAYBE I'LL DO THAT
IN MY CLOTHES RESPONSE PACIFIC
WHICH YOUR QUESTION THEY SHOULD
BE GENERAL FUND OUT THIS IS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
RIGHT NOW THE BASE HAVE ONE
PERSON WHOSE JOB IT IS. TO HELP
. ALL SCHOOLS IN OUR STATE YOUR
TECHNOLOGY AND SO SOME COUNTIES
HAVE FULL TIME. BUT PEOPLE WHO
DEAL WITH TECHNOLOGY IN THE
CLASSROOM. AND A LOT OF COUNTY
ESPECIALLY RURAL COUNTIES ARE
INNER CITY COUNTIES DON'T HAVE
ANYONE TO WORK EFFECTIVELY WITH
TEACHERS. IN TECHNOLOGYSO THIS
WOULD BE TO FIND. A STAFF AT THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION. TO ASSIST
IN THESE REGIONAL TECHNOLOGY
CLUSTERS. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
CENTER PAM. HI THANK YOU- CENTER
BACKER FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT-
PRIOR TO CO BID- THAT TO
ACTUALLY- NOR TO PROVE ACCESS TO
EDUCATION- WE DID WANT- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE BETTER ACCESS TO.
TECHNOLOGY TWO PEOPLE ARE
SKILLED TECHNOLOGY AND USING
TECHNOLOGY TO HELP ENHANCE
EDUCATION WHETHER. IT'S IN THE
CLASSROOM OR EVEN IF THERE'S
DISTANCE CERTAINLY GOT COVERED-
HAS. EMPHASIZED- THE- YEAH ALL
THE CHALLENGES AND THE NEEDS OF-
DOING SOME DISTANCE LEARNING I
THINK WE ARE WE WORK VERY HARD
TO GET STUDENTS IN PERSON
UNFORTUNATELY THEY'RE ALSO
FAMILIES OUT THERE WHO. YOU KNOW
WHETHER THE CHILD IS- I DON'T
HAVE CHRONIC CONDITION HOW TO
PUT THEM AT RISK OR THEY HAVE
SOMEONE EMILY WHO IS. AS WELL
WHO- MAY DESIRE OUR OUR OUR OUR
NATION DESIRES AND RIGHT WORD-
THE- THE FEEL CHALLENGE THAT IF
THE SCHOOLS NOT SAFE ENOUGH THEY
CAN'T SEND THEIR CHILD TO SCHOOL
AND POTENTIALLY HARM SOMEONE OR
HOUSEHOLDS SO. MAYBE LOOKING AT
DISTANCE OPTIONS UNLESS THE
SCHOOLS TAKES STEPS TO ENSURE IT
SCHOOLS ARE SAFER SO- BUT
CERTAINLY YOUR BILL IS ABOUT
JUST. ENSURING THAT SCHOOLS HAVE
ACCESS. TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
SKILLED. TO ASSIST THEM FOR
WHATEVER TECHNOLOGICAL ISSUES
THE WISH TO ADDRESS I BELIEVE
SO- SO I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR SCHOOLS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND-
CERTAINLY- I'M IN SUPPORT AND
WILL BE MOVING AND I WISH TO
MOVE TO BUILT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR PAN ANYONE
ELSE. ALL RIGHT CENTER BIGGER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH
JUST MAKE TWO POINTS FIRST THANK
YOU- TOUCH PEN FOR YOUR-
COMMENTS AND THIS REALLY. SO
FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS AGO WE
ACTUALLY DID HAVE THESE REGIONAL
CLUSTERS WHERE WE'D- ON A
REGIONAL BASIS TRAIN TEACHERS
AND TECHNOLOGY. THE ONLY MOVED
TO L. C. F. F. WE GOT RID OF A
LOT OF PROGRAMS AND BY LARGEST
YOU MIND WAS POSITIVE BUT WE
LOST SOME THINGS. THAT WERE ALSO
POSITIVE LIKE THIS REGIONAL
STRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE TO REALLY
THIS IS ACTUALLY PUTTING IN
PLACE. WHAT WE HAD BEFORE TO- TO
EDUCATE TEACHERS AND TO THAT
POINT AND THE POINT I DON'T YOU
THROUGH ANYTHING THAT THE
SPEAKER IN THE- IN THE ROOM SAID
AND PEOPLE KNOW I'VE FOUGHT HARD
TO GET. THE KIDS BACK IN SCHOOLS
IS REALLY NOT ABOUT DISAPPOINTED
NOT TO SINCE LEARNING THIS IS
REALLY THE WHOLE SUITE OF
EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY- NOW AS
ANYONE WHO HAS KIDS- THAT YOU
REALIZE WHETHER IT'S INTERACTING
HOW TO UPLOAD THINGS AND- DEAL
EFFECTIVELY WITH CLASSROOM
MANAGEMENT AND HOMEWORK AND ALL
THAT PIECE- TO- THINGS THAT
PEOPLE MIGHT WANT TO USE IN THE
CLASSROOM TO A LEARNING- THIS IS
NOT. ABOUT REPLACING- IN PERSON
LEARNING AT ALL SO WITHOUT A
ACTUALLY ASK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THIS BILL A CENTERPIECE
THANK YOU BILLS MOVE BY SENATOR
PER MEMBERS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
I NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT SEVENTY
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA HI LEYVA AUDIO TO ABODE.
COURTESY I PROTECT THE AYE DOLLY
AYE DALY AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN HI. CAN
I. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DO
HAVE ONE COMMITTEE MEMBER
MISSING SO WE'LL KEEP IT ON CALL
CENTRE BAKER THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED TO SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU. FOR THAT THANK YOU MANAGER
MEMBERS THAT HAVE NOW PRESENTED
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE.AND THANK
YOU VENTURE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND OTHERS WITH ALL THE WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE A CHILD CARE
LAST COUPLE YEARS. THE IN THIS
BODY. AT THIS BILL WE WILL VISIT
IN APRIL ONE IN CHILD NUTRITION
THE PROVIDE TWO FREE MEALS TO
ALL CHILDREN AT DAYCARE AND
PRESCHOOL FACILITIES. THAT ABIDE
BY THE FEDERAL CA CFP STANDARDS.
BILL ALSO ELIMINATES THE STATE
MEAL REIMBURSEMENT PAY PENALTY
THEY CURRENTLY ONLY REIMBURSES
UP TO SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. OF
THE TOTAL ANNUAL COST. TRUCKERS
A LARGE SITTING SUPPORT ACCESS
TO NUTRITIOUS FOODS FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN. WERE THE CRIMINAL
REIMBURSEMENT STRUCTURE AT LEAST
FAMILIES INVITED TO MAKE UP THE
COST DIFFERENCE AS- AMOUNTING TO
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE TO THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. AND
THAT IMPACTS DISPROPORTIONATELY
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS. AND THE
CONTINUE PERPETUATE A STRUCTURE
THAT UNDERVALUES UNDERPAID LABOR
PERFORMED BY BLACK LATINO
IMMIGRANT WOMEN. PRIMARILY WHAT
ISSUES OF FOOD INSECURITY MY
CALIFORNIA'S HONEST LOOK AT
LEARNERS PREDATE THE COVERED
PANDEMIC. THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ALSO EXPOSED THE
WEAKNESSES AND WHITE IN THE GAPS
IN OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM. ALL
CARE PROVIDERS SCRAMBLE TO FEED
EVEN HUNGER KIDS ARE STRUGGLING
WITH INCREASED FOOD COSTS
LIMITED SUPPLIES IT CONSISTENT
ROMAN AND INADEQUATE SUPPORT FOR
THE STATE. TO THIS PROVIDES A
METHOD TO REDUCE CHILDHOOD
HUNGER IN SHORT CHILDREN HAVE
ACCESS TO NUTRITIOUS FOOD. AS
WELL CURRENTLY STANDS FAMILY FOR
MAKE QUALIFY FOR STATE
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE BUT NOT
FREE OR REDUCED MEALS. FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. THIS LEGISLATION WILL
ENSURE THAT FINANCIAL NEED TO
ACCURATELY REPRESENTED FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND ELIMINATE
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO FOOD AND
CHILD CARE. AND WITH ME TO
TESTIFY- LISA MARCY FROM CHURCH
THE CHILD DAYCARE IN FONTANA AND
SAMANTHA MARSHALL THE CHILD AND
ADULT CARE FOOD PROGRAM ROUND
TABLE. GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BOTH OF YOUR LEAD SUPPORT
ARE CALLING IN SO WE WILL GO TO
MS MARSHALL FIRST YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
CLEARLY THAT AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I AM MATT MATT THE
MARSHALL WITH THE PREVIOUS YEAR
ON CABLE. WE'RE PROBABLY BECAUSE
I'M VERY SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE.
THANK YOU THOUGHT ABOUT FOR FEAR
LEADERSHIP ON AT FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE. I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU.
FOR COSTS AND THE BATTLE
CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO FACE
ELEVATED LEVELS OF HUNGER AND
HARDSHIP. ACCORDING TO A RECENT.
SURVEY THREE AND FOUR
CALIFORNIANS WITH LOW OR
MODERATE INCOME WORRIED ABOUT
AFFORDING ENOUGH FOOD IN THE
PAST YEAR. AND THREE OUT OF FIVE
ACTUALLY GET THEM OUT OF. SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE MAKES LONG
OVERDUE TRANSFORMATIVE
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE YOUNG
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE. IT WILL BRING
EQUITY ARE TRANSITION PROGRAMS
BY ENSURING. FREE EMAIL FOR ALL
CHILDREN IN CHILD CARE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE OUTDATED AND
RACIST MIELKE PENALTY. AN
ADEQUATE SUPPORT FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO RAMP UP
PARTICIPATION IN THE STATE IF
YOU. HAPPEN TO THE POWER OF THE
COMBINED FEDERAL AND STATE
HEALTH CARE CARE NUTRITION
PROGRAMS. SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE
BROADRIDGE'S EXISTING YET
FEDERAL MEAL REIMBURSEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE. THROUGH THE
CALENDAR CARE THE PROGRAM. IS
DOUBLE FEDERAL RULES AND
REIMBURSEMENTS DO NOT MEET THE
NEED IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
EVERYTHING IS MORE EXPENSIVE
INCLUDING THE COFFIN. ON THE
HEELS OF A SIMILAR POLICY FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE PEOPLE FOR
CALIFORNIA THE LEADER IN
ENSURING EVERY STUDENT HAS TO
FREE MEALS EACH SCHOOL DAY. SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE AFTER THE-
PROVIDE A SUPPLEMENTAL
REIMBURSEMENT TO SUPPORT CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND ENSURING. THE
SAME. SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE IS
NOT A MANDATE AND AN INCENTIVE
TO PARTICIPATE IN A PROGRAM. FOR
HEALTHY MEALS- FOR FREE FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN. WE APPRECIATE
THE INVESTMENT IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO STATE BUDGET TO
RESTORE THE SMALL EIGHT MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT BUT WITH COTTON.
TWELVE HOWEVER ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IS NEEDED TO ADEQUATELY
COMPENSATE PROVIDERS FOR THE
MEALS THEY SERVE. AT THREE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE WOULD BRING
PARITY BETWEEN COLONIAL AND
HEALTHCARE MALES BUT LIMITING
THE FEET PENALTY. THAT IS PLACED
ON CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. WITH SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE CALIFORNIA
HAS THE POWER TO FILL THE GAP IN
AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO HEALTHY
MEALS. AND CHILD CARE. CANCEL
THE LADY OF THE CHILD CARE WORK
FOR. THANK YOU FOR THE UP. TO
TODAY I'M HAPPY TO ANY QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU WELL NOW TO MS DS
MISTER IS YOU HAVE TO MINUTES
OFF. THANK YOU MORNING AND THANK
HERE. CHAIRED LEYVA AND MA'AM OF
THE- I'M MORE. WITH THE CHILD
CARE HOME A MOMENT JOHN. ARE
THAT UNLIKE WILL DISTRICTS WHO
ARE SCHOOL- FIVE THE CHILDREN
WITH HIM GO BACK TO THE AND A
HALF HOURS DAY- SOME CHILDREN
MIGHT BE ARE PRESENT UP TO NOW A
- IN THE ALLEY WE SERVE RIGHT
DANCE GAMES NOT LUNCH IN FACT
AND DINNER. SOMETIME ADDITIONAL
BACK WHEN THEY GET THE TEMPLATE
OF EXAMPLE GRAY AWRY AT EIGHT AM
HE THESE ARE SIXTY AT TWO THIRTY
HERE ALREADY FOR A. M. AND
FRANKLY. WHICH IS WHAT I WOULD
PARTIALLY REMEMBER FOR COMING UP
IN ONE SNACK I AM YOU OF THE
COMMITTEE AS A GROWN INSTAGRAM.
OF WOULD YOU WITH PM SNACK AND
FROM THIRTY UNTIL HE GETS PICKED
UP SIX. FOR THE LAW THIRTEEN
YEAR I HAD EATING ALL THE
CHILDREN ALL MEALS WE GOT OF
YOUR PERSONS I THINK FINANCIAL
LOSS AB BECAUSE I'M A MOM OF
FOUR AND YOUR PARTICULAR. THREE
TRISH EQUALLY DURING THE PROGRAM
I WE OUR CARES FIGHT REMAINED
BEYOND TIME ENROLLMENT. FOOD
PRICES WENT UP AND IT WAS
DIFFICULT TO EITHER FIND I SAID
IN MY LONG. AND MAJOR. APPROVED
HOURS IN THE RAIN HOPING TO BUY
A BREAD AND PP WE EXPERIENCE
GREAT PRICE GOUGING FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY OF TO SIXTY.
FIFTY YEAR AND EXPENSIVE SO IN
SUMMARY THE MOMENT BECAUSE GOOD
PRICE WILL PLEASE NEIL A BIRTH
MISTER. COPYRIGHT FINANCIAL
LITERACY LOS WE COULDN'T AFFORD
CLOSE BECAUSE CLOSE WE WILL
MEMBERS OF WE WORK FOR TO DIP
INTO HUSBAND INCOME TO
SUPPLEMENT THE EXPENSES.
MARKET GREAT WITH- THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU FOR TESTIFYING
ALL RIGHT WELL THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE HERE
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE. SEEING NO-
WE NEED TO GO TO SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINES SORRY PERINEAL MORE
CAFFEINE THIS MORNING SO BEFORE
WE GO TO OPPOSITION LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINES MISTER MODERATOR
AND WE CAN ALSO GO TO ANYONE IN
SUPPORT HERE IN TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED. SEEING NO ONE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE LINES
FOR SUPPORT. FOR SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU MEDICARE
TO GET YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ADELINE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING
KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS DONNA
HOFFMAN CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF
COUNCIL FIRST ON AMERICA MISSION
READINESS. READY NATION AND
FIGHT CRIME INVESTING KIDS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALL PLEASE. WE'LL WIND UP ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND SUPPORTED
SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. IN WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO ZERO FIVE TWO OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND MEDICARE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MATT DAVISON
ON BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO MARIN
FOOD BANK I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. INEXORABLY NO ONE
SEVENTY FIVE PEOPLE AT. GOOD
MORNING THIS YEAR AT ALL WITH
YOUR IRIS CALIFORNIA STARTED
COSPONSORED AND INSTRUCTOR FOR
THANKS THANK YOU. AND THAT'S ONE
ONE ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MEAN THEY NEED R. E. M.
SENATE ALLEN TO BE HELD BACK
FROM CARPET BARLEY WE ARE
CALLING FOR. FIFTY FOUR EIGHTY.
THE YOU. THE NEXT ONE TO ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CRIMINALIZED OVER THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL GO TO BLIND AT ONE
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING KAMALA HARRIS FOR
THE FOLKS WHO STANDS ON BEHALF
OF THE SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WILL LINE TWO TWO ONE
ZERO ELIZABETH. HELLO MY NAME IS
MARIE SHE'S MEDINA AND CALLING
WITH THE SINGLE PAYER CUSHION
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORTER SB
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THIS WILL WIND
ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LIFE IS
OFTEN. ONE ONE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M BOB
BURLINGTON THE BANK OF CONTRA
COSTA AND SOLANO WE ARE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING NINE BASKET WHY IT WOULD
POLICY CARE FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES DOCTOR NETWORK
SUPPORTED SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE. REIMBURSEMENTS NEED TO BE
INCREASING GRANT TO BE OFFERED
SO IT MORE THANK YOU WRITERS
WILL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IT WILL
LINES- TO LEGAL. WHY DO YOU DO
DO ALL TO YOURSELF THAT. IF WE
WILL MOVE ON WE HAVE ONE MORE
LIKE COMMITTED TO BE JUST ONE
MOMENT.
IT YOU GO TO LINE TWO TWENTY TWO
TWO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
TWENTY WHAT IS OFTEN. IT
MEDICARE AND NO FURTHER LINES IN
SUPPORT OF THE SENATE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW
GO TO OPPOSITION AS I STATED
EARLIER THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE WHO
OPPOSES THE BILL HERE IN TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED SEE NO ONE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO APPLY
OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE.
THANK YOU MEDICARE'S LADIES
DON'T FEAR IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND MEDICARE A LOT IF YOU
MOMENT- DON'T WANT TO THE
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WILL NOT
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. WITH THE BILL CENTER
PANNED THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
SURVISCOR WHICH LED TO CLOSE
RESPECT RESTAURANT I VOTE VERY
GOOD THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN AM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I THEM NUMBER
THREE SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES LEYVA HI. LEYVA
ABOVE. COURTESY HI COURTESY I
DAILY. DAILY AYE GLAZER AYE
FREEZER AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE
PAN HI CAN I. VERY GOOD THAT
BILL IS OUT BUT WE'LL WAIT FOR
OUR ABSENT MEMBER TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE ON THAT BILL AS WELL ALL
RIGHT WHILE WE ARE WAITING FOR
AN AUTHORS SENATORS SKATERS UP
NEXT THE CENTER GLAZER IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR BILL.
PLEASE DO SO AT THIS TIME
RAYMENT LOSSES THE CENTER
SKINNER WALKING AND- THAT'S
ALWAYS THE- AS ALWAYS HAPPENS
THAT ALWAYS HAPPENS THAT'S THE
SUPERINTENDENT YEP. I DO NOT SEE
HER SO PLEASE PROCEED WELCOME MR
SUPERINTENDENT WE'RE GLAD TO
HAVE YOU IN OUR HEARING TODAY.
SENATOR GLAZER PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY WITH SB NINE
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU CHAIR
LEYVA. YOU KNOW THROUGH THE
WISDOM OF- I PASS LEGISLATURE WE
HAVE A PLACE IN STATE GOVERNMENT
NOW WHERE YOU CAN GO. TO SEE THE
SALARIES OF ANY PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
IN THE STATE ANY ANYONE IT'S A-
PUBLIC PAY DOT CA DOT G. O. V.
IT HAPPENED BECAUSE OF THE
WISDOM AND LEADERSHIP OF
ASSEMBLYWOMAN CRISTINA GARCIA.
IN NINETY IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN ALONG WITH THE SUPPORT
OF CONTROLLER. JOHN JOHN- THERE
WAS AT SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER EVERYBODY HAD EVER HAD
IS COMPLYING WITH THAT WITH THAT
LAW- THERE WAS SOME AMBIGUITY IN
THE LEGISLATION THAT ALLOWED
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO NOT
COMPLY. IN FACT. ONLY ABOUT A
THIRD OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
OUR STATE ARE ACTUALLY DOING
WHAT THAT LAW REQUIRES OF THEM
AS IT DOES INVOLVE PUBLICATION
SEES. SO THE LEGISLATION THAT
YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU IS TO
PROVIDE THAT CLARITY AND
ELIMINATE THAT AMBIGUITY AND
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NEED TO DO THE SAME
THING THAT ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NEED TO DO AND- PROVIDE THAT
TRANSPARENCY ON. ON PAY DATA-
YOU KNOW THAT LEGISLATION BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN GARCIA HAPPENED
BECAUSE- THERE WAS A SCANDAL IN
THE CITY OF BELL WERE
INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT. THE
CITY MANAGER HAD MANIPULATED THE
SYSTEM TO OBTAIN A SALARY. OF
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. AND IT MORE RECENTLY SOME
NEWS REPORTS IN LOS ANGELES-
POINTED OUT THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF A VERY SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT DOWN THERE WAS
BEING PAID SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. A YEAR. SO
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO CLARIFY
THAT REPORTING OBLIGATION TO
ALLOW THAT TO RIFIC WEBSITE
UNDER THE- LEADERSHIP OF THE
CONTROLLER TO HAVE THAT ACCESS
TO. THE DATA FOR EVERYONE NOT
JUST A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE
REST SO WITH THAT. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY WITH
ME I HAVE SEAN MORRIS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER. SKEWS
ME A LEAD SUPPORT MISTER SHAWN
MCMORRIS I BELIEVE YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. YES THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING SHOPLIFT MORSE GRANT. AT
THE ETHICS AND ACCOUNTABILITY
PROGRAM MANAGER CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE. WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE NINE TWENTY FOUR AN
IMPORTANT REFORM THAT WOULD
ELIMINATE UNNECESSARY. ACCEPTED
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS. RIGHT WELL
. STATE COMPTROLLER PUBLISHED
ANNUAL COMPENSATION INFORMATION
FOR CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HOWEVER UNLIKE OTHER
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BOX LIPSTICK
THE EXCLUDE. THE COMPILING AND
CLOSE THE ANNUAL COMPENSATION OF
EMPLOYEES THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AS A RESULT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONLY 23% OF EDUCATION EMPLOYERS
IN THE STATE RESPONDED TO THE
CONTROLLER'S REQUEST FOR
EMPLOYEE SALARY INFORMATION
WHILE 98% OF CALIFORNIA COUNTY
99% OF CALIFORNIA CITY. 99% OF
CALIFORNIA. SPECIAL DISTRICTS
COMPLIED WITH THE LAW. WAS A
CLEAR. HELLO IN EXCHANGE. ACT
MECHANISM. EXCEPT FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THIS MUST CHANGE.
REMEMBER THAT THE CURRENT LAW IN
THE CURRENT YEAR BY PUBLIC I'M
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SALARIES THE
PRODUCT OF EXTREME CORRUPTION IN
THE CITY OF BELL AND IN OTHER
PLACES. WHAT HAPPENED TO BE A
BALCONY BEHALF IN SCHOOLS. THAT
GET REPORTED HAS REVEALED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MONTEBELLO SAN DIEGO
AERIAL MARC PLAYER AND SAID THE
KNOW ABOUT. IT SHOULD NOT TAKE A
STAND OKAY. HELLO CHEN UNCOVERED
IN THE CITY THE STATE ARE.
OLDEST THE SAME LEVEL OF. AT ALL
OTHER LOCAL JURISTIC. CALIFORNIA
SB. NINETY FOUR I'M SORRY AT
NINE TWENTY FOUR. WHAT DO JUST
THAT. THIS COMMONSENSE REFORM
WILL BOTH HER AND REPEAL ENACT
MISUSE OF WITH THE AND ACROSS
SCHOOL. THIS TIME FOR CAL TO OF
SCHOOLS THE STATE RIGHT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY MACBOOK PRO. CITY
SPECIALIST. WE RESPECT REQUEST
YOUR IBOOK PAPER SB. NINE POINT
FOUR. THANK YOU MR MCMORRIS
THERE IS NO OTHER LEAD US
SUPPORT ANYONE HERE TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SEEING NO
ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
STATE THEIR NAME AND SUPPORT.
FOR S. B. NINE TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MA'AM AGAIN IF YOU'RE
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FOUR YOU
LIKE MAKE COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZEROAT THE START. ID MOMENT
THEY WERE GIVING THEIR GIVING
THEIR NÂNG NUMBERS WE JUST
MOMENTS THANK YOU.
IT WITH LITTLE WIND TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI I'M NOT
PATTERSON I'M THE RESEARCH
DIRECTOR FOR THE PUBLIC A
WATCHDOG ORGANIZATION
TRANSPARENT CALIFORNIA WE THANK
SENATOR GLAZER AND URGING THE
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE NINE TWENTY
FOUR. ANYONE WHO'S NOT FAMILIAR
WITH OUR SITE CAN GO TO A RESCUE
CALIFORNIA .COM OR YOUR- I.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. IN LIEU OF THE
WIND TWO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M VERY WHICH CELERY
HEARING RIGHT NOW WE ARE ON S.
B. NINE TWENTY FOUR MA'AM. NINE
TWENTY FOUR. BY SENATOR GLAZERS
EARNED ONE. OUR EDITOR GLACIER-
MY NAME IS RELIGION CALLING FROM
PLASTER COUNTY AND I AYES AYE
OPPOSED THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'M OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE TWENTY
FOUR. IN MANAGED CARE OF NO FOR
THE LINES IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME VERY GOOD THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR. WE WILL NOW GO TO
LEAD OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO FOLKS
WHO ARE IN LEAD OR WILL BE THE
LEAD OPPOSITION INDIRA MCDONALD
AND NATALIE SIDERIS BOTH FROM
THE- SORRY MISS- INDIRA IS WITH
THE DEPUTY CONTROLLERS
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE. AND MISS OF
SEVERUS IS FROM THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AS WELL WHO
WHO'S GOING FIRST HI MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS INDIRA
MCDONALD WITH THE OFFICE OF
STATE CONTROLLER BETTY YEE WHILE
THE CONTROLLER SUPPORTS THE
INTENT OF SB NINE TWO FOUR. I AM
HERE TO EXPRESS OUR OFFICES
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS- AND WE
DO BELIEVE THAT COULD BE EASILY
ADDRESS I'M NATALIE WILL BE HERE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
PERFECT. HOW WE UNDERSTAND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE ALREADY
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO REPORT THE
COMPENSATION DATA AT ISSUE IN
THIS BILL TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
THE BILL MANDATES THE SAME
INFORMATION BE SEPARATELY
REPORTED TO THE SCO. UNDER THE
FORMER CONTROLLERS DIRECTION K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS WERE
ASKED TO VOLUNTARILY REPORT
COMPENSATION COMPENSATION DATA
TO THE STATE COMPTROLLER IN
RESPONSE OUR OFFICE RECEIVED A
FLOOD OF COMPLAINTS THAT THE
DATA REPORTING METHOD AND FORMAT
OUR OFFICE USES. FOR OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCIAL DATA
REPORTING IS UNREASONABLE FOR
ALREADY OVERTAXED SCHOOLS. HAS
IT WOULD ENTAIL A COMPLETE
OVERHAUL OF THEIR INTERNAL
SYSTEMS AT GREAT EXPENSE BY
FORCING THEM TO REPORT THE SAME
DATA THEY ALREADY REPORT TO CDP
TO SCO THIS BILL WOULD TRIGGER A
BALLOT COSTLY STATE MANDATES
CLAIM. THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS ALREADY THE
RECIPIENT OF A LARGE VOLUMES OF
DATA FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ANNUALLY IN A WORKABLE FORMAT
THIS IS EVIDENT BY THE CURRENT
76% RATE OF COMPLIANCE NOTED BY
CDT. COMPARED TO OUR OFFICES 23%
REPORTING COMPLIANCE. FOR
VOLUNTARY REPORTING PROGRAM. IN
ADDITION KERN LOCKER CD WITH.
MAC FOR ANY DATA REQUIRED BY THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT. BECAUSE
COMPENSATION DATA IS CURRENTLY
REPORTED TO CDP AND USED TO
FULFILL THE OBLIGATION UNDER
CURRENT LAW TO CALCULATE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE SALARIES FOR
DISTRICT USED IN THE
ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT CARD.
INCURRING GOT IS POSTED ONLINE
WE WOULD ASK THAT THE INCREASED
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS BE
CONSISTENT AND ALIGNED WITH
CURRENT CD REPORTING IN THIS
FUNCTION NOT BE PLACED WITH THE
STATE COMPTROLLER. CREATING A
DUPLICATIVE MANDATE WE SHARE THE
AUTHORS COMMITMENT TO
TRANSPARENCY WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH HIM AND TO KEEP THE
STATE'S GOALS IN THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER. THANK YOU FOR
THE UPDATE PERFECT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND YOU SAID THAT MS
MCDONALD IS JUST HERE FOR.
NATALIE SAID ALLEY YEAH IT'S
WITH OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REPORTING PROGRAM AND SHALL BE
AVAILABLE ALSO FOR ANY QUESTIONS
PERFECT ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD WE
WILL THEN GO TO ANYONE HERE IN
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SEEING
NONE MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE TWENTY
FOUR. THANK MEDICARE AND WHAT
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
THEIR POSITION ON SB NINE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
IN ONE OF THE FEW MOMENTS OF
MEDICARE NO ONE'S COMMITTED IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME OKAY
VERY GOOD THANK YOU WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
SENATOR PAN. THIRTY THIRD A
QUESTION I JUST TO CLARIFY- FROM
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE- ARE
EXCITED YET IS THE SAYS SO ARE
YOU SAYING THAT THE SALARY DATA
IS A READY REPORTED JUST TO
DEPART EDUCATION- SO IT'S
ACTUALLY READY THERE. ARE ARE SO
THAT AT THE TIME I CLARIFY SAID
THIS IS THE STATE ALREADY BEING
COLLECTED BY SOME AGENCY IN THE
STATE YET WE UNDERSTAND SO THERE
UNDER CURRENT LAW- AT EQUIVALENT
EMPLOYEES BY DISTRICT AND THE
LOWEST HIGHEST AND AVERAGE
SALARIES PAID THERE IS DATA
REPORTING NOW IT MAY BE THAT
OFFICE INTENTION OR LEGISLATION
CONTINUE TO ENHANCE THAT. AND
SOMEWHAT AND SO WE WOULD JUST
ASK THAT WE NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AT TO SEE WHAT DATA
THEY CURRENTLY HAVE AN COULD BE
ENHANCED TO ACHIEVE YOUR GOALS
AS OPPOSED TO I DUPLICATIVE
REPORTING OKAY ALL RIGHT. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THEY DON'T. THAT ACTUALLY REPORT
YOU DID HE INDIVIDUAL SALARY
THEN TO A SO I GUESS AND A
QUESTION I GUESS THE AUTHORS AND
STUFF- CERTAINLY I WAS VERY- I
THINK LITTLE DISAGREEMENT THAT
PARTICULARLY SENIOR YOU KNOW
SUPERINTENDENTS PEOPLE IN SENIOR
ROLES ETCETERA LIKE THE EXAMPLES
YOU PRESENTED FOUR DOORS FRAUD
AT CETERA. DO YOU SO IS THE
INTENT THEN TO HAVE EVERY SINGLE
DOWN TO THE JANITOR- THIS IS
SALARY REPORTED- SO IT'S
SEARCHABLE AND THEN ALSO IS THIS
THE SCOPE OF THIS IS THIS JUST
ONLY EMPLOYEES AT. PUBLIC SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OR THAT ANY EMPLOYEES
IN THE EDUCATION SYSTEM ARE
FUNDED THROUGH PUBLIC DOLLARS
LIKE CHARTER SCHOOLS. SO I JUST
WANNA CLARIFY EXACTLY WHAT THE
ONE IN THIS DATABASE AND HOW.
AND THEN WHO WHO'S YOU KNOW WHO
WHO WHO'S- THE BETTER THE SCOPE
OF THIS ESPECIALLY WHEN YEAH
IT'S- I UNDERSTAND THIS IS ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR PUBLIC
SPENDING. THANK YOU. PLEASE
RECEIVE THE CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR PAT- THE GOAL IT REMAINS
THAT REGIONAL GOAL CENTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA'S BILL IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND THAT'S
THAT. EXPENDITURE TAX DOLLARS-
THE TRANSPARENT. AND THAT
INCLUDES ALL THOSE WHO WORK IN
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. IDON'T THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT WHAT THE
JANITORS BEING PAID BUT IT'S UP
TO PUBLIC DOLLARS AND SO IT
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE IN THE SAME
SEARCHABLE FORMAT THAT THAT
BILL- REQUIRED. YEAH THERE ARE
WE HAVE A SEARCH- SITUATION WITH
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS-
CURRENTLY THERE'S A DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS- FOR. PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN ITS THREE
HIGHEST PAID INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO
BE DISCLOSED EVERY YEAR I'M NOT
INTENDING TO GET IN THAT SPACE
AND CHANGE THE- THE GUIDELINES
THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED FOR THE
SPECIAL CATEGORY OF PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS BUT THEY DO
DISCLOSE. AT SOME LEVEL ALREADY
. OKAY ALL RIGHT I APPRECIATE
THAT ANSWER I THINK THE AND
SINCE YOU KNOW YOU BRING THIS UP
AT- I GUESS- YEAH I'M GOING TO
PUT YOUR BILL TODAY BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IN TRANSPARENCY- I HOPE
WE LOOK AT THIS A LITTLE BIT IN
TERMS OF. WE DO HAVE THIS
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO
DECIDE TO CHOOSE PUBLIC SERVICE
AND YOU KNOW WHAT PUBLIC SERVICE
NOT JUST ABOUT BEING ELECTED
OFFICIALS ALSO ABOUT SERVING AND
GOVERNMENT RIGHT. AND AND THEN
THERE'S DIFFERENT ROLES RIGHT
AND CERTAINLY IF SOMEONE HAS
RESPONSIBILITY OVER YOU KNOW
THE- THE PUBLIC DOLLARS AND SO
FORTH- AND- THE- WOULDN'T MEAN
HAVE TRANSPARENCY SO WE KNOW
THAT THEY'RE NOT SELF DEALING.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT- THEN
THERE'S OTHER EMPLOYEES WHO
PROBABLY NOT REALLY IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE AND THEN THE
QUESTION IS THAT. WHAT ARE WE
REALLY SERVING AT THAT POINT TO
RATE IF TO ACTUALLY. IDENTIFY
SPECIFIC PEOPLE NEAR PACIFIC
SALARIES RIGHT AND SO THEY'RE
NOT THAT KIND OF ROLE. AND SO I
REALIZE THIS IS PERHAPS A LITTLE
LARGER THAN THE SCOPE OF WHAT
THEY DID THAT BUT THIS BILL DOES
ADDRESS THAT FOR FIRST FOR
SCHOOL SO. AND AT MAYBE
REVISITING SOME ISSUES- WITH-
THE PRIOR. PRIOR LEGISLATION
BUT- YEAH I JUST WANNA BE A
LITTLE SENSITIVE TO THE FACT
THAT FOR MOST PEOPLE THE
FINANCIAL. INFORMATION IS. NOW.
CONSIDERED PRIVATE AND
CONFIDENTIAL. AND THEN SAYING
THE IF YOU. ARE SIDE TO ENGAGE
IN PUBLIC SERVICE BUT NOT HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR PUBLIC
DOLLARS DIRECTLY. THAT YOU HAVE
TO GIVE UP THAT PRIVACY JUST FOR
SERVING JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE
WORKING IN A SCHOOL DISTRICT OR
SOMETHING. I THINK YEAH I DON'T
DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM FROM
WORKING THERE AND YOU ONE COULD
ARGUE THAT MAYBE THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM
DOING SO- BUT- I DO I. I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS- THAT PERHAPS WE
CAN BE THOUGHT THROUGH- BUT
AGAIN I DO YOU KNOW THE
UNDERSTAND AND SUPPORT THE IDEA
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
TRANSPARENCY TO WE CAN IDENTIFY.
A FRAUD OR A PEOPLE ARE SELF
DEALING AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT SO- SO DATS-
I'VE- HOPEFULLY UP WE CAN HAVE
SOME FURTHER DIALOGUES THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER PANTS CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU A FIGURING THIS BILL
FOR I THINK THERE IS- THOSE OF
US WHO'VE BEEN AROUND AT LEAST-
AT LOCAL LEVELS AND FOR. MYSELF
FOR A LONG TIME I I'VE WITNESSED
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE CITY OF
BELL AND IT WAS. IT WAS
TRANSPARENT IT WAS OF THE OPEN
THE PEOPLE JUST DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT IT. AND THEY DID IT IN A
WAY- BUT I BELIEVE WAS
UNDERHANDED AND THEY'VE SPIKED
THEIR RETIREMENTS OF AS WELL AS-
YOU KNOW TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THE
OF THE SYSTEM WAS AVAILABLE SO
I. I AM GONNA SUPPORT YOU WILL
MOVE THE BILL TODAY I THINK IT'S
AGOOD OPPORTUNITY BE
TRANSPARENT AND LOOK. AT THE END
OF THE DAY- THE FOR THE FOR
CALIFORNIANS YOU TO KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE PAYING FOR WHAT AND- AND
SOME OF THOSE ARE VERY HIGH. THE
PAID POSITIONS AND JUSTIFIABLY
THEY SHOULD BE BECAUSE THEY'RE
RUNNING MAJOR. A. B. LIKE
RUNNING A MAJOR CORPORATION IF
YOU'RE A COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICER AND L. A. COUNTY. YOU
HAVE A HUGE PAYROLL AND YOU HAVE
A HUGE. RESPONSIBILITY QUITE
FRANKLY AND THAT TYPE OF TALENT
NEEDS TO BE COMPENSATED IN A WAY
THAT YOU CAN GET GOOD PEOPLE TO
DO THEIR JOB SO I THINK IT'S
MORE. ON THE OTHER SIDE WHERE WE
CAN ACTUALLY DEMONSTRATE- THE
LEVEL OF EDUCATION AND THE LEVEL
OF EXPERTISE THAT YOU NEED.TO
DO A GOOD JOB IN PUBLIC SERVICE
AND YOU HAVE TO PAY FOR THOSE
POSITIONS QUITE FRANKLY- AND
SOME SOME PEOPLE IN THE PUBLIC
MAY THINK THAT THAT'S- TOO HIGH-
BUT WE SHOULD HAVE THAT DEBATE
WE SHOWED THAT. WE HAVE THAT
OPENNESS IS TO SEE- WHAT THE JOB
TITLE IS. AND WHAT IT PAYS AND
SOME PEOPLE ON THE OTHER END OF
THE SPECTRUM ARE UNDERPAID. AND
WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THOSE
FOLKS WHO. HAVE MET THOSE
CRITERIA CENTER UNDERPAID AS
WELL- BECAUSE IN THE PRIVATE
WORLD THEY CAN THEY WOULD BE.
COMPENSATED EVEN MORE BUT THEY
CHOOSE TO GO INTO PUBLIC
SERVICE- BECAUSE IT'S A PASSION
AND SO I THINK THAT THERE'S-
OPPORTUNITY ON BOTH ENDS. OF
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION TO
LOOK AT WHO PEOPLE WHO ARE NEED
TO BE PAID MORE AND- ARE NOT
CLASSIFIED IN THE RIGHT AREAS.
AND ONES THAT ARE AT THE TOP
WHERE THEY HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF SO I'M- HI. GRATEFUL I'D LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF
THAT'S POSSIBLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER DOLLY ANYONE ELSE
COMMENTS CONCERNS SEEING NONE.
OF THE CENTER GLAZER I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY- BUT I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU WORK WITH THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE BECAUSE I
DO THINK THEY BROUGHT FORWARD
SOME. VALID CONCERNS ALL AND I
WOULD ALSO JUST SAY I WOULD LOVE
TO KNOW WHAT THE CONSISTENT
CUSTODIANS MAKING. BECAUSE
SOMETIMES IT'S GOOD TO SEE THE
DISPARAGEMENT SOMEONE WHO SHOWS
UP AND WORKS HARD EVERY DAY TO
KEEP OUR SCHOOLS. ARE RUNNING
AND WORKING AND WHAT THEY'RE
BEING PAID COMPARED TO THE TOP
PERSON. SO WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR A COUPLE THINGS TO SAY IN
RESPONSE TO THE THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. AT
FIRST I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE ON
THESE IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES.
IT'S FRUSTRATING WHEN THE
BUREAUCRACY KIND OF GETS IN THE
WAY OF- ARE GOOD DEL LAWMAKING
THAT PREVIOUS LEGISLATURES HAVE
ADVANCED- SECONDLY YOU KNOW- WE
HAVE INCREDIBLE PUBLIC SERVANTS
IN OUR STATE. AT EVERY LEVEL.
IT'S ALWAYS TERRIBLE WHEN YOU
HAVE THESE BY. APPLES THAT. THAT
APPEAR. AND IT MAKES US ALL
REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE BECAUSE- A
PART OF A- TRUST IN GOVERNMENT
IS- TRANSPARENCY AND THE FACT
THAT WE'RE DOING OUR WORK.
APPROPRIATELY I WILL MENTION AND
THIS IS AGAIN THE EXCEPTION TO
THE RULE. BUT A JANITOR. IN A
PUBLICATION C. WAS MAKING OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A FEW YEARS AGO. AND
THAT EXPOSED AT SOME ISSUES IN
THAT PARTICULAR CLASSIFICATION
FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL AND THE AND
THE SUPER HISTORIAL RANKS THAT
THEY ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN IT'S
VERY RARE IT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
BUT A WELL WE TALK ABOUT THE TOP
OF THE CHAIN AND THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND THAT'S
WHERE GREATER ABUSE OCCURS. I
WOULD SAY THAT YOU NEVER KNOW
AND SO WE ALWAYS LIKE TO TRY TO
ERR ON THE SIDE OF THE B. AND
REALLY TRANSPARENT CROSS THE
BOARD. WITH THAT I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY ASKED
FOR I DON'T THINK IT'S CENTER
GLAZER THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR DOLLY MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB NINE
TWENTY FOR THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS THAT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA HI LEVI OCHO ABOVE. THE
CHOI BOGUE I CRITICIZED BY
PROTESTS THE I. DELI. DELI I
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE PAN ALL RIGHT.
HANNAH SEVEN VOTE. ALL RIGHT
THAT BILL IS OUT OUR FIRST SEVEN
OH OF THE DAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR GLAZER. ALL RIGHT%
WE ARE LOOKING FOR SENATOR
SKINNER BUT SHE IS NOT HERE SO
MISTER JONES WE WILL GO TO YOU
SENATOR JONES. IS PRESENT TEAM.
S. B. HELLO THIRTY FIVE. PLEASE
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I HAVE US
SOME WITNESSES FILING INTO THE
ROOM RIGHT NOW IT LOOKS LIKE
THEY'RE MAKING IT- SENATE BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE ESTABLISHES A
PILOT PROGRAM FOR THE CARDIAC
SCREENING PROGRAM. FOR USE
GRADES FIVE TO TWELVE. HOW MANY
OF YOU HAVE HEARD ALONG THE
LINES OF AN OTHERWISE HEALTHY
KID DROPPING DEAD ON A
BASKETBALL COURT. THOSE KIDS
NORMALLY ARE FOUND TO HAVE
SUFFERED FROM SUDDEN CARDIAC
DEATH. DUE TO NINE DIAGNOSED
HEART CONDITION. MEANING IT WAS
LIKELY PREVENTABLE. THE PILOT
PROGRAM ESTABLISHED UNDER THIS
BILL WILL EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
CARDIAC SCREENINGS DONE BY
NONPROFITS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
RESULTING IN MORE CHILDREN BEING
DIAGNOSED EARLIER. AND MAKING
POSSIBLE FOR THEM TO SEEK
TREATMENT. THESE SCREENINGS
OFFER EACH STUDENT THAT CHOOSES
TO PARTICIPATE A CARDIAC RISK
ASSESSMENT OF WARNING SIGNS IN
FAMILY HISTORY IN A TWELVE LEAD.
ELECTROCARDIOGRAM IMPORTANTLY
50% OF THE STUDENTS THAT ARE
FOUND TO HAVE HEART CONDITIONS
PASSER ASSESSMENT WITHOUT ANY
CONCERNS BUT THEY WERE FOUND TO
HAVE IRREGULAR ECGS. THAT'S SO
MANY LIVES CAN BE SAVED BY QUICK
NON INVASIVE ECG. BEFORE I TURN
OVER TO MY WITNESSES TO SHARE
THEIR PERSONAL EXPERIENCES I DID
WANT TO MENTION THAT WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE CMA TO TIGHTEN
UP THE LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THE
APPROPRIATE PHYSICIAN IS
INTERPRETING ECG RESULTS. THESE
NONPROFITS ALREADY PARTNER WITH
CARDIOLOGISTS INTERPRET THE
RESULTS SO WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THE LANGUAGE IS
CLEAR. BUT THAT MANAGER I'D LIKE
TO TURN OVER TO MY WITNESSES TO
HEAR HOW THIS HAS AFFECTED THEIR
LIVES. PERSONALLY VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES ALL
RIGHT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE THREE
FOLKS ARE GOING TO TESTIFY. TO
FOLKS ARE GOING TO DO ONE MINUTE
AND THEN THE LAST PERSON WHO'S
CALLING IN THIS GOING TO DO TWO
MINUTES SO WE HAVE RINA PERATIS'
GREESON. AND HECTOR PERATIS' SO
RENO WE WILL START WITH YOU HAVE
ONE MINUTE PLEASE PROCEED GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
RITA PREJUDICE GRAYSON ERIC'S
MOM. JUST ABOUT ONE MONTH FROM
TDAY MARKS THE DATE ERIC WOULD
HAVE BEEN TWENTY EIGHT. INSTEAD
HE LOST AT AGE. HE WAS LOST AT
AGE FIFTEEN TO A HEART CONDITION
NO WHEN YOU HE HAD. THIS
BEAUTIFUL KID SO FULL OF LIFE
ALWAYS READY TO PLAY. WHO LOVED
TO DANCE AND WANTED TO MAKE THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE. BUT HE
NEVER GOT THE CHANCE. THIS
HAPPENED BECAUSE OF A TREMENDOUS
GAP IN PREVENTATIVE HEART CARE
FOR OUR KIDS. WHICH STEMS FROM A
LACK OF EDUCATION ABOUT THE
REALITY OF SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST
AND USE KNOWN AS A CA. HALF OF
YOU STRICKEN HAVE NO WARNING
SIGNS OR FAMILY RISK FACTORS IN
OF YOUTH WHO DID SHOW SYMPTOMS
THEY WERE OFTEN MISSED OR
MISDIAGNOSED BECAUSE NO ONE
REALIZED HE WAS LIFE
THREATENING. I AM A NURSE AND I
DID NOT KNOW. STEADY SHOW ONE IN
THREE HUNDRED YOUTH HAS AN
UNDETECTED HEART CONDITION THAT
PUTS THEM AT RISK. IT'S TIME TO
EDUCATE OURSELVES ABOUT HOW WE
CAN DO A BETTER JOB TO PROTECT
YOUNG HEARTS. WE KNOW WE CAN'T
BECAUSE OUR NONPROFIT FOUNDATION
HAS PROVIDED NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND FREE YOUTH HEART
SCREENINGS FINDING. TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE WITH CARDIAC
ABNORMALITIES SERIOUS ENOUGH TO
CAUSE SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST.
BECAUSE JULIA SCREENING
REVEALED. FONG CUTIE
WHEN A CHECK A SERVICE WITH TEAM
COACH TOLD HER TO PUSH THROUGH
THE PAIN. IN PARAMEDIC SCOTT
SHERMAN THOUGHT HE RECOGNIZED A
HEART CONDITION BUT HE MISSED
SPENCER'S HE SAID THANK YOU FOR
SAVING MY SON SO I COULD ENJOY
HIM FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE
WHICH IS SOMETHING. I HAVE NOT
DONE. AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
S. B. ONE ONE THREE FIVE IS
ABOUT. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY- MISTER
PREJUDICE PLEASE PROCEED YOU
HAVE ONE MORNING GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE BUDGET IS ABOUT WHAT
WE NEED TO DO TO MITIGATE THESE
PREVENTABLE TRAGEDIES AND I DO
MEAN PREVENTABLE. OF THE LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH IN YOUTH
ACCIDENTS FROM SIDE TO SIDE
CANCER HEART CONDITIONS. THE
LAST ONE IS THE IS THE ONE WE
HAVE THE TOOLS THAT RIGHT NOW.
THE PILOT WILL PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL DATA DEMONSTRATE THE
VALUE TO VOTE TO FAMILIES OUR
HEALTH SYSTEM DOING MORE. AND
ALONG THE WAY IT WILL PROVIDE A
LIFESAVING SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA
YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES. MY
NAME IS HECTOR PREDECESSOR
AMERICA STAND. WHEN WE LOST ERIC
I JUST SOON AS MY SON I LOST A
LOT OF OUR FUTURE. OUR FAMILY
WILL NEVER TRULY RECOVER. I'M
RETIRED AFTER A LONG CAREER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
THE COACH WATER SPORTS AND I
CAN'T BELIEVE I DIDN'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT SUDDEN CARDIAC
ARREST. THAT'S WHERE FOUNDATION
SPONSORS SCA PREVENTION
LEGISLATION. AND WE KNOW IT'S
MAKING AN IMPACT. TRAINING
MANDATED BY THEIR CREDIT SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST PREVENTION ACT
HAS ALREADY ADJUDICATED. OVER
TWO HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
COACHES ABOUT CARDIAC EMERGENCYPREPAREDNESS WORKING SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES HAS PROVEN TO BE
INEFFECTIVE MEANS TO BOOST
HEALTH LITERACY AND HEALTH
EQUITY. IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
CDC'S WHOLE SCHOOL WHOLE
COMMUNITY ND WHOLE CHAU
COLLABORATION. THIS INITIATIVE
HAS BECOME A NATIONAL MOVEMENT.
RECENTLY EVIDENCED BY PRESIDENT
BIDEN ADDING ECG SCREENINGS FOR
NEW CADETS AND MILITARY
ACADEMIES TO NATIONAL DEFENSE
APPROPRIATIONS ACT. WORKING
MODELS FOR YOUTH HEART
SCREENINGS IN CALIFORNIA ALREADY
EXIST THIS PHONE THROUGH
POLICIES CLEARLY EXECUTED BOWL.
AND THE DATA IS CRITICAL TO
IDENTIFYING THE BENEFITS OF
REMOVING THE NUMBER ONE KILLER
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES. SENATE BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE WILL HELP
GIVE FAMILIES AND THEIR KIDS THE
FUTURE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR
STORY. WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES AND WE HAVE JACOB LEE. WHO
IS A STUDENT SCREWS SCREEN
THROUGH AIRPORT IT IS SAVE A
LIFE FOUNDATION. OF JACOB ARE
YOU WITH US. YES I AM ALL RIGHT
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES PLEASE
PROCEED. RIGHT HI MY NAME IS
DIRECTLY ON TWENTY ONE AND IN
JUNIOR COLLEGE. I'M HERE TODAY
BECAUSE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
NIGHT. HEART TRAINING AGO.
HONESTLY IT WASN'T THE FIRST
THING I WANT TO DO WHAT HAPPENED
THAT THEY CHANGED MY LIFE
FOREVER. MY MOM TOLD ME
SCREENING WOULD BE PAINLESS AND
IT ONLY TOOK ABOUT AN HOUR. SHE
WANTS A REAL ANY ISSUES MY
HEART. DESPITE LOOKING HEALTH
EMPLOYEES FOR OLD. SHORT OF
BREATH AND ROB. DURING OR
SOMETIMES EVEN WHEN I WAS AT
REST. STILL TIGHT DO YOU TREAT
ABOUT THE- AND I WAS. INHALER
BUT DIDN'T HELP. DURING OUR
TRAINING I WAS. THAT WITHIN SITE
CARDIO. HE TOLD ME THAT I HAD A
CONDITION CALLED ACUTE YEP ONE
OF THE LEADING CAUSES CARDIAC
ARREST. EXPLAINED THAT I WOULD
NEED SURGERY BUT I WOULD RETURN
TO NORMAL ACTIVITIES. ALL THE
WELL MEANING PEOPLE IN MY LIFE
MISDIAGNOSED MUSTN'T. I WAS ONE
IN THREE HUNDRED YEARS RIGHT HOW
THE CONDITION THAT COULD LEAD US
YEAH. BECAUSE OF THAT TRAINING
MY STORY DIDN'T END LIKE ERIC'S
. EVERY YEAR TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND UNDER EIGHTEEN GUY FROM
CITY CARDIAC ARREST. MORE YOU
FORKING CAR ACCIDENTS AND MORE
OFTEN SIZE. I'M HERE TODAY
BECAUSE- OF HER THE APPOINTMENTS
HARD SCREEN PRE SUPPORT SB ONE
ONE THREE FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NOW GO TO ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO
ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU MEDICARE
AND YOU'RE ON THE PHONE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND W. ONE
NINETY TWO YOUR LINES OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AIRBRIDGE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT COURT THANK
YOU. WE'RE GOING TO FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M A
RESTRICTED DURING YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. IN ORDER TO ALIGN TO
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DEMOCRATS REMEMBER WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION-
SUPPORT OF AMENDED ONE- EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION TO THE FENDER
AND FEEDBACK FOR WORKING WITH US
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND GO TO
ONE TWO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME FEET BASICALLY
ON THE PRINCIPLE OF MADISON
MIDDLE SCHOOL THE NEW YORK
COUNTY TRAGICALLY LOST STUDENT
MARCO JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO TO
STUDYING KARTIKA CARDIAC ARREST.
AND HAVE SINCE SCHEDULED A FREE
HEART SCREEN AT OUR SCHOOL IN
DECEMBER. THE SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU. AND GO
TO ONE TO TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ALISON THE REPO MY DAUGHTER RYAN
WAS FOUND IT BURKE SAID IN
CARDIAC ARREST IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND A FREE HEART
SCREENING AND IT HAD CORRECTIVE
SURGERY. RYAN WAS A THREE SPORT
ATHLETE SHE HAD NO WARNING SIGN.
TODAY IS THE D. ONE ATHLETE AT
UC BERKELEY PLEASE SUPPORT SB.
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
IT WILL ALIGN TO TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
SERENA AND I WAS FOUND HOURS
BEFORE SETTING CARDIAC ARREST
THANKS TO MY MOM LEARNING ABOUT
THE WARNING SIGNS AND RISK
FACTORS FROM THE- CREDIT
STABILIZE FOUNDATION. SO SHE CAN
ADVOCATE MY HEART HELP WITH MY
MEDICAL PROVIDERS PLEASE SUPPORT
SB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU
. IT WILL WIND TWO FIFTEEN TWO
ONE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHERRI GOOD MORNING ON KNOWINGLY
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS- I ALSO
HAVE. SEVERAL OF THE STUDENTS
THAT I USED TO WORK WITH
WITHHOLDING THEIR HEART. AND ALL
OF THIS IS GOING OCTOBER YOU.
ARE OF THE AGE BRACKET BUT EVEN
HIGHER BECAUSE- A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS OF THE PARENTS. ARE
THAT THEY MIGHT BE ACT
AGGRAVATED OR EXONERATED-
BECAUSE OF THE FACT BEING. THANK
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND WE'RE GOING TO
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RIGHT NOW ALL I AM CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN A GRADUATE PROGRAM
MEDICINE I FIND IT REPRESENTING
HER AT THE RAP FOR HER HIGH
SCHOOL HARDENING OUTSIDE OF THE
WALK DECENT BENEFIT MY FAMILY
MEMBERS WERE OFFERED IDEAS ON
KEEPING I'M CALLING MY DAD.
REPORTER AT T THE ELEVENTH FIVE
OF PART. THANK YOU. INCLUDING TO
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS UP. FIVE
CARS I'M A JUNIOR AND STUDYING
NURSING I WAS FOUND AT RISK OF
THEM PARTY AFTER IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN- ARE MEANING AND I
THAT'S CORRECT J. PLEASE SUPPORT
AT ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU
. IT WILL ALIGN TO FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
TANYA I LOST MY SON CHRISTIAN TO
SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST ONE DAY
BEFORE THE NINETEENTH BIRTHDAY
KRISTIANSTAD AND I WISH WE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY OPPORTUNITY TO
GET IN SCREEN BEFORE HE PASSED
AWAY PLEASE SUPPORT SB. ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU. IT WILL
ONE TWO OH FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS WILLIAM
FLORES I ALSO LOST MY PHONE
SEVEN CARDIAC ARREST I WISH WE
WOULD HAVE THESE FREE HEART
SCREENINGS FOR MY SON PRIOR TO
SO WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE
ONE THREE FIVE. I THANK YOU
CENTER. IN MEDICARE WE HAVE A
NOTE FOR THEIR LINES IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD I DO
THINK WE HAVE SOMEONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE ROOM PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL PLEASE. COMMANDING
MORGAN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
SORRY WAS RUNNING FROM THE OTHER
CAPITAL A OKAY- JOHNSON CLEAR
ABOUT THE SCRIPT SO. BASED IN
SAN DIEGO HERE IN SUPPORT GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU MADE IT
JUST IN TIME. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
NO LEAD OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
OPPOSE THE BILL. SEEING NONE
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU GO TO
THE PHONE LINES. AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
OPPOSE SB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE.
CERTAINLY IN THE- LEADING HIM IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
MEDICARE NO LINES IN OPPOSITION
AT THE TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE BUT BEFORE I GO
TO THE COMMITTEE SERVER JONES
DID YOU ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS. I
AT OTHER MINUTES READY FROM THE
COMMITTEE YES YES WE ARE.
ACCEPTING THOSE CAN PERFECT
WASN'T SURE THEY WERE READY FOR
TODAY OR FOR THE NEXT DAY
ALREADY OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. CENTER PAN. THANK YOU AND
THE ADDRESS THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- WHAT
QUESTIONS I DID HAVE THOUGH AND-
GIVEN YOUR INTRODUCTORY
TESTIMONY IS THAT- THE- IN THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY BEEN HAVING
SOME CONVERSATIONS CMA- BUT ALSO
FOR EXAMPLE THE AMERICAN CAPPY
AFFECTS HAS RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT- WE ACTUALLY- COFFER HARD
SCREEN OF ALL USE- ACTUALLY AT
LEAST- YOU KNOW EVERY THREE
YEARS. SO THAT'S CERTAINLY IN
SUPPORT. BUT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE
NOTE THAT- ALSO THAT- THE
GUIDELINES ALSO INDICATE THAT
ROUTINE E. ECG SCREENING OF
HEALTHY PEDIATRIC PATIENTS WITH
NO PERSONAL FAMILY HISTORIES
ARAMBULA READ OFF THE GUIDELINES
HERE. KOREA BECAUSE HE SAID
DEMONSTRATED A HIGH FALSE
POSITIVE RATE HAS NOT BEEN FOUND
TO REDUCE MORTALITY FROM SUDDEN
CARDIAC DEATH. SO THE- THE WEEK
SO WE CERTAINLY SIX SCREEN AND
THAT INVOLVES TAKING IT HAS.
VERY CAREFUL HISTORY AND SO
FORTH BUT A ROUTINE EKG
SCREENING OF OTHERWISE SOMEONE
WHO DOESN'T HAVE ANY. PERSONAL
OR FAMILY HISTORY IS NOT
INDICATED BECAUSE THAT. WOULD
ACTUALLY- THAT DOES ACTUALLY END
UP POTENTIALLY EVEN CAUSING HARM
BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT OF WORK UP
AND SO FORTH AND CERTAINLY
EXPENSES WELL. SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS THAT IN TERMS OF
YOUR BILL AGAINST SUPPORT THE
IDEA THAT WE DO SCREENING. IS
THAT- THAT- THAT THE SCREEN IS
CONSISTENT WITH- BASICALLY YEAH-
MEDICAL GUIDELINES. SO THAT
WE'RE NOT TELLING PEOPLE THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO BE YOU KNOW
SCREEN OUT. EKG THESE ARE G. ON
. ALLIES HELLO RISK- PATIENTS
BECAUSE THAT ACTUALLY IS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE. RIGHT AND I
THINK DOCTOR PAN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE TAKING PLACE
WITH CMA RIGHT NOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THAT'S ALL AND-
INCLUDED IN THE LANGUAGE AND-
MAKING SURE THAT IT'S CLEAR.
OKAY NIGHT BRIEFLY THAT- CENTER
JONES AND IF THEY THINK IT'S YOU
KNOW AGAIN I KNOW YOUR INTENT IS
TO BE SURE WE HELP THE FAMILIES
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATIONS AND- TESTIMONY I
HEAR ON YOUR BILL. AND WE WANT
TO TRY PREVENT US ON CARDIAC
DEATH. AND SO WE SHOULD BE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO DO THAT-
BUT SOMETIMES WE SAY EVERYTHING
WE CAN- THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
MEAN. ALWAYS YOU KNOW DOING
THINGS THAT MAY NOT NECESSARY BE
PRODUCTIVE BUT SEEM LIKE THAT
MAY HELP SELL- YEAH APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR WORK ON THAT THANK
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR ALL TAKEN CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU SENATOR. FOR BRING
THIS BILL FOR A FIRST I WANT TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR LOSS AND- BUT
THIS BILL I WANT TO MOVE THE
BILL. I DON'T CARE IF I MAY. AND
ALSO- JUST KNOW THAT- THE LOST
GO IN VAIN WE WERE AND WERE ABLE
TO DO THAT DECISION LIKE THIS
AND- ACTUALLY. PREVENT IT FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATE ALL ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. OF THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSER JAKE YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
I JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AT
YOURSELF IN THE- SENATORS YEAR-
PATIENTS TODAY IN- AND
GRACIOUSNESS AND ALLOWING THE
TESTIMONY. I THINK IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR- THESE FAMILIES
DEAL SHARE APPS PERSON ANY OTHER
EXPERIENCE. TORRENT- IN CLOSING. SORRY OKAY THANK YOU TIME I
JUST WANT TO RECOGNIZE RENOWNED
HECTOR- I. HAVE HAD THE OPTION
WORK WITH THEM SINCE I WAS IN
THE ASSEMBLY. AND I'M NOT SURE
OF THE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
DATE WAS THE EVENT THAT I
ATTENDED. AT- GRANITE HILLS HIGH
SCHOOL OR OF ROSE ANOTHER DATE
THAT- WE'RE GONNA BE DOING
ANOTHER SCREENING IN SAN DIEGO
THIS WEEKEND- I'LL BE THERE ON
SUNDAY MORNING THEY'RE DOING
ANOTHER ONE IN JUNE IN SAN
DIEGO. AND I'M AMAZED AT THE
OUT. THE PEOPLE THAT ATTEND
THESE THINGS YOU KNOW I SHOWED
UP I DON'T KNOW IT WAS PROBABLY
A SUNDAY MORNING. AND I SHOWED
UP TO THE HIGH SCHOOL AND
THEY'VE GOT HUNDREDS OF
VOLUNTEERS. AND THEY'VE GOT
HUNDREDS OF KIDS AND THEIR
PARENTS. COME AND TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE SCREENINGS AND SO WE ARE
MAKING A VERY POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
INSIDE THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
ASK FOR NEIGHBORHOOD. THANK YOU
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING MAKING A POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE WE APPRECIATE YOU.
ARE THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER DOLLY MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE OTOBO. A TROUBLED AYE
COURTESY AYE COURTESY AYE DALLY.
DAILY AYE GLAZER. GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE. CAN I CAN I. THAT BILLS
OUT BUT LEAVING A CALL FOR
SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK YOU
SENATOR. APPRECIATE ALL RIGHT
NEXT UP IS SENATOR SKINNER BUT
SHE IS NOT HERE SO WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO SENATOR LEE MON
CEREMONY COME FORWARD TO PRESENT
SB NINE FIFTY TWO AM S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY ONE- SEED WHEN YOU
ARE READY. YOU ARE WELCOME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AT MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SB NINE FIFTY TWO
ESTABLISHES THE EXPANDING
CULTURE AND LANGUAGE LEARNING IN
SCHOOLS GRANT PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THE
GRANT PROGRAM AWARDS FIFTEEN
MILLION TO TWENTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SEEKING TO CONVERT TO
A DUAL LANGUAGE IMMERSION
SCHOOLS DUAL LANGUAGE IMMERSION
SCHOOLS OFFER INSTRUCTION IN TWO
LANGUAGES FOR BOTH ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND NATIVE ENGLISH
SPEAKERS. DUAL LANGUAGE SCHOOLS
HAVE DEMONSTRATED COGNITIVE
SOCIAL CULTURAL ECONOMIC AND
EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS FOR
STUDENTS THEY ARE EFFECTIVE IN
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND
TEST RESULTS SHOW THAT MOST DUAL
LANGUAGE SCHOOLS OUTPERFORM
OTHER DEMOGRAPHICALLY SIMILAR
SCHOOLS. THE STATE AND LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AS CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS ARE EXPANDED STATEWIDE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION THIS BILL PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONVERT. AN UNDER
ENROLLED SCHOOLS TO A DUAL
LANGUAGE IMMERSION SCHOOL TO
HELP ATTRACT AND RETAIN FAMILIES
IN THEIR CURRENT SCHOOLS. SB
NINE FIVE TO PROVIDE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH THE TOOL TO
INNOVATE AND ESTABLISH SCHOOL
PROGRAM MODELS THAT ARE PROVEN
TO PROMOTE STRONG ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE AMONG STUDENTS FROM
ALL BACKGROUNDS I MYSELF HAVE
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF ONE OF
THESE PUBLIC DUAL IMMERSION
SCHOOLS AND KNOW HOW EFFECTIVE
THEY ARE. KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND I ALSO
HAVE SEEN EXTREMELY LONG WAIT
LIST TO GET INTO THESE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. TODAY A WE HAVE OUR
CALIFORNIA SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND
TO ALSO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. AND WITH THAT- I WILL TURN
IT TO OUR WITNESSES GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CEREMONY WE HAVE A
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND HERE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD SIR YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES AND THEN WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR DR ANNA.
DID JENNA. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FIVE TO. A BILL THAT WE ARE
PULLED UP PLEASED TO BE A
SPONSOR OF I WANT TO THANK SAID
AMONG FOR YOUR AUTHORSHIP AND
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA. AS
YOU HEARD WE HAVE A ROBUST
HISTORY OF DUAL LANGUAGE
IMMERSION PROGRAMS IN THE STATE.
AND THE RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
THERE ARE COGNITIVE BENEFITS FOR
ANY STUDENT WHO LEARNS ONE OR
MORE LANGUAGES OR TWO OR MORE
LANGUAGES. AND SO- WE'RE ASKING
TO HAVE THESE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS
ARE PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO BE ABLE
TO- BECOME. DUAL LANGUAGE
IMMERSION SCHOOLS WE KNOW THAT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE VERY POPULAR-
THERE ARE WAITING LISTS
EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE WHERE
THERE IS INTEREST- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENT FOR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. AT A TIME WHEN OUR
SCHOOLS ARE EXPERIENCING-
DECLINING ENROLLMENT HI THIS IS
A GREAT INVESTMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS. RBC SUPPORTS
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT ACADEMIC
DEVELOPMENT SOCIAL DEVELOPMENT
I'VE HAD A CHANCE TO VISIT AND I
WANT TO THANK- THE FOLKS AT THE
WEST COUNTY MANDARIN SCHOOL- WHO
WORK WITH US TO DESIGN THIS
PROPOSAL- THIS IS A SCHOOL IN
THE WEST. AFTER UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND S. IN EARLY MULLIN
SAID THE STUDENTS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE DUAL LANGUAGE
IMMERSION PROGRAMS- DEMONSTRATE
HIGHER PERFORMANCE THAN THEIR
PEERS ACROSS THE BOARD IN NEARLY
EVERY CATEGORY. THIS IS A PROVEN
PROGRAM TO HELP CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP- TO HELP PREPARE
OUR STUDENTS TO BE GLOBAL
THINKERS OF THE WORLD- AND- I
WOULD ASK RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON S. B. NINE FIVE TWO.
I THINK YOU MISTER SUPERINTEND
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE YOU
HERE COMMITTEE WITH US THANK YOU
FOR OF SPONSORING AND SUPPORTING
THE BILL. I WE'RE NEXT GOING TO
GO TO DOCTOR ANNA DID JENNA WHO
IS ON THE LINE- THIS IS
SUPERINTENDENT. AT FOR OF
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES FOR THE
OXFORD SCHOOL DISTRICT. DOCTOR
DID JENNA ARE YOU WITH US. I AM
YES GOOD MORNING. HI GOOD
MORNING HM MA'AM THINK FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY. MY%
NAME IS ANNA CHEN AND THE
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT FOR
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES FOR THE
OXNARD SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
VENTURA COUNTY. AND AS OUR
SUPERINTENDENT THAT IT IS NO
SECRET THAT BILINGUALISM. IS
EXTREMELY BENEFICIAL FOR
STUDENTS IN DUAL LANGUAGE
IMMERSION PROGRAMS IN MY
DISTRICT. HAVE BEEN VERY WELL
RECEIVED BY OUR COMMUNITY AND
HAVE STARTED TO REALLY
DEMONSTRATE. ACHIEVEMENT OF OUR
STUDENTS IN THE PROGRAM. I DO
LANGUAGE PROGRAMS ARE BASED ON
PROVEN RESEARCH AND METHODS BOTH
IN THE CLASSROOM. I'M AND FROM
RESEARCH OF MANY YEARS ACROSS
THE NATION AND IN DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES- IT- STUDIES SHOW THAT
ARE DOING MERGING PROGRAMS ARE
BENEFICIAL BOTH FOR ENGLISH
LEARNER STUDENTS AS WELL AS
THEIR NATIVE SPANISH SPEAKER. OF
OUR TARGET LANGUAGE. AND PUT. IT
PUT THEM ON A PATH TO RECIEVE AT
THE STATE OF BY LITERACY AND IT
OPENS DOORS FOR MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS AND WHO ARE ABLE TO
PROVE THEIR- PEOPLE THEIR
BILINGUAL IT. WHEN I MENTION OR
DO WITH HIM PRO. IN OUR DISTRICT
- MEANT THAT THEY ARE VERY
POPULAR. FOR SEVERAL YEARS WE
HAD LONG WAIT LIST FOR ALL OF
OUR BY LITERACY SCHOOLS. AND IN
ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE THE REQUEST
THAT CAME FROM OUR COMMUNITY.
AND WE WOULD WE HAVE MADE A
DECISION IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
CONVERT OUR STRANDS SCHOOLS WE
HAD TEN DIFFERENT SCHOOLS TO
CONVERT OUR SAMPLES INTO FOUR BY
LITERACY SCHOOL. WE HAVE STARTED
THAT CONVERSION AND CURRENTLY.
WE ARE IN THIRD GRADE A FULL
CONVERSION AND HOPE TO CONVERT
TO A GREAT ADVOCATE DISTRICT- BY
THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY SIX WE
HOPE TO HAVE TEN OF OUR SCHOOLS
BEING FULL BY LITERACY SCHOOL. I
INTO COME. OF OUR SCHOOLS WE%
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
THE NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY. AND
IN ADDITION TO THAT HAVE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME AND RESOURCES MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE ARE. THAT WE
ARE TRAINING OUR STAFF- ON THE
ON THE PEDAGOGY THAT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR BY LITERACY
EDUCATION BUT ALSO ON. I'M
REALLY TAKING INTO ACCOUNT- ALL
THE BENEFITS THAT COME WITH THAT
IN A COMMUNITY SUCH AS OURS BUT
WE ARE ABOUT 90% HISPANIC LATINO
AND 90% OF SOCIO ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS. WE FEEL
THAT THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
PREPARING OUR STUDENTS OUR
STUDENTS FOR COLLEGE AND CAREER-
WE BELIEVE THAT IS NOT ONLY GIVE
THEM THOSE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PROFESSIONAL GROWTH IN THE
FUTURE. BUT ALSO GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY YOU BUT PLEASE MIND
OF PRIDE IN THEIR HERITAGE. AND
SO WITH THAT I'M SORRY I THOUGHT
I WOULD JUST- LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE.
AND TO ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN ENSURING
THAT WE BECOME AT. A DISTRICT
AND EIGHT EXCELLENT THANK NOT
REALLY. ON THE HILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING NOW MOVES TO SUPPORT
CARE ROUTE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED.
PLEASE COME FORWARD STATE YOUR
NAME AND SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
PLEASE GOOD MORNING JENNIFER
BAKER REPRESENTS. FORTY EIGHT
STATION FOR. MEDICATION A PROUD
CO SPONSOR IN. HERE TO URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
TO YOU SEE NOTHING ETCETERA CAL.
TOGETHER PATCO- COST AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. RIGHT SEE
NO ONE ELSE HERE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK OR
SAY THEIR NAME AND SUPPORT. FOR
SB NINE FIFTY TWO. THE MAN CARE
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX NINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN THE
WORLD ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NINETY EIGHT LINES
OPEN. AND WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
LINE TWO SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MARK THIS
YEAR AGO THE DEALS REPRESENTING
DELTA KAPPA GAMMA CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT. OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
INCLINED TO FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I CAN MORNING ON THE
ISLAND FOR THE CELL. IN THIS ONE
TO THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN IF YOUR SUPPORT OF THE S.
B. NINE FIFTY TWO. WHAT IS YOUR
NAME AND ASK THEM IN ORDER TO
SELL. THANK YOU. AND MEDICARE
AND NO FURTHER LINES OF SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL WE WILL COME TO THE
COMMITTEE AND SEE IF ANYONE HERE
WHICH IS TO OPPOSE THE BILL. SEE
NO ONE MISTER MODERATOR COULD
YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO STATE THEIR OPPOSITION
FOR SB NINE FIFTY TWO. CERTAINLY
WHAT TO GET IF YOU LIKE WE CAN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
MANAGER WITH NO ONE'S COMEDIAN
IN OPPOSITION. THE TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE DOES ANYONE
HERE ON THE COMMITTEE WISH TO
SPEAK ON THE BILL I CAN AVAIL.
OF THE BILL THANK YOU YES. JUST
A QUICK QUESTION WILL THIS.
BELIEVED WITH THIS THAT WAS BE
FUNDED ON THE GENERAL FUND OR
OUT OF THE PROPERTY ALLOCATIONS
THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION AND I
CAN GET BACK TO YOU OKAY I DON'T
HAVE THE NEED TO ANSWER UNLESS
SOMEONE HAS AN IMMEDIATE ANSWER.
WE CAN GET BACK TO YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR CORTESE. THE FIRST
POPE- LET ME SAY I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE SO I DO HAVE. TWO
QUESTIONS I'M JUST GONNA IS KIND
OF COMBINE IS ONE BECAUSE A
GROUP RELATED I GUESS. OF IT
WHAT IS THE INTENT IN TERMS OF
GETTING YOU KNOW GEOGRAPHIC
EQUITY OR OR JUST DISTRIBUTION
OF THE I KNOW YOU CAN'T CONTROL
WITH THE GRANT APPLICATIONS COME
FROM PER SE- IN THE SECOND PART
OF THAT. BUT OBVIOUSLY I WANT
TO. HAVE AN INTEREST WITH
SOMEBODY THAT HAS ALMOST THIRTY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN MY DISTRICT
YOU KNOW TO MAKE SURE THAT.
PEOPLE ARE READY SET GO ABLE TO
COMPETE- AND SECONDLY- WE RUN
INTO SOME ISSUES IN MY DISTRICT
PARTICULARLY WITH ONE OF THE-
VERY LOW INCOME DISTRICTS-
HAVING A HARD TIME EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE. TWENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS AT TWELVE CAMPUSES AND
THEY HAVE DIVERSION PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW BUT IN PASSED
IN DIFFERENT PROGRAMS OTHER NON
TO IMMERSION PROGRAMS. COMPETING
IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE. OF A
CHARTER SCHOOL ONE SINGLE
SCHOOL. HAS THE SAME APPLICATION
APPLICATION WAIT AS ALL THE
SCHOOLS AS A AS A DISTRICT THAT
HAS A DOZEN SCHOOLS IN IT THAT
IS NOT AN ANTI CHARTER COMMENT
THAT IS- AND IN EQUITY. IN
COREY- AND I DON'T PUT THAT ON
YOU BECAUSE THE L. E. A.
DEFINITION IS USED SO OFTEN
WE'VE SEEN IT ON OTHER BILLS
EVEN AT LEAST ONE OF THE BILL
EVEN TODAY. BUT I'M JUST WARNING
WITH THIS PROGRAM. YOU KNOW WHAT. THOUGHT YOU HAVE IN TERMS OF.
TRYING TO DISTRIBUTE. YES I
DEFINITELY CAN COMMENT ON THE
INTENT AND IF- FOLKS WITH WITH A
YOU KNOW OUR SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION MIGHT BE ABLE
TO THINK MORE BECAUSE IT WOULD
BE HIS. DIVISION AND DEPARTMENT
THAT WOULD- ACTUALLY DISTRIBUTE
THESE FUNDS BUT- YOU KNOW THE
INTENT IS DEFINITELY THAT THIS
IS. A DIVERSE. SET OF SCHOOLS
THAT WOULD GET A IT'S A SMALL
PROGRAM RELATIVELY SPEAKING WITH
THE NUMBER OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WE HAVE IN THE STATE AND THIS IS
A VERY POPULAR. AT CURRICULUM AT
THE MOMENT WITH A LOT OF WEIGHT
LIST SO A SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IF YOU LIKE TO MAYBE
COMMENT ON THAT LITTLE BIT MORE
THAT IS READY- INTO THE CHAIR
THE ABSOLUTELY- THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION FOR THESE WOULD BE-
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS. AND AND AS
THE SENATOR MENTIONED THIS IS A
GRANT OPPORTUNITY THAT.
DISTRICTS WOULD APPLY FOR. ANY
PUBLIC SCHOOL CAN APPLY FOR ANY
EXISTING PUBLIC SCHOOL CAN APPLY
FOR. A TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOL
OR CHARTER PUBLIC SCHOOL- CAN
APPLY FOR THESE GRANT DOLLARS
AND THAT'S HOW- THE VIA A RUBRIC
IN THE CRITERIA ESTABLISHED-
THE- ALREADY THE BILL SPELLS OUT
THAT. SCHOOLS THAT HAVE ABOUT
40% ENGLISH LEARNERS ARE AMONG
THE PRIORITY AREAS IN THE BILL.
THERE ARE A FEW CRITERIA ALREADY
ESTABLISHED THAT WOULD GO INTO
THE GRANT PROGRAM. BUT THERE BE
A FULL GROUP OF FOR MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT- THE APPLICANTS
TO BE SELECTED. GREAT I
APPRECIATE ENSURING THAT WE
JUST. SUPPORTED BECAUSE WHERE WE
DO HAVE THESE PROGRAMS IN
EXISTENCE OF MY DISTRICT THEY
BEEN GAME CHANGERS THOSE. FIRST
HAND SO THANK YOU FOR. YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BOTH OF YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL THREE.
ANYONE ELSE. ALL RIGHT CENTER
PAN I THINK YOU MOVE THE BILL
BUT SENATOR ALI WELL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I BUT- THANK YOU THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
PAN MEN CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB NINE FIFTY TO THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THAT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA HI LEYVA.
OHIO CHAU ABOVE. THE CHOI
ABOAGYE COURT THE- CURTIS THE
IDEA. GALLI GLAZER. GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE. PAN HI CAN I WRITE THE
BILL'S ENOUGH FOR GAP WE'LL WAIT
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- CENTER MODE
YOU ARE. HAVE A B. FOR ONE PER
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. SB ELEVEN FORTY ONE
EXPANDS THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
THAT QUALIFY FOR IN STATE
TUITION IN CALIFORNIA. AB FIVE
FORTY PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND
WENT TO CREATE A PATHWAY FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS TO ACCESS
HIGHER EDUCATION. UNDER EXISTING
LAW A STUDENT MUST EITHER ATTEND
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL FOR THREE
YEARS AND GRADUATE. OR ATTEND A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR
THREE YEARS AND EARN AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE. TO BE ELIGIBLE
TO TRANSFER TO A UC OR CSU. IF A
STUDENT STARTS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL THERE IS A TWO
YEAR CAP ON FULL TIME ENROLLMENT
IN CREDIT COURSES. THAT SUPPLIED
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AS A
RESULT STUDENTS MUST TAKE A
THIRTY YEAR OF NON CREDIT
COURSES TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR AB
FIVE FORTY STATUS. THIS CAUSES
STUDENTS TO TAKE COURSES THAT
THEY MEET THAT MAY NOT BE
APPLYING TO THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS. AND THE LASER TIMELINE TO
TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION. SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
ARE TRYING TO EARN AB FIVE FORTY
STATUS. SB ELEVEN FORTY ONE
EXPAND ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION BY REMOVING THIS CAP.
THE REST. TO FIVE FOR EIGHTY
FIVE FORTY. FROM THREE TO TWO
YEARS. PRIOR TO BEING ELECTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE I'VE WORKED WITH
MANY STUDENTS THAT BENEFITTED
FROM EIGHTY FIVE FORTY. THIS
BILL WILL FURTHER STUDENTS
COLLEGE ATTAINMENT AND WILL
INCREASE COLLEGE COMPLETION
RATES. EVERY STUDENT DESERVES
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AND WITH THAT I HOPE
THAT WE CAN RESPECTFULLY PASS
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR LIMÓN WE WILL GO TO YOUR
LEAD SUPPORT I BELIEVE DAVID
O'BRIEN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. VICE
CHANCELLOR GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
IS HERE IN PERSON VERY GOOD AND
THEN WE WILL GO TO ESTHER. A
SOMEBODY WHO IS A STUDENT AT EL
CAMINO COLLEGE AND IS CALLING IN
MISTER BRIAN YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DAVID O'BRIEN
IS THE CHAIR MENTIONED. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHAMP-
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WE ARE PROUD
TO SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION AND
WHEN I THINK SENDER LIMÓN FOR
HER CONSISTENT- OF LEADERSHIP
OVER MANY MANY YEARS FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS. AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED SB ELEVEN
FORTY ONE IS A BILL WHICH WILL
EXPAND ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND CREATE A MORE
EQUITABLE SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA. BY
BREAKING DOWN SOME OF THESE
BARRIERS THAT CURRENTLY EXIST
FOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS IN
MANY OTHER STUDENTS IT'S NOT
BEEN A LITTLE OVER TWENTY YEARS
SINCE CALIFORNIA CRACKED OPEN
THE DOOR TO HIGHER EDUCATION
WITH ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY.
THAT WAS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- TELLING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIA YOU BELONG IN HIGHER
EDUCATION YOU BELONG HERE YOU
DESERVE A CHANCE TO FURTHER YOUR
GOALS AND SEEK A HIGHER
EDUCATION AND CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY BY-
INCREASING YOUR CHANCES OF
EMPLOYMENT BY EARNING A DEGREE
OR CERTIFICATE. WE'RE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE WHICH WOULD
FURTHER- FURTHER EXPAND THE
GOALS OF AB FIVE FORTY BY
BREAKING DOWN SOME OF THE
BARRIERS THAT DO STILL EXIST
PARTICULARLY FOR ADULT LEARNERS
WHO IN ARE MAKING UP AN
INCREASING SHARE. OF THE
COMMUNITY CALLED POPULATION AND
THE POPULATION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AND SO WE VIEW IT AS A
THIS BEING THE TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO REAFFIRM ITS
COMMITMENT TO THE STUDENTS AND
TELL THEM ONCE AGAIN THAT YOU DO
BELONG HERE YOU BELONG IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. THANK YOU HAVE YOU
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOT GO
TO THE PHONE LINES AND WE WILL
GO TO OUR WERE STUDENT MS. UGH-
ZAMBA. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. HELLO GOOD MORNING
YEAH. I FOCUS BACK A LOT OF
FRIENDS AND ON PEOPLE BROUGHT UP
LITTLE. GOOD HI YOU HAVE SHOWN
THE- FOR ME WAYS. I THANK. AND
EMOTIONAL. ALL BECAUSE I CAN
NEED IT FIVE POINT ELIGIBLE BY
ONE. WITH A QUESTIONING HI
WITHOUT I AM ON TO THE LIKE TO
HAPPEN A MORE THAN OUT YES BUT
THE FOLKS. GOOD HI AT FEE A LOT
OF PRESSURE ON MY BECAUSE THE
ACTUAL C. HOOKED UP THANK YOU
VERY.
OKAY BECOME A DESTINATION FOR
EQUITABLE ALL ACCEPTABLE
EDUCATION. I FEEL A ONE CENT AND
HIGHER EDUCATION. THE YOU AT THE
BOARD LIKE THIS ONE HOW WOULD
YOU TO HELP THOUSANDS OF CARS
FROM THE LIKE ME. GREAT ACTING
PEOPLE CSU. FIFTY FIVE IN SCHOOL
. FOR ALLOWED. I A QUESTION
ABOUT MY FIELD ONLY BIRTH
CONTROL THE ISSUE. ASHARQ WILL
LIVE INSIDE. AND BECAUSE WITH
THE AND ECONOMIC. OKAY I REQUEST
REQUEST THAT ABLE ON THE SB
LEVEL FOR THE ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MUCH ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
ANY HERE TWENTY HUNDRED I LIKE
IT RUN TO THE MY- PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR SUPPORT OF
BILL PLEASE. GOOD MORNING THEN I
GREW PLAN ON BEHALF OF THE CAN
COLLEGE THE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THE BIG YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING JOHNSON FOR BY
PRESIDENT OF IS A FAIR THIS YEAR
AND I THINK. CAN YOU COLLEGES IN
HIGH SO. THANK YOU. SOCIAL WITH
LOS ANGELES IN SCHOOL AND- THANK
YOU. KATHLEEN TO MAKO IT CAL
CAPCOM WITH THIS BILL GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SAY THEIR NAME AND SUPPORT FOR
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY ONE. THANK
MEDICARE YEAH HE LEFT THE SPEAK
IN. THE SB ELEVEN FORTY ONE
THESE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN FIRST
GO TO ONE OF TWO SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND WE WILL DO ONE
TO THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING PROTECT BECAUSE ALL
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
BOTH WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANNEX ONE
TO SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY DO SEVENTY FIVE GOOD ONES
UP. HELLO MY NAME IS CARLOS AND
FEDERAL FUNDING FROM BECAUSE OF
ANIONS AND STRONG SUPPORTER SB
ONE ONE FOUR ONE. THANK YOU.
ADELINE YOU OLD SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS HERE LET COMMITTEE
CALLING FROM YOU COLLEGES VERY
FIRST CENTER CALLING IT JUNK
REPORT OF S. B. ONE ONE FOUR ONE
THANK YOU. AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
ONE SIXTY FIVE YOU WANT TO OPEN
. HELLO MY NAME IS AN ANAGRAM.
CAL THE CONVERTING ABOUT A
COLLEGE REPORTING- SB ONE FOUR
ONE ELEVEN FORTY ONE. I THINK.
IN ORDER LINE SEVENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS RELEASED EIGHT CENTER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
FALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
ONE LET FOR FUN THANK YOU. IN
THIS LITTLE LINE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DEFENDER LAMINE ALL AND
THE DIRECTOR OF THE INDUCTANCES
RESEARCH CENTER CALLED THE
CANYON HAWKING FROM WORK AT.
ELEVEN FORTY ONE. ONE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
REALLY LOCAL FOR CALLING BECAUSE
THEY CAN USE THAT IN THE FUTURE
AND I AM INSTRUCTED BOTH OF AS
YOU KNOW- FORTY ONE. NEXT TO
LINE SIXTIES YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AMID ALL THE CREWS BACK ON
DOCUMENTS SUCCESS COORDINATOR A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS STUFF. NEXT ONE
LINE ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS WILL THE REST
OF THE STUDENTS ARE ACTUALLY
WORKING COLLEGE IN NINE
CONFERENCE BOARD OF AT ELEVEN
FORTY ONE THANK YOU. NEXT WILL
LINE THE ONE O. Q. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
THIRTY MINUTES FROM HEATH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MISSED THE
RECORD TO NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR S. B. ELEVEN FORTY ONE THANK
YOU. NECKLINE ONE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS AN
ADVOCATE ESSENTIAL COLLEGE I IN
THE TEAM CENTER COORDINATOR AND
THE CURRENT SB SIXTY EIGHT AFTER
OF THAT AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB FORTY. ELEVEN FORTY ONE. IT
WILL GO TO LINE TWO OH THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT MARK WITH MONSTER
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIANS UP IN THE HIGHER
EXCLUSION. AND THE PROBLEM
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE ACCESS
NETWORK RESPECTFULLY REQUEST IN
I- ON SB ELEVEN FORTY ONE THANK
YOU. NEXT ONE LINE ONE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
ALEXION COVERED EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FROM COMMUNITIES IN
SCHOOLS OF LOS ANGELES CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF F. B.
ELEVEN FORTY ONE THANK YOU. NO
OTHER LINE TO FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES HI MY NAME IS
pHISPANIC BACKGROUND AND LET ME
TELL YOU I UP CLOSE THIS BILL.
MEMBER IT NOW WITH THE- MOMENT
FOR. ADD COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL SO YOU MAY WANT TO
CALL BACK. IN WE WILL ONE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MAC JERRY ON
THE OFF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT. AND WE WILL ONE ONE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DANIEL
RODRIGUEZ CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
INFORMATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN FORTY ONE. AND WE WILL
WIND UP ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS THE FEMININE
OFFER MISSION COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
IN FROM THE FINANCIAL AID
DEPARTMENT CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF AT ELEVEN FORTY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. IT WILL
ALIGN TO SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
OLIVIA REPUBLICAN COLLEGE
COORDINATOR OF THE CULTURAL
CENTER AND A DOCUMENTS TO
SUPPORT COLLEAGUES FROM SUPPORT
OF SB ONE ONE WAS FULL. AND WE
WILL GO TO ONE EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO EIGHTY THREE
OF ONE IS OPEN FOR YOUR SUPPORT
SB ELEVEN FORTY ONE. AND WE WILL
MOVE ON TO ONE FORTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GET UP AND HELP
YOU KNOW COLLEGE ROCK OR AT
SEVEN FORTY FIVE. IN WE WILL
WANT TO THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON FIVE EVEN
FIND IT ORAL DOCUMENT WITHIN
WITH A DOCTORAL DEGREE FROM THE
UC DAVIS I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL NUMBER PRETENDING
CALIFORNIA YOU'LL BE AT THE FROM
THE ASIAN BANKER FIFTY COLLEGE
DREAM CENTER AND ARLECCHINO
EDUCATIONAL. MISSION FROM OUR
DISTRICT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE WILL WANT TO NINETY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS MAUREEN
GEORGEFROM THE BATTLE BACK
COLLEGE AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND SB. ELEVEN
FORTY ONE. ADELINE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS IRIS TO GO FROM THE COLLEGE
SUPPORT CENTER I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. AT
ELEVEN FORTY ONE THANK YOU. IN
WE WILL WANT TO SIXTY FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
MOST OF THE VENAL AND I AM FROM
THE GRETZKY PROGRAM AT FULTON
COLLEGE AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
FORTY ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. IN LITTL ONE. NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS AT LEAST IN THE DIGITAL
HERNANDEZ I'M CALLING FROM B. S.
YES WE GET COLIC IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT ELEVEN FORTY ONE. AND
NOW WITH A LOOK TWENTY TWO
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CYNTHIA
CAMPBELL I'M CALLING FROM RUSSIA
THE RECORD OF THE CALL INSTANCE
TRUCK BEFORE OF ELEVEN FORTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ADELINE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS THE FACT THAT FROM
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS AND IM
AND I AM CALLING A TRUMP
SUPPORTER OF SB. ELEVEN FORTY
ONE. AND WE'RE GOING TO NINETY
NINE YOU'RE LOCKED UP IN.
ANDALITE TWO FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING AND
REYES NO ONE NEEDS SOME WORK BUT
COLLEGE AND- ALCOHOL IN
CALIFORNIA I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS I THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
MEDICARE A BILL FOR THEIR LIVES
AND SUPPORT AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR WE DO HAVE ONE
OTHER PERSON IN SUPPORT HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MANAGER DAVID
NEVIN ON BEHALF OF WHAT'S REYES
COMMUNIQU ALSO DISTRICT LONG
BEACH COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
AND PASADENA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT EXCELLENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OR THERE'S
NO LEAD OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL
DO WE HAVE ANYONE HERE TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION SEEING NO
ONE MISTER MODERATOR AND GO BACK
TO YOU TO QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO STATE THEIR NAME AND
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN FORTY
ONE. MAKE MEDICARE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN FORTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
WE WILL WANT TO FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES I HAD EARLIER- MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE ON THE LOSS IN
THE STRELA I AM NOT A FAN OF
BACKGROUND AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. IN MEDICARE WE
DO IT FOR MY COMMUNITY JUST ONE
MOMENT.
ADELINE THREE ZERO SIX THREE
OKAY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS A LEANING TOWARD THE-
FROM FULLERTON CALI I AM A
FORMER DOCUMENTS WITHIN A
PROFESSOR FOR THE COLLEGE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THE ACT IN-COURT TODAY YEAH THANK YOU. AND
MEDICARE- NO FOR THE BLIND IN
OPPOSITION AT THE TIME THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANYONE WHO
HAS ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS SENATOR DOLLY. WITH THE
MANAGER SO I- FIVE THE ED IS SB
I THINK BY FORTY THAT CREATED
THE ORIGINAL SO I MY QUESTION IS
THAT. THERE'S A THERE'S A FINITE
AMOUNT OF CAL GRANTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AND THE PREVIOUSLY
JIM. LEGISLATION ALLOWED FOR- WE
CALL DREAMERS THAT WERE IN THE
PIPELINE COMING TO BE ABLE TO GO
ON AND MAKE AN EXCESSIVE CAL
pTHE CAL GRANT HAS BEEN
OVERSUBSCRIBED IS NOT IT'S NOT.
WE GET SIX BUT- THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH MONEY TO GO AROUND SO
WHAT WHAT HOW DO YOU SEE THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION INTERACTING
THAT AND ALLEVIATE THAT SAME
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE. BECAUSE
WE'RE ACTUALLY REDUCING THE-
CRITERIA OF. OF TIME YOU HAVE TO
BE IN THE- IN THE SCHOOL TO. BE
ABLE TO APPLY FOR THE CALGARY
REYES SO THE IDEA IS THAT THIS
WOULD LIKELY INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS WHO COULD QUALIFY-
AND FOR THE CAL GRANT- THERE ARE
STILL CERTAIN EXPECTATIONS AND
THAT'S BEEN OVER SUBSCRIBED AND
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT WILL
CHANGE IT. WILL THIS CREATE MORE
OF AN OVER SUBSCRIPTION I THINK
IT REALLY DEPENDS ON WHAT WE
DECIDE TO DO WITH THE GAL GRANT
I KNOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN
MULTIPLE EFFORTS INCLUDING
CURRENTLY. ON REVAMPING THE CAL
GRANT- AND SO I'M GUESSING
YOU'RE LIKELY TO SEE THAT THAT
THOSE LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS IN
CONVERSATIONS HAPPEN BUT THIS
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE CAL GRANT
PIECE THAT THE SEPARATE PIECE.
AND I KNOW THERE ARE MEMBERS.
WHO HAVE BEEN CHAMPIONING THAT
AND I SUSPECT YOU WILL SEE THAT
BILL. THAT COME FORWARD- IN ITS
TYPE OF CONVERSATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS YES SENATOR
PAM MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE CEREMONY WHICH I
TO CLOSE THANK YOU AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS WORKED WITH THAT
THOUSANDS. OF STUDENTS- AND MANY
WHO WERE YEAH AND DOCUMENTED IN
CALIFORNIA I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT
A PROGRAM LIKE THIS MEANS. FOR
STUDENTS WHO GREW UP HERE TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
SCHOOL HERE AND CONTRIBUTE. YOU
HEARD PEOPLE WHO ARE DOCTORS.
YOU KNOW WHO HAVE. COMPLETED
THEIR THEIR DOCTORATE AND
MASTER'S DEGREE UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREES AND WHO STAY IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AD SO THIS IS AN
UNBELIEVABLE INVESTMENT. AND WE
ARE HOPING TO MAKE IT MORE
EFFICIENT- YOU DON'T NEED TO
TAKE AN EXTRA YEAR OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. NON CREDIT CLASSES.
JUST TO GO TO A FOUR YEAR SCHOOL
AND BE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR
THIS THIS IS ABOUT AND
INVESTMENT- AND THE DATA HAS
SHOWN. THAT THERE ARE STUDENTS
STAY HERE- AND THEY REALLY DO
BECOME AND THEY LOOK FOR OTHER
PATHWAYS. AT TO BECOME. FULLY
FULLY YOU KNOW MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IDOL.
YOU SENATE LIMÓN. THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SEN PAN.
CONSULTANT CALL THE ROLL. BY
LAW. SHE'S ME FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB ELEVEN FORTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. LEYVA I LEAVE I-
CHAU ABOVE. OR TROUBLED AYE
COURTESY. AYE COURTESY AYE DALLY
. GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE. PAN
HI CAN I THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT BUT WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER THE MOUND. ALL RIGHT
SENATOR SKINNER YOU WERE UP NEXT
WITH SB EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANKS SO MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS. I'M SB EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH WE'VE DUBBED
TO THE ROAD TO SUCCESS.
TECHNOLOGISTS THAT CALIFORNIA IS
AN OUT LIAR AMONGST ALL THEIR
STATES IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
HOME TO SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION.
WE ONLY PROVIDE 9% OF OUR KIDS
THAT GO TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS WITH A
BUS RIDE. AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY- I THINK
WE ARE IN THE BOTTOM OF THOSE.
MARKS THE LOWEST FIVE STATES IF
NOT THE LOWEST STATE WITH IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING-
TRANSPORTATION TO SCHOOL NOW WHY
IS THAT IMPORTANT- THE SURVEYS
WE CALIFORNIA HAS A PRETTY HIGH
ABSENTEEISM RATE FOR OUR- K.
THROUGH THREE THIRD GRADE
STUDENTS IN IN THE SURVEYS. OF
WIRE THESE CHILDREN MISSING
SCHOOL IT IS COME OUT AGAIN AND
AGAIN FOR MANY OF THEM IT WAS
LACK OF TRANSPORTATION. NOW WE
KNOW THAT IF YOU MISS SCHOOL IN
THAT CRITICAL TIME PERIOD THOSE
EARLY GRADES YOU FALL BEHIND. IN
SCHOOL. AND SO IF WE CAN PROVIDE
ANSWERED THAT ONE QUESTION BY
PROVIDING SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION
THEN WE'VE ADDRESSED A VERY
IMPORTANT SCHOOL SUCCESS ISSUE.
NOW IT WAS AFTER PROP THIRTEEN
THAT CALIFORNIA REALLY REDUCE
THE FUNDING TO SCHOOLS REGARDING
TRANSPORTATION WHICH WE AT THAT
POINT THERE COULD HAVE BEEN
THERE IS SOME LOGIC BECAUSE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY
STAYED IN THE CLASSROOM BUT
WE'RE IN A DIFFERENT POSITION
NOW WE'RE IN A HEALTHIER BUDGET
SITUATION. AND THE WAY THE BILL
IS CONSTRUCTED IT WOULD ALLOW
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO UTILIZE
PUBLIC TRANSIT PUBLIC TRANSIT IF
IT IS AVAILABLE IN THAT AREA OR
TO UTILIZE- CONTRACT SERVICES
WITH OF COURSE A PROPERLY
QUALIFIED DRIVERS SO THERE'S
SOME FLEXIBILITY. AND I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES WHO
WERE BRIEFED AMENDMENTS WHICH
ARE TO DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION
SO THAT- WE CAN GUARANTEE THAT-
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS A FREE
BUS RIDES BY TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT AND THAT THE BROUGHT THE
SMARTEST OF THAT IS A
TECHNOLOGIST THAT. THERE'S A
VARIETY OF THINGS THAT COULD-
MAKE THIS DIFFICULT TO IMPLEMENT
RIGHT AWAY WHETHER IT'S THE
SUPPLY SHORTAGE AROUND- SCHOOL
BUS AVAILABILITY OR- DRIVER
SHORTAGES ARE VERY THINGS LIKE
THAT SO OF COURSE WE WANT TO
ACHIEVE THIS WE DON'T WANT TO
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR OUR
SCHOOLS. ON THE OTHER AMENDMENT
IS TO- AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WILL DELAY THE REQUIRED
IMPLEMENTATION WE WOULD NOT
PREVENT ANY OF THOSE SCHOOLS
THAT ARE ABLE AND READY TO
PROVIDE THIS TRANSPORTATION NOW.
TO DO IT SO AND THEN LASTLY TO
REPLACE THE PROPOSED FUNDING
FORMULAS. WITH THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD BE REIMBURSED A
100% FOR SCORE CURRENT SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION COSTS AND THE
COSTS RAMPING UP. TO THE TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT UNIVERSAL OUT
UNIVERSAL OFFERING POLICIES ALL
RIGHT TO LET ME JUST MOVED TO MY
WITNESSES. I'VE GOT BETH
MEYERHOFF OF THE CALIFORNIA PTA
SHE'S GOING TO BE JOINING US BY
TELEPHONE IN MATTHEW THOMAS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS
WITH HERE IN PERSON. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER LET'S
START WITH YOUR IN PERSON
SUPPORT MR MATTHEW THOMAS.
PLEASE FOR C. WHEN YOU'RE READY
OF TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING I
MATTHEW THOMAS I'M THE DIRECTOR
TRANSPORTATION FOR GARDEN GROVE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS BETTER
KNOWN AS CASTRO OUR ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTS APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. CASTOR WAS FOUNDED
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT TO
PROMOTE SAFE SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA PUPILS. WE ARE
DEDICATED TO THE SAFETY OF ALL
CHILDREN THROUGHOUT EDUCATION
AND TRAINING AND EVERY AVENUE OF
TRANSPORTATION SCHOOL BUSES ARE
THE SAFEST FORM OF
TRANSPORTATION IN THE NATION.
CASTOR WAS RECOGNIZED BY STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES AND OTHER
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS AS
THE LEADER OF SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
ORGANIZATIONS STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT. THE
REASON IS THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA RANKS DEAD LAST IN
THE UNITED STATES IN NEARLY
EVERY METRIC. WE ARE THE SAFEST
STATE WHEN IT COMES TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
SCHOOL. THIS WOULD ALSO REDUCE
SCHOOL SITE TRAFFIC AND SAVE.
FUEL AND EMISSIONS. AS SENATOR
SKINNER NOTED ONLY 9% OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL KIDS TAKE A
SCHOOL BUS. TO SCHOOL EACH DAY
THAT'S THE LOWEST PERCENTAGE IN
THE NATION THE NATION AVERAGE IS
ABOUT THIRTY SIX PERCENT.
CALIFORNIA ALSO SPENDS THE LEAST
AMOUNT PER STUDENT ON SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION OF ANY STATE SB
EIGHT SB EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT WELL
ALIGNED CALIFORNIA WITH OTHER
STATES ON HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION. IT WILL ALSO
IMPROVE STUDENT SAFETY WHICH IS
THE MAIN MISSION OF OUR
ORGANIZATION ACCORDING TO
FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION ABOUT 14% OF
CARTS SHIPS DURING MORNING RUSH
HOURS. ARE FOR SCHOOL RELATED
TRAVEL REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
CARS TRAVELING TO AND FROM
SCHOOLS EACH DAY WILL IMPROVE
SAFETY FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. FOR THOSE
REASONS I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON
SB EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT AND I THINK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER THOMAS WE WILL NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MR A
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN QUEUE UP MS
MEYERHOFF AND SHE HAS TWO
MINUTES AS WELL. AND THEY'RE
GOING TO OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS BETH MEYER HOPPED NINE
EDUCATION LEGISLATION ADVOCATE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARENT
TEACHER ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IS AN ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS WHOSEMISSION
IS TO POSITIVELY IMPACT THE
LIVES OF ALL CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. CALIFORNIA STATE PTA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT WHICH WILL
ENSURE THAT EVERY PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENT PKT TWELFTH GRADE IS
OFFERED A FREE BUS RIDE TO AND
FROM THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOL
EACH DAY. LAST OF GUARANTEED
TRANSPORTATION TO SCHOOL WAS ONE
OF THE MOST COMMON REASONS FOR
UNEXCUSED ABSENCES FROM SCHOOL
ACCORDING TO A RECENT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION REPORT.
WE BELIEVE THAT SB EIGHT SEVEN
ABLE GREATLY REDUCE ABSENTEEISM
. RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS THAT
CHRONIC BSENTEEISM CORRELATES
HIGHLY WITH LOWER STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT AND LOWER GRADUATION
RATES. CALIFORNIA'S LEFT SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION PLACES UNDUE
BURDENS ON FAMILIES ESPECIALLY
FOR LOW INCOME WORKING FAMILIES
. SOME FAMILIES IN RURAL AREAS
TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES TO DROP
OFF AND PICK UP THEIR STUDENT.
DISTRICT PROVIDED TRANSPORTATION
ELIMINATES THAT TRAVEL TIME FOR
FAMILIES AS WELL AS HELP RESOLVE
CONFLICTS FOR WORKING FAMILIES
WHO SCHEDULES MAY NOT PERMIT
GIVING STUDENTS A RIDE TO SCHOOL
. SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CURRENTLY CHARGE FAMILIES TO
RIDE THE BUS. OR FAMILIES THAT
PAY FOR PUBLIC TRANSLATE TO
TRANSPORT THEIR STUDENTS TO
SCHOOL. IN SOME AREAS THE COST
IS AS MUCH AS TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY DOLLARS PER MONTH PER
STUDENT THAT IS SIMPLY
UNAFFORDABLE FOR FAMILIES WITH
LIMITED RESOURCES. CALIFORNIA
STATE TEACHERS BELIEVE THIS BILL
WILL HELP HIS BREAK FROM THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO INCREASING
STUDENT PARTICIPATION IN
GRADUATION RATES. IT WILL BE
GUARANTEED A WAY TO GET TO
SCHOOL DAY AND FAMILIES WON'T
HAVE TO DRIVE HOURS A DAY OR
HAVE TO PAY ON AFFORDABLE FEES
FOR BUS TRANSPORTATION. SB EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT WILL IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF MILLIONS OF STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA. I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
PRESENTABLE EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL GO
TO ANY SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. THE STEP UP
STATE YOUR NAME AND SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. UGH GOOD MORNING
MORNING MISTY WALKABOUT THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT. OVER SUPPORTERS
BUILDING I THINK CENTER SKINNER
FOR INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE
TERRIFIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING SONG LAW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WHERE CO SPONSOR OF
SB EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT. REALLY
WANT TO THINK THAT COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THESE AMENDMENTS AND WE'RE
REALLY HAPPY WITH THE BILL OF
SALE I. URGE YOUR I THINK THANK
YOU. CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH
AYE CHAU WE REPRESENT THE MOST
POPULOUS SCHOOL DISTRICT THIS IS
AN ISSUE LIMITED JUST ROLL
AREAS- DESPITE PROXIMITY THERE'S
A NUMBER OF ACCESSIBILITY
ISSUES. FOR OUR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE OF OUR LOW
INCOMES ARE REALLY APPRECIATIVE
OF THE COMMITTEE'S WORK TO MAKE
THIS. HAPPEN TODAY AND WE- WE
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHAEL RAY AND I AM A RETIRED
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION DIRECTOR
OF A GPA. OF SEVENTEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. I'VE ALSO BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS FOR CASTRO. I'VE BEEN
AFFECT MATT CONSULTANT FOR
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS IN THE AREA
OF SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION. IN
ALSO CAL'S BOSE TEACHER OF THEIR
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION LEADERSHIP
PROGRAM. I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROGRAM. BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
SOME AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE. WHO
WISHES TO STATE THEIR NAME AND
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK MEDICARE IN ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU CAN SUPPORT OF SP
EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. IT'LL BE JUST ONE
MOMENT WHEN WE HAVE ONE
COMMITTED.
IT A LITTLE ONE TO THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
NICK RADO I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
MEDICARE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A ONE PERSON WHO IS LEAD
OPPOSITION AND IS HERE IN-PERSON. VERY GOOD MISTER JEFFREY
BACHA CHIEF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
OFFICER DIVISION OF GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS RIVERSIDE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION THAT IS A
MOUTHFUL PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WELCOME- JEFF AKA REPRESENTED
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS. TWENTY THREE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SUPERINTENDENTS OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. OUR POSITION
AS OUTLINED IN YOUR COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
AS IT WAS INTRODUCED THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED BY SENATOR SKINNER
TODAY. I'M AND WE THANK HER FOR
ACCEPTING THOSE AGO A LONG WAY
TOWARD RESOLVING OUR CONCERNS WE
ALWAYS SHARE THE GOALS OF
SENATOR SKINNER. OUR ISSUES WERE
WITH THE STRUCTURAL DETAILS OF
HOW YOU GET THERE WE'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION WITH
THE SENATOR AND HER STAFF AND
WITH YOUR STAFF AS WELL. WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
CONCERN ABOUT EVEN A DELAYED
MANDATE ABOUT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED TODAY- WE ARE ABLE TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
SKINNER AND HER STAFF OTHER
SPONSORS AND- AND PARTICULAR
MADAM CHAIR YOU AND YOUR STEELY
EYED CONSULTANT MR JOHNSON WHO.
REALLY WENT ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
CALL OF DUTY AND WORKING WITH
ALL OF US ON THIS THANK YOU. WAS
OUR PLEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT ONE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE THE
BILL SEE NO ONE WE WILL GO TO
THE- PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO STATE THEIR NAME
IN OPPOSITION. TO SB EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK MENTAL
AGAIN PEOPLE TO SPEAK NOW. OF
THE EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE. AND MEDICARE ME JUST
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A LINE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
A LITTLE LINE ONE FIFTY FOR YOUR
LOTUS OPEN. GOOD MORNING SURELY
THAT WOULD CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOL
RECONCILIATION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THAT'S CURRENTLY IN FRANCE I'M
ALWAYS BEHALF CONCERNS AROUND
THE MANDATE WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR OF WORKING
WITH FAST AND THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING TAKEN
TODAY WE ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND HER STAFF AGAIN. MAIN
ANYTHING SEUN JOHNSON- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING TO WORK. YUP- THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. YEAH MEDICARE WE HAVE NO
FOR THEIR LINES IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANYONE IS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
CENTER DALIAN FAIR CORTESE. THE
MANAGER- SO SOMEBODY REPRESENTS
A VERY RULE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND- I'M I'M ONLY OFF YOUR BILL
TODAY I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
DETAIL- THAT NEEDS TO BE WORKED
OUT AND- AS YOU KNOW- CALIFORNIA
PASSED TO. THE ACT ERROR ERROR
RESOURCE BOARD PASSED THE TRUCK
AND BUS RULE WHICH- TO IMPLEMENT
EVEN THOSE REGULATIONS AND
MANDATE THOSE OUT EVEN FOR FIVE
YEARS IS GONNA BE REALLY COSTLY-
TO SOME OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO MEET THE
STANDARDS THAT CALIFORNIA SETS
THE BAR REALLY HIGH FOR SO I'M
GONNA. I'M GONNA HOPE YOU'RE
GOING TO GET THERE BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S- REALLY CRITICAL THAT
WE DO GET TO OUR OUR OUR
CHILDREN SAFELY TO SCHOOL BUT-
HOW WE'RE GONNA GET OUR TO DO IT
IS I THINK THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAIL SO I'M ONLY OFF YOUR BILL
TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
WHAT THE AMENDMENTS AND MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER DALITS CENTER CORTESE.
HELLO THANK YOU THE AUTHOR OF
FOR. DOING THIS WORK AND I'M
VERY SUPPORTIVE- THAT IS
INFORMED BY NINETEEN PASSED BUS
TRIPS TO SACRAMENTO ON EDUCATION
THE- I USED TO CONDUCT AS LOCAL
OFFICIALS WERE TRYING TO
CONTINUE THAT NOW- IN MY IN MY
APRIL HERE'S A STATE SENATOR BUT
ON VIRTUALLY EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE TRIPS- WERE STUDENTS WERE
PRESENT HE TESTIFIED- AS TO THIS
NEED. NOT SO MUCH FOR THEMSELVES
ANYMORE BUT WAS PARTICULARLY
THOSE WITH BROTHERS AND SISTERS
THAT WERE COMING UP- HEARD
THROUGH THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN TYPICALLY THE
TESTIMONY MOVED HERE IS I DO NOT
WANT MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS
HAVE TO GO THROUGH WHAT I WENT
THROUGH- IN TERMS OF LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION- JUST AS FAR AS
FEEDBACK- WHICH YOU MAY OR MAY
NOT- EMBRACE. OF FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS SAID UP TO SOLVE
OPERATE- IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
DISTANCE REQUIREMENTS CAN BE
DRAMATICALLY REDUCED IN IN IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF MY DISTRICT
THAT WOULD BE REALLY CONDUCIVE
TO STUDENT SAFETY- WHERE WE
HAVE. EVERYTHING FROM RIVAL
GREAT GANGS TO JUST PARTS OF OUR
CITY THE UNFORTUNATELY OUR
WALKABLE- ENOUGH IN IN UNIL
HALF A MILE IS OFTEN. USED IN
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AS A- THE
A FAIR DOES- WE TRY TO USE-
EIGHT HUNDRED FEET- MORE LIKE A
QUARTER MILE EIGHT HUNDRED TO
TWELVE HUNDRED FEET- OFTENTIMES
AS CRITERIA. YOU KNOW IN OUR OWN
AREA ESPECIALLY MOST DIFFICULT-
PUBLIC SAFETY AREAS SO JUST
WANTED TO OFFER THAT SUGGESTION-
IF. HE PUT SOME POINT OF THAT
MIGHT BE EMBRACE WITH THAT- I'M
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL-
THINKCENTRE CORTESE ANYONE ELSE
. ALL RIGHT MADAM CHAIR OF
VENTURE MEN BUDGET CHARM SO USED
TO CALLING YOU SENATOR SKINNER
SAME THING OF THE I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FOR IT I'M HAPPY TO BE A CO
AUTHOR AND WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING SO HARD
WITH ME AND WITH MY COMMITTEE
STAFF THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WHICH ARE OUTLINED ON PAGES
SEVEN AND EIGHT IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS PRESERVE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT ALL PUPILS BE
OFFERED FREE HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION WHILE
COMPLICATING THE FOLLOWING. GIVE
ELEAZAR TIME TO RAMP UP THEIR
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS BY
DELAYING AND DELAYING THE
DIRECTIVE FOR ELEAZAR TO OFFER
UNIVERSAL TRANSPORTATION FOR
FIVE YEARS CHANGE THE PROPOSED
FUNDING METHODOLOGIES SUCH THAT
ELLIE IS WOULD BE REIMBURSED FOR
A 100% OF THEIR APPROVED
TRANSPORTATION COSTS WITH AN
ANNUAL COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
CLARIFIED THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN REQUIRED BY
ELEAZAR MUST BE PRESENTED
PUBLICLY WITH AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IN PERSON AND
VIRTUALLY THE GOAL OF THESE
AMENDMENTS IS TO HELP SET ELOISE
UP FOR SUCCESS. BY GIVING THEM
ADEQUATE TIME TO PURCHASE BUSES
HIRE QUALIFIED DRIVERS DESIGN
OPTIMAL BUS ROUTES AND MUCH MORE
THAT WE PROBABLY DON'T EVEN KNOW
FURTHER I BELIEVE IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT WE ENSURE THE
FUNDING PROVIDED TO CARRY OUT
THIS REQUIREMENT IS STABLE AND
RESPONSIVE TO THE REGIONAL AND
GEOGRAPHIC DIFFERENCES AMONG THE
OVER ONE THOUSAND ELOISE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE A CO AUTHOR I
THINK THIS IS A LONG OVERDUE
ISSUE. YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
M. YES YOUR ESSAY INDICATED IN
ACCEPTING THE MINIATURE
COMMITTEE SPEND REALLY YOU ENTER
COMMITTEE AND DO NOT WANT TO IN
IN NOT IMPLICATE THAT YOU AS THE
LEADER OF THE COMPETITOR OF
ACTUALLY BEEN PIVOTAL TO THIS
AND- THE DIEM IN MATH ARE AN
IMPROVEMENT TO THE BILL- I
WANTED TO. SEE WILL POINTS THAT
ON SOME OF THE FOLKS SPOKE ABOUT
I DIDN'T SO MUCH BRING UP BUT
THE THOSE PARENTS OR FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO CAN DRIVE THEIR KIDS. TO SCHOOL WHEN THEY DO AND
THERE'S NO OTHER TRANSPORTATION
THEY CREATE A LOT OF CONGESTION
NEAR THE SCHOOL SITE. AND THEN
YOU HAVE OTHER KIDS WALKING AND
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S A HIGH
PEDESTRIAN DEATHS PEDESTRIAN
ACCIDENT RATE AROUND SCHOOLS.
AND SO IF WE CAN JUST REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF CARS COMING INTO A
SCHOOL EVERY DAY THAT WOULD BE A
HUGE HELP- AND- ON- YOU KNOW
WHETHER AIR QUALITY OR
DISPOSSESSED AND SAFETY YOU NAME
IT. AND THEN TO SENATOR
CORTESE'S POINT. YES A HALF A
MILE WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE
LITTLE LITTLE KIDS THAT YOU KNOW
THAT'S THE DISTANCE SO WE YOU
KNOW THERE MAY BE THE ABILITY TO
MODIFY. SAY FOR THE LOWER GRADES
OR YOU KNOW WE'LL HAVE TO SEE AS
THE BILL MOVES THROUGH. THOUGH
CERTAINLY YOUR POINT ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY FOR THE OLDER
GRADES IS ALSO TRUE THOUGH IT
MAY BE HARDER. TO REQUIRE- THE
TRANSPORT FOR THE SHORTER
DISTANCES SAY IN HIGHER GRADES
BUT ANYWAY WE ARE DEFINITELY WE
WILL CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD I
THINK YOU BROUGHT UP SOME VALID
POINTS. SO WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR BILL THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER THE BILL WAS MOVED BY
CENTER CORTESE MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. LEYVA HI LEYVA
IOTA ABOVE. THE TROUBLED BY
POTENTIALLY. CORTEZ THE AYE DALY
. PLAY GLAZER I. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE PAN ALL RIGHT. AM I. THE
BILL'S BUT WE WILL- WE ARE ALL
HERE THAT BILL IS OUT AND OUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER ALL
RIGHT OF CENTER BRADFORD WAS
HERE BUT I DON'T SEE HIM NOW. SO
CENTER DOLLY IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL. PLEASE
KERETA HEAD HURRY REAL FAST.
SOMETIMES AUTHORS IN. ALRIGHT
ALL RIGHT SENATOR DOLE IS GOING
2% FILE ITEM TEN SB ONE TWO TWO
TWO CENTER AT ALL IF FORESHORES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AYE- I BROUGHT THIS BILL FOR
LAST YEAR IS THE EXACT SAME BILL
AND- IT'S- IT SB A LET AT TWELVE
TWENTY TWO. REQUIRES THAT SEXUAL
EDUCATION MATERIALS BE POSTED
ONLINE FOR PARENTS AND STUDENTS
TO BE ABLE TO REVIEW THEM GIVEN
THE CURRENT DISTANCE LEARNING
EDUCATION SYSTEM PARENTS OFTEN
TIMES CANNOT PHYSICALLY VISIT
THE SCHOOL ACQUIRED MATERIALS
THAT WILL BE TAUGHT TO THEIR
CHILDREN. THE SHIFT IN INTERNET
BASED DISTANCE LEARNING HAS
PROVIDED AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SCHOOLS TO GET PARENTS MORE
ENGAGED IN THEIR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION. AND THIS BILL HELPS
FOR THAT GOAL. ALL WE'RE DOING
IS ENSURING THAT PARENTS CAN BE
ENGAGED AT THE LEVEL THEY CHOOSE
THEIR CHILD'S EDUCATION WITH ME
TO TESTIFY TODAY IS KATHLEEN TO
MANY. DEMEANING CO. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CATHOLIC-
CONFERENCE AND I ALSO HAVE LANCE
CHRISTIANSEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
POLICY CENTER HERE TODAY.
TRAFFIC STRICTLY ASPEN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY ALL
RIGHT- WE HAVE LANCE
CHRISTIANSEN AND KATHLEEN TO
MINGLE BOTH HERE PERSON. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST. STEP
RIGHT UP. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S KATHLEEN TO MAKO I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
AND I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
TWENTY TWO. SO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY YOUTH ACT PROVIDES FOR
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL EDUCATION
AND HIV PREVENTION EDUCATION FOR
STUDENTS IN GRADES SEVEN THROUGH
TWELVE. ALLOWS FOR SIMILAR
EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS IN GRADES
EARLIER THAN EIGHT THEN SEVENTH
WITH AGE APPROPRIATE AND
MEDICALLY ACCURATE INFORMATION.
MYSELF I THINK WE'VE ALL HAD
THIS JOINT COBIT EXPERIENCE
WHERE IF YOU HAVE YOUNG ENOUGH
KIDS WHO ARE IN SCHOOL SITTING
MAYBE NEXT YEAR AT THE KITCHEN
COUNTER IF YOU WERE WORKING AND
THEY WERE DOING AT SCHOOL. WE
HAD AN INSIDE VIEW INTO WHAT
THEY WERE LEARNING IN THEIR
CLASSROOMS I THINK IT'S BECOME
MORE AND MORE APPARENT THAT
PARENTS REALLY WANT TO BE A PART
OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS. I LEARN
THINGS WITH MY FOURTH GRADER AND
HAD SOME REALLY GREAT
CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM AND I
THINK THAT'S REALLY WHAT PARENTS
WANT TO DO SO WITH IT. WE'RE
JUST ASKING FOR TWO ZERO ASKING
FOR PARENTS TO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SEE WHAT'S BEING TAUGHT FOR
THEIR TRIP TO THEIR CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY AROUND THESE VERY
SPECIFIC. AND IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS SO THAT THEY CAN
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEIR CHILDREN AROUND THE DINNER
TABLE SO THEY CAN BRING THEIR
OWN NARRATIVE IN THEIR OWN
FAMILY STORIES TO BEAR. AS THEY
SHARE THEIR VALUES ABOUT THIS
THIS IMPORTANT INFORMATION
CALIFORNIA KIND OF COMFORT. IN
STRENGTHENING THOSE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND OUR PARENTS BY
MARTIN. RECOGNIZING THE ROLE
THAT PARENTS PLAY AND IN THE
NATION. WE AFFIRM THE PARENTAL
HUMAN RIGHT TO DIRECT AND TO BE
FULLY ENGAGED IN THEIR OWN
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION. AND THEN
CURRENT STATE LAW AT THE
LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZES SAYS THAT
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS OF THE
ALTERNATE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
IMPARTING VALUES REGARDING HUMAN
SEXUALITY TO THEIR CHILDREN.
THIS BILL AFFIRMS THAT
RECOGNITION AND STREAMLINES THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARENTS TO
ENGAGE IN INJURY. THE LEVINE
AFTER THEIR CHILDREN. THANK AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR AND TWELVE
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU MISTER
MAKER MISTER CHRISTIAN
CHRISTIANSEN. THESE ARE GONNA BE
WITH YOU AGAIN LANCE
CHRISTIANSEN THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF EDUCATION POLICY AND
GOVERNANCE AFFAIRS OF THE
COMPANY POLICY CENTER AN ALUM OF
THE SENATE. GOOD TO BE HERE WITH
YOU TODAY. HI CALIFORNIA POLICY
CENTER IS AGNOSTIC ON MOST
CURRICULUM WE WISH THE BEST MOST
OPEN TRANSPARENT SYSTEM THAT'S
WHERE YOU'RE FROM THIS BILL. WE
SIZE AS RESPONDED PANDEMIC
BARRISTER POSTING CORRECT I
CURRICULA LINE OR IN OTHER
PORTALS HAVE BASICALLY BEEN
ELIMINATED AND THE VIRTUAL
QASSEM HAVEN'T BEEN DIMINISHED
ALMOST ZERO. AND WE THINK THAT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO THAT STATE CAN
DO THIS VERY EFFECTIVELY QUICKLY
ANDWITHOUT MUCH COST. FURTHER
THE IMPACTS OF THE COLLEGE-
EXCUSE ME OF THE COVETED-
PANDEMIC IN THE LOCKDOWNS. IT
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR A LOT OF
WORKING PARENTS AGAIN AND TO
OBSERVE WAS HAPPY TO COULD
SCHOOLS IF THEY COULD GET THERE
AT ALL. AND SO FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN INDEPENDENT STUDY HOME
SCHOOL OR CHARTER SCHOOLS. THEY
ALREADY HAVE ACCESS TO YOUR
CURRICULUM PARENTS ARE MORE
INVOLVED IN THAT CONVERSATION WE
BELIEVE THE SAME THING THROUGH
SB TWELVE TWENTY TWO IN SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR CHRISTIANSEN IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN. TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
WHO WISHES TO STATE YOUR NAME
AND SUPPORT FOR SB ONE TWO TWO
TWO. GO RIGHT AHEAD. AS A PARENT
WHO HAD DIFFICULTY- SEEING
MATERIAL AT THEIR OWN SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I'M IN SUPPORT OF
TWELVE TWENTY TWO AND MY NAME IS
DENISE PORSCHE THANK YOU DENISE
. THANK YOU. SENATOR DELHI FOR
BRINGING THIS UP I'M A RETIRED
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER. HAD A
TRAINING ON CSE IDEAL THE MEN
SUPPORT IN SUPPORT IN ENDING
CONFUSION FOR PARENTS WHAT WAS
YOUR NAME LISA JUST BROKE THANK
YOU LISA. MY NAME IS ROCHELLE
CONNOR I AND THE LEGISLATIVE
LIAISON FOR CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA I AM ALSO A GRANDMOTHER
AND GREAT GRANDMOTHER AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
ASK FOR YOUR I THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN TWENTY YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME' GREG BURKE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANKS
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MISTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO STATE THEIR NAME IN
SUPPORT OF. SB ONE TWO TWO TWO.
THANK MEDICARE IN PLACE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
. AND ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS RACHEL
CORRECTIONAL THAN I SUPPORT
TWELVE TWENTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
AND ONE THREE EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI I AM ACTUALLY IN
OPPOSITION. GREAT WILL COME BACK
TO YOU. AND WE WILL ALIGN THREE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
NINE YEAR BREAK ALL HIGH AND-
APPARENT AND- I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF IT BECAUSE I STILL
GOT ON HERE SHOULD BE INVOLVED
AND WE PICKED A DELINEATED FOR
LIKE YOU VERY MUCH SIX COLONIES.
IN A LITTLE TO THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO BLIND THREE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS UP AND-
HI AND MY NAME EXCEPT AGAIN THEN
AND I AM IN STRONG AND FAVOR AT
THIS BILL TO PASS PARENTS NEED
TO BE INVOLVED. THANK YOU. AND
GO TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES I AM IN STRONG
FAVOR OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
HOLYOKE THANK YOU. IN ORDER TO
ALIGN THREE TWENTY FOR YOUR
LINES UP AND. YES ANY HEARINGS
IN CONGRESS AND EAGLE COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. IT WILL GO UP TO ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
STE MY THIRTY THREE ARE YOU
SUPPORTIVE SB TWELVE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINES OPEN. NEARLY WE CAN'T
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. POPULAR
PHOTO RIVERSIDE COUNTY- SPOCK
ONCE BEFORE I OF THE VOTE TO
PREPAY PROPOSED CHANGES TO
THOSE- IF YOU CAN THANK YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND MEDICARE
A NO FOR THE LINES IN SUPPORT AT
THE TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE ROOM. WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB ONE
TWO TWO TWO. SENSORS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION YOU MAY HAVE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU'RE WELCOME- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CARLOS
MACHADO WITH CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION- FIFTY MUST
REGAIN WRITTEN. REGRETTABLY
OPPOSE- S. B. TWELVE TWENTY TWO
HOWEVER WE DO APPRECIATE- THE
AUTHORS- BUT WILLING TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS FROM LAST YEAR'S BILL
TO REMOVE THE IMPLEMENTATION.
IMPEDIMENTS TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THE TRANSLATIONS THAT LAST
YEAR'S BILL HAD HAD REQUIRED-
THE BILL WOULD MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR ELEAZAR TO OBTAIN
MATERIALS FOR THE UNIT ON A
SEXUAL HEALTH AND HIV PREVENTION
EDUCATION. AND THE MORE
DIFFICULT SERVE STUDENTS- INTEL
TO DISTRICT STAFF CHARGED WITH
MANAGING- THE CURRICULUM AND
PARENT OUTREACH- WE'VE HEARD
THAT- DISTRICTS HAVE FOUND THAT
THE USE OF TRAINED STAFF. HAVE
BEEN MOST EFFECTIVE IN ANSWERING
THAT TEMPLE QUESTIONS THEY
RECEIVE FROM PARENTS. THESE
INTERACTIONS ALLEVIATE MOST OF
THE CONCERNS THAT PARENTS HAVE
WITH THE UNIT AND MATERIALS. I
DISTRICTS ALSO HIGHLIGHTED- THAT
PARENTS AND OTHER COMMUNITY
MEMBERS SUCH AS STATE LEADERS
AND COMMUNITY NONPROFITS FOR
EXAMPLE ARE INVOLVED IN THE TOOL
SELECTION. BEFORE THEY ARE USED
IN THE CLASSROOM. I DISSENT- IS
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND PARENTS TO
INSPECT THE MATERIALS BEFORE
THEY ARE ROLLED OUT FOR ACTUAL
USE. ADDING A NEW REQUIREMENT-
TO THESE MATERIALS IT MAKES.
MATERIALS AVAILABLE AT SCHOOL
SITES- BYPASSES THESE EXISTING
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW AND MAY
MAKE IT HARDER FOR PARENTS TO-
BE INVOLVED IN IN THE SELECTION
PROCESS. AND HAVE THEIR VOICES
HEARD- SB TWELVE TWENTY TWO
THREATENS TO DISRUPT THE CURRENT
SELECTION AND ADOPTION PROCESS
CURRICULUM MATERIALS USUALLY
HAVE AN EIGHT TO TEN YEAR CYCLE-
WHICH WOULD BE CUT SHORT AS MANY
MATERIALS ARE NOT AVAILABLE EVEN
AND- ELECTRONIC VERSIONS- THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED BY THE BILL. I
LIKE MATH AND ENGLISH OF COURSE
MATERIALS WHERE YOU MIGHT HAVE
AS MANY AS TWENTY FIVE- MORE. I
TWENTY FIVE OR MORE DIFFERENT
CHOICES OF COURSE MATERIALS
THERE MIGHT ONLY BE THREE OR
FEWER- OPTIONS FOR- FOR THESE-
FOR THIS UNIT. THE BILL ALSO
COMPLICATES COMPLIANCE WITH
AUDITS AND MONITORING OF LEDS.
BY REQUIRING EVERY SCHOOL SITE
TO MAKE CURRICULUM TAX THAT'S
TWO MINUTES IF YOU WRAP UP
PLEASE SURE- SO I AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT-
AND- I. WE APPRECIATE HIS
EFFORTS TO KIND OF- MAKE THIS. A
LITTLE EASIER FOR DISTRICTS TO
IMPLEMENT BUT WE STILL HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL PLEASE. ANY
CHALLENGE THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION APOLOGIES
FOR THE LATE OPPOSITION GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
SEE O ONE ELSE HERE MISTER
MODERATED COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY- IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ONE TWO TWO TWO. BUT AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWELVE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. INCLUDE LINE EIGHTY ONE
YEAR OLD IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
MOLLY RIPS IN THE STATE. OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE OF THANK YOU
THANK YOU. IN ONE MOMENT HERE WE
HAVE SOME MORE ONCE COMMITTED.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
INMATE AT THE TOP OF THE QUEUE.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT ONE IS OPEN.
YEAH HI AND- I APOLOGIZE I AM
ACTUALLY CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL BUT I JUST KEPT. MY ONE
ISSUE WITH MY FOUND THAT'S MY
MAIN GOAL TO SPEAK JUST SAY YOUR
NAME AND THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL. OKAY MY NAME IS COURTNEY
MAY DANIEL I AM A PARENT WHO HAS
EXPERIENCED THE DIFFICULTY OF
GOING TO THE DISTRICT OFFICE
FIRSTHAND HER VEHICLE. THANK YOU
MA'AM MAKES OUR PLANS THANK YOU
NAME AND LOCATION NOW. IN GOING
THREE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI SALLY CHAIN WITH THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY WEARING
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND WE'RE
GOING TO NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT ACTUALLY INSURING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TOMMY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND MEDICARE WE HAVE BUT NO
FURTHER ONE IS IN A POSITION AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS SEEING NONE
. SENATE ALL YOU MAY CLOSE WELL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO SPEAK TO-
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING. TO
CHANGE CURRICULA. THIS IS QUITE
FRANKLY LETTING PARENTS HAVE
TRANSPARENCY AND NO- WHAT'S
BEING TAUGHT AT THEIR SCHOOL
ONLINE THIS IS THE EXACT SAME
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT WE
BROUGHT LAST YEAR- WE DIDN'T GET
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS- AND I
JUST FIND IT. FASCINATING AFTER-
COBIT AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH-
MORE MORE ENGAGE IN SCHOOL THAT-
YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE OF THE
OPPOSITION- DOESN'T WANT TO SEE
US- SHARE WITH OUR PARENTS
WHAT'S REALLY HAPPENING AT THEIR
SCHOOL SO. OF THIS BILL THAT
REMEMBER THIS BILL DOES NOTHING
ABOUT CHANGING CURRICULUM THE
CURRICULUM IS ALREADY TAKING
CARE OF THIS IS JUST PUTTING UP.
WHAT THEY'RE TEACHING AT THE
SCHOOL ONLINE SO PARENTS CAN
ACCESS IT SAFELY. AND AND LET
FIND OUT WHAT THEIR STUDENTS
SHOULD BE TAUGHT SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY WE HAVE
A MOTION MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT-
VAST RECONSIDERATION YOU
ABSOLUTELY MAY HAVE CONSIDERED
RECONSIDERATION OF. THANK WELL
BY THE SKIN YOUR TEETH THERE
OKAY THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR OCHO BOKE MAN CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN S. B. TWELVE TWENTY
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
LEYVA HI LEYVA OHIO CHOI BOGUE.
A TROUBLED AYE COURTESY. CORTEZ
HE NO DOUBT HI KELLY GLAZER.
MCGUIRE ACQUIRE NO PAN NO HAN NO
ALL RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL
OPEN FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBER TO
VOTE ALL RIGHT SENATOR BRADFORD.
COME ON DOWN THERE FOREVER IS
GOING TO PRESENT SB. TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I'M PRESENTING AS
FREE TWELVE SEVENTY THREE WHICH
ELIMINATES THE MANDATORY
REQUIREMENTS THAT SCHOOLS NOTIFY
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR A WIDE RANGE
OF STUDENT BEHAVIOR SUCH AS
POSSESSION OF CANNABIS OR
ALCOHOL OR ANY OF. ASSAULT ON
SCREW- EMPLOYEES DECADES OF
RESEARCH AND ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE
FROM STUDENTS AND PARENTS SHOW
THAT LONG TERM HARM TO YOUNG
PEOPLE OF EVEN MINIMAL CONTACT
WITH THE JUVENILE. OR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. ONCE STUDENTS
MAKE CONTACT WITH THE SYSTEMS
THEY ARE LESS LIKELY TO GRADUATE
HIGH SCHOOL. I AM MORE LIKELY
WIND UP IN JAIL OR PRISON BLACK
STUDENTS WILL CHANNEL STUDENTS
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR THE
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
DISPROPORTION REFER TO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY REFERRED TO
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT. AS CITED
AND ARRESTED OVER EXISTING OFF
OFTEN FORCES SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND STAFF TO
NOTIFY LAW ENFORCEMENT. YOU WHEN
THEY KNOW. THIS WILL BE HARMFUL
TO THE STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
THE PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCES OF
THE INCIDENT OR THE INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT SITUATION. IN SOME
INSTANCES THESE WALLS EVEN
AUTHORIZED EDUCATORS TO BE FINE
FOR FAILING TO REPORT SUCH
INCIDENTS. SB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE WILL REDUCE LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVOLVEMENT IN
SCHOOLS AND GIVE TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS WHO ARE OFTEN
BEST SUITED TO DETERMINE THE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE THE
FLEXIBILITY AND POWER THEY NEED
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS BY.
ELIMINATING STATE MANDATES FOR
SCHOOL NOTIFICATION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT INCREASE AN EDUCATOR
DISCRETION IN DETERMINING WHERE
TO NOTIFY LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
WHEN I COULD DIDN'T NOTIFY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ELIMINATING- UP
PROSECUTION OF SCHOOL STAFF WHO
FAILED TO REPORT INCIDENTS AND
ELIMINATING THE CRIMINAL PENALTY
FOR WILLFUL DISTURBANCE. OF
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. THAT'S FIND SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TODAY'S GARY HARDY
WITH THE SOCIAL JUSTICE LEARNING
INSTITUTE AND SOPHIA SELA- WITH
ACLU OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
ALSO HAVE KEPT THIS YEAR- FROM
ACLU AVAILABLE CANCER DETECTED
QUESTIONS SEARCH REQUEST RIVAL
TRAFFIC THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD WE WILL START WITH
MISTER GARY HARDY. SIR YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE PROJECT
MEMBERS OF THE CURRENT MONETARY
PARTY. WORKING PROP OR THE-
ABILITY TO BUY SOLUTION. AND
ALSO. BY A STAFFER AT BEST A
LOT- I MARKETS BECAUSE WATER AS
PEOPLE WOULD BE THREE. A GOOD
ACTORS THIS DOESN'T WORK TO
SUPPORT THE MONEY TO BUY OF THE
YOUNG. IT'S IMPORTANT TO LIVE UP
THE FACT THAT ALLOW THAT OUT. AT
THE THIRTY THREE THE JUST THAT
BY REMOVING. WITH DEPARTMENT- TO
EVOLVE OR NOT I. ALL THE WAY
FROM THE REQUIREMENT ALLOW THE
SCHOOLS WE- ON TOP UNDER THE
BELT BACK. IN THERE TOO TO. AT
NOT ALIVE COMMENTS FOR THE AB.
THE PREVIOUS MANDATED EXPECTS
FOR. AND PROVIDE. WHILE WORKING
ON PEOPLE TO THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON. WERE YOU FIND LOTS
BROWN'S WERE. SUPPORT WILL WORK
FOR WE'VE MOVED AWAY FROM THE
SCHOOL. FIFTY FIVE. AND PUBLICLY.
NINE NOT A AND ALSO COMMON FORM
AND HELP BASED APPROACHES THAT
LEARNING AND POSITIVE
ENVIRONMENT WE GET THIS RIGHT
YES WITH THE MISSION SO AFTER F.
L. THE PRODUCT LEARN AND GROW
ARE YOUR SUPPORT AFTER THAT THE
BOOK WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU
FOR TIME THANK YOU FOR MUCH ALL
RIGHT GO TO MISS SILA PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. YOU
ALSO HAVE TWO MINUTES. HI MY
NAME. IS SHEILA I AM A LEGAL. AT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S ON EDUCATION
THE ISSUE. EIGHT CALIFORNIA.
PROUD ON. OF THE THREE. AT THE
TOP OF THREE ELEVEN THAT MANDATE
FOR A THEATER CALL LARK BONTA.
EVEN MY THEY KNOW IT IS NOT
RIGHT. WHEN INCIDENTS. I PART OF
MY WORK I READ THE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BUY THE OVERREACHING
MANDY. TODAY I WILL SHARE OF
THEIR- IN NOVEMBER TWO TWENTY
ONE ANTEMEDIAL AND THAT THE
FREEDOM OF TO MY DISTRICT
BOATSWAIN THE ALLEGED ELLA. FUND
CAMPUS. I LOVE. FIRED UNDER AT
FORTY NINE HE HE- WHICH MANDATE
THE FUSION OF BONTA BURKE FOR
ANY INCENTIVE. CONDUCTING WORK
ON CONTROL SUBSTANCE. THE LOS
ANGELES. ON UPON SPEAKING WITH
AN.
NUMBER TWENTY TWENTY LI LONNIE A
LOT NEXT PRESSING WITH THE PATH
AND OTHER STUDENTS. LEILANI HAD
NO INTENTION OF PUTTING IN A WE
STRUGGLE TO GET AWAY. DURING THE
ATTACK SEPTEMBER ASSEMBLY
INTERVENED AND OFFERING BACK
AROUND THE LAWN I NEED AND TO
MAKE CONTACT WITH THEM. GEN
MEDIA WE APOLOGIZE TO COMPLY
WITH ALL OF THE CONSTRUCTION.
THE TEACHER IT MAY CONFIRM THAT
WE WANT TO. TURN INTO A CONTACT
WITH HER. I HAD NO FORMAL
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES AND I'VE NEVER
BEEN IN ANY PHYSICAL ALTERCATION
. THEY WANTED INJURIES INCLUDED
FRACTURES BRUISES AND SEVERELY
THREATENING THERE WERE NO MARKS
ON THE- BODY. THE ONLY ONE WITH
THE FORTY THIRD AFTER ALTHOUGH
THE OFFICERS. THAT IN THE FUTURE
ANY KIND WITH THAT THAT'LL AND
THAT'S- EVEN AFTER FUTURE. THANK
YOU HAVE A REPORT IF HE SAID HE
- A RESULT WE MONEY. ARGUS
SIMPLY LINING UP FOR TO PAY
ATTACKS AND- I THINK NOW FOR
QUITE A- TO THE FACT THAT THE
WILL OVER REACT. AND FOR. WILL
SHOULD HAVE. UPON COMPLETION OF
THE COMPANY MANY CERTIFICATES
WILL LIKELY BE MET. WAY MONEY I
HAVE NEVER BEEN BEFORE. OFFICER
ALONE.
TO ANYONE HERE TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED WHO'S IN SUPPORT PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME. AND YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. NICK ROMAN
WE HAVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL COUNSELORS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RUEGEN THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE. WHO WISHES TO STATE
THEIR NAME AND SUPPORT FOR S. B.
ONE TWO SEVEN THREE PLEASE.
THANK MEDICARE AND AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS AT THE HEART WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOU ARE WE
ARE IN STRONG. SELF THANK YOU.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE ZERO
SEVEN THREE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ERIC MARTIN MET ALL THE
APPROPRIATE- OF THE A LOT MORE
THAN THE OTHER WE ARE CO
SPONSORING A STRONG WORK ETHIC
BEFORE. THANK YOU I AM A LITTLE
LINE AT THREE THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS BY NAME SHARES
ASSEMBLY DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA STRONG. BOB US. OUR
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVENTY THREE. IN
ONE THREE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF A
FRIEND COMMITTEE ON THE
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE. AND THE LITTLE ONE THREE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LIKE THREE FORTY ONE IF YOUR
SUPPORT OF SP POSSIBLY THREE
LINES OPEN. THREE FORTY ONE DID
YOU NEED TO MAKE A COMMENT. AND
WE WILL MOVE ON THE LINE TO HOLD
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS HERE WE ARE. AND ALLOW. THE
USE OF THIS ISSUE CLINICS THAT
WILL AWFUL REFERRAL FOR ATHLETES
OF THE THREE THANK YOU. IT WAS A
LITTLE THE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. THANK YOU- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BELINDA
GRAVEL AND I AM AN EDUCATION
PROGRAM ASSOCIATE WITH A LOT OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AND URINE FOR OF
SB THIRTY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE.
OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
SEPARATE BOYS- I'M NOT ONLY HERE
WITH THIRDS MORAINE SHOWING UP
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT E. TWELFTH SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU. IT'LL
ONE THREE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS THE WORST
YEAR OF COUNSEL WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATE AND WE ARE ATTHE
CORNER SB. TWELVE SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN WITH A
LITTLE ONE THREE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
TERRY COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MINOR LIRA I'M AN ATTORNEY
WITH PUBLIC COUNCIL WE ARE
COSPONSORS SB TWELVE THIRTY
THREE AND WE ARE IN A STRONG
SUPPORT ITSELF. THANK YOU. ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FROM ALL THE TRADE IN
THE COLOR AND I'M WITH THE BLACK
HAIR LOSS BEFORE AND SHALL WORK
S. B. WHAT THAT MEANS. IN LITTLE
ONE THREE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU FOR SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NINETY ARLENE
HAS A LONG- AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF YOUTH ORGANIZING WHAT IS THAT
LIKE ANY THOUGHT AND WE ARE
PROUD BOTH SPONSORS AND
ARMSTRONG. SB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
WE WILL BE ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS ERIC
YOU KNOW WE WERE WITH ITS
ALLIANCE IN HOLLISTER CALIFORNIA
WE ARE SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. IN ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU CHARACTER MEDIA
MEMBERS MY NAME INTERNET AFTER
POLICY DIRECTOR AT YOUTH
ALLIANCE IN BOTH SAN BENITO
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE TWO
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS COLBY LANDS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS AND WE ARE IN STRONG
OR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
MANAGER WE HAVE A NO ADDITIONAL
IN SUPPORT OF STERN TERRIFIC
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR
A WE DO HAVE ONE OF LEAD
OPPOSITION WHO CAME IN LATE OF-
SHERA MOOD SHORE UP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION ARE YOU ON THE LINE. MISTER MODERATOR DO YOU KNOW
IF YOU SHOW A MUCH LOWER IS ON
THE LINE. IN MEDICARE NOW THAT
THIS TIME OKAY VERY GOOD SO WE
WILL GO TO ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WHO OPPOSES
THE BILL. SEEING NO ONE MISTER
MODERATOR WE WILL GO TO YOU TO
QB ONE WHO WISHES TO STATE THEIR
NAME IN OPPOSITION TO SB ONE TWO
SEVEN THREE. THANK MEDICARE
AGAIN APPEARED LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SP PROP SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN
ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. WHERE YOU ARE NUMANTIA MEMBERS
RYAN SHERMAN IF I COULD- MAKE
SURE WASN'T ABLE TO- I LIKE
PROVIDE- MAYBE A MINUTE OR TWO
OF TOUGH MONEY THAT WOULD BE
OKAY YOU MAY HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME THE
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS OF THE
FIRST I CHECKED BOTH THE SENATE
AND NUMEROUS LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS. MEDIC WHICH
REPRESENTS SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS IS SWORN DUTY IS TO
PROTECT CHILDREN ENSURE THEIR
SAFETY ON CAMPUS. INCLUDING THE
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CLAREMONT CORONA MONA EL THIRTY
THREE PORT BEACH. BUDGETARY
DEPUTY SHERIFF. UP WHEN SANTA
ANA BURBANK INGLEWOOD ARCADIA
RIVERSIDE LOS ANGELES SCHOOL
POLICE ASSOCIATION ORIGIN POLICE
IN CULVER CITY POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION ALL. FINALLY POSTED
AT ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE A
MEASURE THAT WOULD ENDANGER OUR
SCHOOLS TEACHERS RESOURCE
OFFICERS AND SPECIALLY THAT.
THIS ILL CONCEIVED BILL SEEKS TO
PROTECT THOSE WHO WOULD ENTER
SCHOOL GROUNDS. HARM CAR WHILE
PROVIDE ANY PERSON WHO WILLFULLY
THE SERVICE ANY FORTY PUBLIC
SCHOOL. OR PUBLIC SCHOOL MEETING
. S. SUBJECT OF NOT MORE FIVE
AND DOLLARS. BILLION PROVISION
SB LOVES OF THREE WERE PERMIT A
PERSON TO WILLFULLY GOOD FOR ANY
SCHOOL OR ANY PUBLIC MEETING
WITHOUT RISKING CRIMINAL
LIABILITY. A TEACHER CALL.
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING ASSEMBLY
SPORTING EVENTS IN CLASSROOMS.
AND TEST ALL BE DISRUPED AT
TWELVE THREE WERE TO BECOME LAW
. WHILE ALSO REQUIRES
ENFORCEMENT BE NO IMMEDIATE WHEN
EVER ANY EMPLOYEE OF A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOL THAT
PACKED OF SALTED OR PHYSICALLY
THREATENED BY PEOPLE. HOWEVER SB
TWELVE THIRTY THREE TICKET CAL
FUEL SCHOOL SAFETY REMOVES THIS
REQUIREMENT THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
BE NOTIFIED WHEN A STUDENT.
ATTACKED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE. AT THE
TO TWELVE SEVENTY REMOVED HER.
THIS WILL NOT FOLLOW ENFORCEMENT
WILL STUDENTS CAUGHT SELLING
DRUGS OR BRING THE VARIETY OF
DEATH WEAPONS THE- COULD
REASONABLY FONG CUTTERS VERY
SEEING WHAT THE TERRORISTS. IN
THE NINE ELEVEN THE- THEY DIDN'T
WERE STAFF SECURITY TWO MINUTES
PLEASE WRAP UP. THANK YOU FOR
THE VICTORY WILL THREATEN THE
SAFETY OF OUR STUDENTS STAFF
SCHOOLS NEIGHBORHOODS AND FOR
THESE AND MANY MORE REASONS WE
REMAIN STRONGLY OPPOSED AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR PLEASE
KEEP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO STATE
THEIR NAME AND OPPOSITION ONLY
TWO S. B. ONE TWO SEVEN THREE
PLEASE. THREE BILLION WITH GO UP
ONE THREE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS CARRY
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MATURE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ILLEGAL ONE THREE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. READ MORE WARNING
AGAINST ONLY ORDER HOSPITAL YES
I'M HOPING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NO I'M. HERE WE HAVE A NO
FURTHER WANTED TO THE OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
COMMENTS CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS.
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU SIR
BRADFORD FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I DO APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE AND- WE
NEED TO BE SURE THAT- THAT'S NOT
STUDENTS DON'T GET AND TAKE ALL
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT-
UNNECESSARILY- I GUESS A COUPLE.
OF A COUPLE QUESTIONS SO ONE IS
THAT- NOW THAT I GUESS SURE OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT OF THESE PEOPLE
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- SAID NO
DATE DAY OBJECTED TO THE LACK OF
REQUIREMENT TO CALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HOWEVER IS THERE
ANYTHING YOUR BILL THAT
PROHIBITS THE SCHOOL FROM IF
THEY FELT THE ASSAULT WAS
ACTUALLY OF. INTENTIONAL SERIOUS
AND SO FORTH- ON SCHOOL
PERSONNEL THAT THE THAT THEY
COULDN'T CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND TELL THEM WHAT I WONDER FOR
SO LONG FOR SENATE. I'M SAD TO
REPORT THIS ISSUE CONTINUED
FALSE NARRATIVE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ANYTIME YOU WANT TO
MAKE REFORMS ARE IMPROVEMENTS TO
A SYSTEM. THE REQUIREMENTS
STUDENT NOTIFIED LAW ENFORCEMENT
STE THEY ARE STILL ABLE AT ANY
TIME THAT A TEACHER
ADMINISTRATOR FEELS THERE'S A-
QUALIFY THREAT OR A STUDENT
SHOWS UP. ON CAMPUS WITH A
DEADLY WEAPON THERE ARE STILL
REQUIRED TO REPORT IT SEEN THE
UNNECESSARY REPORTS OF. A FIST
FIGHT AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE
THAT WE'VE ALL SEEN AND BEEN
INVOLVED IN FROM THE TIME WE
ENTER KINDERGARTEN TO THE TIME
WE GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL. AND
THE FAR DIFFERENCE AGAIN IS HOW
FREQUENT POLICE ARE CALLED WHEN
YOU'RE A BLACK AND BROWN
STUDENTS VERSUS WHITE STUDENTS
TO CONTINUE TO COME ON CAMPUS
WITH GUNS AND ALL GO HOME IN A
ONE CHANCE SO IT DOESN'T REACH-
REMOVING MINISTERS. OR TEACHERS
ABILITY TO CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
IF WITH A QUOTE CREDIBLE THREAT
IS THERE OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT
CLARIFICATION AND THEN THIS IS
THE SECOND QUESTION I DO HAVE IS
THAT- RELATED TO THE PROVISION-
THAT YOU'RE REMOVING THE
PROVISION RELATES TO WILLFUL
DISTURBANCE OF A PUBLIC SCHOOL
OR PUBLIC SCHOOL MEETING. AND TO
FIND ASSOCIATED- A CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND PERHAPS WHY THIS
MAKES SENSE TO REMOVE FOR
STUDENTS- I GUESS THE QUESTION
IS THAT- SOMEONE WHO IS NOT
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SCHOOL SHOWS
UP IN THE SCHOOL OR AN ADULT WHO
HOPEFULLY IS- WOULD HOPEFULLY
HAVE EXERCISE BETTER JUDGMENT-
SO NOT A PUPIL AT THE SCHOOL
STUDENT AT THE SCHOOL- BEFORE
WE'VE SEEN CASES OF TEACHERS AND
OTHER SCHOOL PERSONNEL BEING
HARASSED OR SOMETIMES EVEN
ASSAULTED ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW THEY
ACTUALLY COMMITTED SALT. THE
OTHER LOTS OF PRACTICE IN THE
PLACE- IS THERE A REASON WHY WE
WOULD JUST SIMPLY REMOVE THIS
FOR STUDENTS AND STILL KEEP IT
IN PLACE PERHAPS FOR OTHER
PEOPLE GIVEN THE FACT
UNFORTUNATELY THESE INCIDENTS
HAVE HAPPENED EVEN RECENTLY. I
THAT'S AGOOD QUESTION AND OUR
GOAL HERE IS TO MAKE SURE WE'VE
SEEN EXAMPLES WHERE STUDENTS
WERE KNOCKING ON DOORS AND
REPORTED AND- TURNED OVER T
POLICE. YES IF SOMEONE ON THE
RISE COMES ON CAMPUS WE WOULD
HOPE THAT. NOT ONLY TEACHERS BUT
ANY RESPONSIBLE ADULT WOULD DO
THE NECESSARY- NOTIFICATION TO.
IN THAT DISTURBANCE AND NOTIFY
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO THIS WE'RE
TRYING TO YOU KNOW. WALK A FINE
LINE IN MAKING SURE KIDS ARE NOT
IN TANKER IN THIS REPORT. RIGHT
WELL I I'LL I WOULD FOR IT IS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD- I WOULD
I WOULD PROBABLY HOPE THAT YOU
MIGHT CONSIDER JUST MAKING
EXCLUSION JUST FOR STUDENTS
ENROLLED STUDENTS. GOD IT MAY BE
IS TOOL UNFORTUNATELY HE
NECESSARY POTENTIALLY NECESSARY.
FOR THE ADULTS ARE ARE OR PEOPLE
WHO ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
SCHOOL COMING ONTO CAMPUS- DOING
THAT AND THAT YOU'VE LOST IT
GIVE SOMEONE A TOOL TO SAY
THERE'S ACTUALLY A CONSEQUENCE
FOR DOING THAT SO. BUT I'VE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND YOUR
EXAMPLES WITH STUDENTS AND THAT
NO WE HAVE NO PROBLEM WOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE- YOU KNOW. THE NEW
YORK ALL RIGHT SISAL OKAY WELL
THANK YOU SANDRA- AND AGAIN
PRECIADO TO MY QUESTIONS AND
THAT HELPING WITH THE BUILT
APPROPRIATE TIME THINKING YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING
NONE THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER PAM AND CONSULT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GIVE ME. I'M
SORRY CENTER BRADFORD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I DID IT YESTERDAY
THANK GOD FOR GOOD COMMITTEE-
YEAH EGGS. AUG AGAIN THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE ALL WE WANT
TO DO IS REDUCE THE LEVEL OF
POLICE INTERACTION WITH KIDS SO
THEY CAN BE. FEEL COMFORTABLE
NOT TRAUMATIZED AT SCHOOL- WE'VE
SEEN A GREATER POLICE PRESENCE
AND- ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO MAKE SURE IT. FIRST
AND FOREMOST THE KIDS ARE SAFE
AND THEY'RE IN A PROPER LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT BUT THEY'RE NOT
FEARFUL THAT. A SIMPLE FISTFIGHT
OR VERBAL ALTERCATION LEAD TO
THEM BEING CITED OR ARRESTED AS
WE SAW A FIVE YEAR OLD- EARLIER
THIS YEAR IN HANDCUFFS A FIVE
YEAR. OKAY BUT SO ANYWAY IT'S A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE AND WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ADDRESS ALL CONCERNS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD MAN CONSULT THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER PAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS THAT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE OTRO ABODE PHOTO
ABOVE NO CORTESE BY PROTESTS THE
AYE DALY. GLAZER MCGUIRE. HAM HI
AM I. BELIEVE THAT ON CALL FOR
OUR APPS MEMBERS THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD MANAGER MEMBERS
ALL RIGHT WE'RE MOVING TO OUR
FINAL BILL THE DAYS SENATOR CHOI
BOGUE THE FLOOR IS YOURS THE-
PLEASE PRESENT SB TWELVE EIGHTY
NINE WHEN YOU ARE READY. WHERE
EVERYONE AGO IT DOES MAKE IT
STAY HERE. OKAY TIME TO LIVE. SO
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU
CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THE MEASURE
TITLE FIVE ENTITLED TWENTY TWO
YOU HAVE THE EDUCATION CODE
CREATED STANDARDIZED EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR TEACHERS IN
OPERATING CLASSROOMS FOR
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN THEY ALSO
CREATED A REQUIREMENT FOR ALL
TEACHERS TO EARN TWELVE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION UNITS AT THE
COLLEGIATE. LEVEL THESE
REQUIREMENTS HOWEVER EXTEND PAST
TEACHERS TO INCLUDE ANY
INDIVIDUAL WORKING ON A
PRESCHOOL CAMPUS. EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION CREDITS
INCLUDE ACTIVITIES LIKE
DIAGRAMMING YOUR FIRST PRESCHOOL
CLASSROOM EIGHT AND VARIOUS
OTHER PROJECTS WITH THE
OBJECTIVE OF PREPARING A TEACHER
TO EFFECTIVELY OPERATE A
STANDARD PRESCHOOL ENVIRONMENT.
WHILE THESE CLASSES PROVIDE A
VERY SENSIBLE EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT FIRST PRESCHOOL
TEACHERS THEIR INCOME GREEN WITH
THE PREPARATION NEEDS OF
ADMINISTRATORS UP OUTSIDE
RECREATION FOR OUR PROGRAMS.
ALTIJD RECREATION PROGRAMS
PARTNER WITH PRESCHOOLS TO BRING
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES TO
PRESCHOOLERS IN ADDITION TO
THEIR TRADITIONAL PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMMING. CALIFORNIA HAS
ALREADY RECOGNIZED THE HIRING
AND STAFFING CHALLENGES THAT
RESULTED FROM THE APPLICATION OF
TEACHER CREDENTIALING STANDARDS
TO THE POSITION OF PART TIME
COACHES AND CREATED AN EXEMPTION
FOR PUBLIC RECREATION PROGRAMS.
BUT DID NOT EXTEND THE EXCEPTION
TO PRIVATE PROGRAMS. SB TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE WILL SIMPLY EXPAND
THE EXCEPTION FOR LICENSURE
REQUIREMENTS AS SPECIFIED IN
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE FOR
PUBLIC RECREATION PROGRAMS TO
ALSO APPLY TO PRIVATE RECREATION
PROGRAMS. THIS WILL CREATE
PARITY BETWEEN THE PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT GREAT WORK GOING ON IN
OUR SCHOOLS. I HAVE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT JOVAN BARCHI
WITH SOCCER SHOT OC AND LEYVA
JERUSALEM APPARENT AND FORMER
TEACHER. TERRIFIC THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY BOTH ARE CALLING IN OF
JOBIN BARKLEY YOU MAY START YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES AND THEN WILL
WE WILL GO TO MISTER SALOUM.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS JASMINE BARKLEY I OWN A
FAMILY RUN PRIVATE RECREATION
PROGRAM ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES WE FACE I OUR
BUSINESS WHEN ATTEMPTING TO GROW
IMPACT FOR CHILDREN ESTIMATED TO
THE ONGOING REQUIREMENT TO HIRE
AN EMPLOYEE FULL THANK YOU
FEATURING PRESCHOOL TEACHERS TO
DO A PART TIME JOB COACHING
SOCCER CLASS. THIS IS BEEN MADE
EVEN MORE CHALLENGING BY THE
CODE CRISIS AND NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON THE AVAILABLE FUTURE
WORKFORCE. WE UNDERSTAND AND
SUPPORT INTENTIONS OF PETALS
FIVE AND TWENTY TWO WHICH
PROMOTE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CHILDREN WILL STANDARDIZE THE
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
PRESCHOOL TEACHERS WHO CARE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF EDUCATING A
COSTUME FOR CHILDREN. THIS
STANDARDIZATION HELPS ENSURE
THAT ALL CHILDREN ARE WE
PREPARED FOR ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
NO. MATTER WHICH PRESCHOOL THAT
TIME. WE BEGIN ASKING WHY AFTER
TIME CO WORK FOR A PRIVATE.
RECREATION PRO. WAS ONLY ON
CAMPUS FOR THIRTY FIVE BEFORE
MINUTES PER WEEK IS REQUIRED TO
MEET THE STATE EDUCATION
STANDARDS OF A FULL TIME
PRESCHOOL TEACHER. WE ARE NOT
ASKING FOR A NEW EXEMPTION TO BE
CONSIDERED. THE STATE QUICKLY
REALIZED BY CHALLENGING IT WAS
TO STOP THEIR OWN RECOGNITION
PROGRAMS WITH YOU SHOULD BE
CERTIFIED PRESCHOOL TEACHERS. SO
THE ST PATRICK'S MENTION FOR
THEIR OWN PUBLIC RECREATION
PROGRAM EMPLOYEES. WE'RE ASKING
THE SUSPENSION THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN CONSIDERED APPROVED FOR
PUBLIC RECREATION PROGRAMS
INCLUDING EXTENDED TO COVER ALL
RECREATION PROGRAMS. PROGRAM
EMPLOYEES IN A WAY THAT WILL
ALLOW ALL POSITIVELY IMPACT FOR
CHILDREN. WITH THE STATED
pTWENTY TWO BEING TO PROMOTE AND
PROTECT HEALTH SAFETY OF
CHILDREN. WE BELIEVE THAT
EXPANDING EXEMPTION WILL EXPAND
ACCESS TO PROGRAMS MORE CHILDREN
IN A WAY THAT DELIVERS THE
STATED GOALS OF THE TITLE. AFTER
THE TO PRODUCE A STUDY THAT
HIGHLIGHTS THE PHYSICAL AND
ACADEMIC BENEFITS OF ACTIVE
LIFESTYLE A YOUNG EACH
ADDITIONALLY. WHILE MANY PARENTS
ARE ALREADY AWARE OF THE
PHYSICAL BENEFIT HAVING YOUR
KIDS PLAY SPORTS. A RECENT STUDY
BY THE CLEVELAND CLINIC ALSO
SHOWS THAT ENGAGING IN TEAM
SPORTS TO ACTUALLY HELP KIDS
WARD OFF. DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY
AS WELL. WHICH IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT THIS POST AND
DEMOCRATS. EXPANDING EXEMPTIONS-INCLUDE BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
RECREATION PROGRAMS WILL
CONTRIBUTE TOWARDS INTENDED
STATED DESIRE. APPELS FIVE
TWENTY TWO WHICH ARE TO PROTECT
AND PROMOTE THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CHILDREN PHYSICALLY
MENTALLY EMOTIONALLY AND
ACADEMICALLY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT MS. LUXURY.
SALOUM EUROPE NEXT TWO MINUTES.
HI MY NAME LAYLA. ONE MINIMUS.
SUPPORT IT'S BEEN A A. COUNTY.
AS A FOR TEACHER IN A INCOME
COMMUNITY ICE- HOW.
PREDOMINANTLY OF- AFFECTED BY
LACK OF INSULIN RICH. NOW SCHOOL
. SOMETHING CATHOLIC SHOWED
STUDENTS LIKE MINE. SO THATTIME
THE UP HE OUR OF SCREEN TIME
BUILDING UPGRADE EXTENDED. THE
DANGER OF WHAT WE ALL KNOW. I
AM. YOU TODAY TO LET. THAT
BARRIER ENTRY FOR PROGRAMS I CAN
BREAK GAP BETWEEN SCHOOL KIND.
AND IDLE TIME FOR CHILDREN.
ENRICHMENT PROGRAMS HAVE A
DIRECT IMPACT ON HOW YOUNG
BRAINS DEVELOP. FOR EXAMPLE
ACTIVITY CENTERED AROUND YOUR
SIZE AND MOVEMENT CAN BE A MEANS
OF SELF REGULATION IMPACTING
INDIVIDUAL WORK. ATTENTION
DEFICIT COOL AND CREATIVE
EXPRESSION. MANY OF US HAVE BEEN
TRANSFORMED BY PROGRAMS BEYOND
ACADEMIC. WHEN THESE ARE ABSENT
AS PART OF THE CORE CURRICULUM
ENRICHMENT PROGRAM CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. CHILDREN ESPECIALLY
CHILDREN OF COLOR LIKE MINE
SHOULD BE PROVIDED THAT
OPPORTUNITY AT SCHOOL. AS A
PARENT I WAS SURPRISED TO LEARN
THAT WHEN THERE ISN'T A PUBLIC
ORGANIZATION WITH MANPOWER
PROVIDER PROGRAM. THERE EXISTS A
BARRIER TO ENTRY FOR OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WITH EXISTING
CAPACITY TO DO SO. YOU WILL BE
HARD PRESSED TO FIND A PARENT
WHO CARES. WHETHER THEIR PREQUEL
RICHMOND PROGRAM AND PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE. YOU JUST. HAVE A FEW
GUIDELINES. THIS IS A MATTER OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND VITAL IN OUR
POST PANDEMIC WHY. PARENTS WERE
RUNNING ON FUMES AND NOW MANY OF
US ARE TEAMING. YES OUR YOGA
MUSIC AND SOCCER SHOULD NOT GET. ON FOR THE LAST THREE TIMES ON
HANDS. TO PROVIDE SOMEONE CAN'T
BY ANY OR- HELP PARENTS. IN THIS
POST COLD ERA EXACT THE- OF
PROGRAM. BY LAW IT TO IS THAT.
FOR ABOUT. BY SIMPLY EXTRA THE-
TO PROVIDE. YOU ARE BECAUSE BACK
GAP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR IT
WILL GO HE TO READ TWENTY
HUNDRED FOR ANYONE IN SOME. SEEN
NO ONE MISTER MODERATOR COULD
YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO STATE THEIR NAME AND
SUPPORT FOR SB ONE TWO EIGHT
NINE. THANK MEDICARE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. YEAH WE JUST A
MOMENT BEFORE WE- GET EFFORTS
LINE AND IN THE FIRST WITH THE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HE WELL YES FIND EIGHTY SEVEN GO
AHEAD YEAH HI MY NAME IS
JONATHAN I AM THE OWNER OF
BHAKER SHOT THE AREA IS WITHOUT
ROOM VISITS I AM IN FULL SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL WELL EIGHTY NINE
AS THAT WILL ALLOW US TO SERVE
MORE CHILDREN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANNEX GUIDELINES THREE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
THINK COURTLY NAVISTAR. THANK
YOU. M. NEXT LITTLE ONE THREE
ZERO NINE THREE OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI I AM EVEN ME I
AM A PARENT AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. ANNEX ONE LINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH BURKE. WELL
AS LONG THE COURT THE STOCK.
NEXT GOOD ONE THREE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY THREE
SIXTY EIGHT ARE YOU SUPPORTIVE
SB PROPERTY NINE. DID WE WILL
MOVE ON WITH ONLINE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AMANDA PARTY. I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. ONE THIRTY ONE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS NICHOLA SPIRIT
I'M A PARENT OF TWO YOUNG
CHILDREN I AM STRONG STRONG
RECORD SENATE BILL ONE TWO EIGHT
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
ONE LINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT WE GLAD
. MY NAME IS HEATHER JONES AND I
AM SUPPORTING FELL TWELVE EIGHTY
NINE THANK YOU. WINA THREE FIFTY
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY
THREE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES. MY NAME IS CHERYL AND
I FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND
IT WOULD LINE TO SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LAURA BERMAN
APPARENT FOR HIMSELF. ONE THREE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH HI MY NAME IS DAVID BARNETT
I AM A PARENT AND A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE EIGHTY NINE. AN EXCELLENT LINE THREE FIFTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS MEGAN BARNETT I LOVE
PARENTS WERE PREFORMED I'M OFF
THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNER THANK
YOU I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. HELLO NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. REMEMBER
SARAH AND I FULLY EXPECT THAT
THE. NOW TOTALING FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS NOT IN
THE KERRY FATHER OF FOUR AND FOR
THE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. NEXT ONE LINE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS YVETTE RYAN I'M A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I OR BELT TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE. IN LITTLE ONE
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS ACTUALLY FONG AND THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND I AM
THANKFUL FOR SB TWELVE EIGHTY
NINE. IT'LL GO TO LINE THREE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SH.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON NO ANY MEDICAL
OR DEFENSE- BUT DISTRACTION THAT
IT'S ALL CHILDREN NOT THE
MINORITY CHILDREN THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY THINK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE US. IN LITTLE ONE
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS ANA VEGA I. ROOMS
THE COURT ITSELF. YOU CAN GO
ONLINE AT THREE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
ALEXANDRIA HONEY AND I WERE TO
SELL TWELVE EIGHTY NINE. IN NEXT
WITH ONE THREE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ANYONE IS. YEAH MY
NAME IS A MIKE BARNETT- AND THE
GRANDPARENTS AND I'M ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN SMALL BUSINESS
AND I AM IN SUPPORT SB ONE TWO
EIGHT NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IN ONE ONE TWO SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS MANDY
LET THEM WORK. THE PART OF THE
SELF. IN NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS YOUR DENTAL
DIRECTOR COACHING WITH A PROGRAM
CALLED DOCTOR SHOPPING MALLS
EAGLES I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
TWO EIGHT I THANK YOU. IN
BROOKLINE THREE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S
ANTHONY HOW MAN ON THE COURT
ITSELF VERY. AND NOW TO LINE
THREE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JIM HELLO
I'M A PARENT AND A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS COMMONSENSE BILL. INFIELDER LINE TO SEVENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI I AM A
PARENT OF YOUNG CHILDREN MY NAME
IS AMBER AND I'M IN SUPPORT. IT
WILL BE ALIGNED THREE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
FAVOR. BANK AND I'M SUPPORT. IN
ORDER TO LINE THREE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS NANCY
UP CALL AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. IN LITTLE LINE AT
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINETY NINE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN MAKING SURE WE HAVE A NO
FOR THEIR LINES IN SUPPORT OF
THE START THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
WE HAVE NO OF FORMAL LEAD
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. SO MR
MODERATOR AND GO BACK TO YOU FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE SB
ONE TWO EIGHT NINE BY STATING
THEIR NAME AND OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE
MEETING NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. EVERY LITTLE LINE THREE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS ACTUALLY IN WORK I WILL
RECREATE FOR SUPPORT AND IT
DIDN'T GET CALLED MY NAME IS
HEATHER FORNEY I'M A PARENT OF
TWO YOUNG CHILDREN AS WELL AS A
COMMUNITY VOLUNTEER AND A SCHOOL
VOLUNTEER NINE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
WANT TO SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS LAURA BERMAN I DON'T. SUPPORT
THANK YOU. IN MANAGER ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE COMING IN.
AND WE WILL LITTLE ONE THREE
SIXTY PEOPLE HAD. YEAH HI AND
JUST THE PRESIDENT I WASN'T
CALLED- BUT I AM IN SUPPORT S.
B. ONE TWO EIGHT NINE THANK
THANK YOU. AND MEDICARE WE HAVE
A NO BYNES'S OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU AND- CENTER SHOW
VOTER APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE WITH YOUR BILL
I GUESS I COULD JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION- SO. THOUSAND
CHILD CARE RIGHT AND THE ONE
INVOLVED YOU HEARD YOGA SPORTS
HEALTH DR TARA WOULD THAT CHILD
THEN BE LEFT IN THE CARE OF THAT
COACH WHO ARE WITH THEIR
ACTUALLY BE SOMEONE WHO SO IN
OTHER WORDS THE TARGET PEOPLE
HAVE TO GET LICENSE AND SO FORTH
RIGHT GO THROUGH THE SCREEN
WOULD THEY EVER BE LIVE WITH
THOSE CHILDREN EVER BE LEFT WITH
SOMEONE WHO ISN'T ON THEIR OWN
OR IT SO I WASN'T SURE ABOUT
THIS WAS THAT THE SITUATION OR
IS THAT- WELL THEY WOULD HAVE
SOMEONE WHO YOU KNOW WENT
THROUGH ALL THE SCREENING AND SO
FORTH. BUT WITHIN MY REQUIRE
SOMEONE ELSE WHO IS THAT THE
COACHING TO HAVE TO ACQUIRE IT
IF THERE. ARE HUGE HE HAD
SOMEONE WHO. WHAT THE RULES AND
IS CERTIFIED AT ALSO PRESENTS
NOTED AYE AYE THAR CLARIFIED
THAT BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S KIND
OF IMPORTANT YOU DON'T WANT TO
LEAVE YOUNG CHILDREN WITH
SOMEONE ALONE. WHO HASN'T BEEN
GONE THROUGH THE SWINGING OUR
QUALIFICATION WORK. RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONCERN SO THIS
BILL IS DEFINITELY NOT INTENDED
TO REMOVE ANY NON PHYSICAL
REQUIREMENTS- BUT YET NOT TO
REMOVE SAFEGUARDS TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN SO IT'S IT HAS IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE STOP THE
BETWEEN SERVE FINGERPRINT IT
STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS THE ONLY THING THAT
THERE WOULD BE EXCLUDED FROM IS
TO HAVE THE EDUCATIONAL FORMAL
EDUCATIONAL COMPONENT OF WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO HAVE A RIGHT A
PRESCHOOL CLASS RIGHT SO THEY
WOULD STILL GO THROUGH THE
SAFEGUARDS OF ARE GOING TO
INDIAN HIRING AND WORKING WITH
THESE KIDS SO. IT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE SAFEGUARDS OF AB
SCREENING PER SE AND IF I I'M
NOT SURE IF THAT AS WITH ANOTHER
THREE OR THE CHARITY CATION YEAH
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL I THINK
THAT. SO THERE'S UP THERE'S THE
SAFETY SCREEN WITH IT AND THAT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE DRESSED AND
THERE'S I GUESS I CALLED THE
CURRICULAR PART BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THERE'S MORE THAN JUST WATCHING
THE CHILD IT'S ALSO PROMOTING
DEVELOPMENT SO FORTH AND WE WANT
TO GET THESE OTHER PEOPLE
ENGAGED IN THAT THAT COULD BE
PART OF THE PROGRAM BUT ALL. OF
THAT THIRTY THAT THAT I GUESS
THE CHILD CARE PERSONNEL THE
PROFESSIONAL OR THE CENTER IS
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT
THEY'RE NOT. EXCESSIVELY SPENT
PUTTING PEOPLE ON. I GUESS.
EXCEPT TIME WITH PEOPLE WHO.
AREN'T THINKING ABOUT THE
DEVELOP OR AT LEAST WORKING THEM
TO BE SURE THAT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE SO I JUST WANNA BE
SURE DOES THAT. THAT COULD LEVEL
SUPERVISION- AT A REALIZE THAT
DESPITE COULD ALSO APPLY TO THE
PUBLIC SIDE WHICH WE ALREADY
HAVE IN PLACE WHICH I UNDERSTAND
ANALYSIS WE DON'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT CAME ABOUT
IN YOUR STATE. YOU KNOW MAKE IT
SORT. OF ON THE PRIVATE SIDE.
BUT I GUESS ARE STEPPING BACK. I
JUST WANT TO INSURE THAT. THE
REASON WE HAVE THESE STANDARDS
IS ALSO TO ENSURE THAT THE
CHILDREN WHO ARE PARTICIPATING.
ARE GETTING YOU KNOW DEVELOPMENT
THE APPROPRIATE- ACTIVITIES AND
THAT- SINCE THE- SOME THE
DEFICIT OTHER FOLKS AREN'T
THAT'S NOT PART OF THEIR
VALUATION- THAT- THAT. THE AT
LEAST THE CHILD CARE CENTER
STATE RESPONSIBILITY FOR BE SURE
THAT THE ACTIVITIES THEY CHOSE
TO DO THEM END UP WITH. ARE
DEVELOPING A PROPERTY FOR THAT
PARTICULAR AGE. SO HOPEFULLY YOU
CAN- YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD LOOK AT THAT I
THINK IT I'M SURE YOU'LL KEEP
THAT IN MIND. I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
YOU THINK ABOUT THESE THINGS-
BUT- SO I AM I'M FINE WITH
MOVING THIS BILL YOU KNOW IT'S
TERM SUPPORTING THIS BILL. I
JUST WANNA BE SURE WE DON'T HAVE
TO CREATE A GAP THERE AND
FRANKLY ACTUALLY EVEN ON THE
PUBLIC SIDE SO THAT I. WAS
WONDERING LIKE OK SO EXACTLY WAS
A SUPERVISION. REQUIREMENTS AND
ALSO A GUIDELINES FOR. THESE
COACHES IN THESE OTHER FOLKS
THAT THEY'RE BEING GAUGED.
ABSOLUTELY AND I IF YOU'D LIKE
SO BASICALLY. THESE ARE JUST SO
THE ENTITIES THAT ACTUALLY HIRE
THESE. THEY JUST RECOMMEND. THE
VET THE PROGRAMS AND THEY HAVE
TO VET TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
COMPLEMENT THE EFFORTS OF THE
SCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING-
YOU KNOW ASSISTED WITH EASE A
PARTICULAR SUPPLEMENT ENRICHMENT
PROGRAMS PER SE- SO I THINK.
THERE'S A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
VETTING AND LIABILITY THAT GOES
INTO THAT BECAUSE IT IS. THEY'RE
WORKING WITH THEM IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THIS HOLISTIC APPROACH
IN TWO AND REGION PROGRAMS AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS FOR THESE
KIDS. I'M BUT I'M NOT SURE IF-
IF I MADE TO THE CHAIR IF MY AB-
SUPPORT WITH AS MR JOBIN HAS ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT THAT HE WOULD
LIKE TO I WITH WITH THAT- WITH.
YOUR QUESTION IN MIND. YES
PLEASE. IF YOU WERE TO A QUICK
RESPONSE. SURE THE ATTORNEY YES
. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU YES
CERTAINLY CERTAINLY THE
PRESCHOOL- OFFICIALS ARE ALWAYS
ALLOWED TO REVIEW OUR CURRICULUM
TO MAKE SURE SOMEONE TO PUT
THEIR TEACHING OUR OWN PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE ACTUALIZED WITH THIRTY
CALIFORNIA EARLY LEARNING
FOUNDATION SO WE TEACH THE EXACT
SAME WAY THEY'RE TEACHING THE
CLASSROOM THE ONLY THING THIS
DOES IS DOING IF IT'S CREATING
EQUAL ACCESS AND EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR PRIVATE PROGRAMS
FOR WHAT PUBLIC PROGRAMS. RT AND
THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR HIRING GREAT COACHES AND
THEN. ON THE PRESCHOOL'S REVIEW
OUR PROGRAM AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE A FIX FOR THEM. ALL THIS
IS SAYING IS THAT WE WOULD NO
LONGER. RIGHT IT FAMILY OWNED
COMPANY HALF THE ONLY HIGHER
PRESCHOOL TEACHERS. THE COACH
FOR THIRTY FIVE MINUTES ON
CAMPUS. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER CORTESE- YES IT I'M
GOING TO- YOU KNOW BE SUPPORTING
MOVING THIS ALONG TO THEM AMONG
THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE- AS
THE AUTHOR GOES SO- WE'LL GET
ANOTHER CHANCE TO LOOK AT IT MY
ONLY CONCERN AND IT'S A BIG ONE
FOR ME IT WAS JUST THE LAST
PARAGRAPH OF THE ANALYSIS. FROM
PAGE FIVE OF FIVE FORD POSES THE
QUESTION OF SHOULD THIS BILL BE
AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE EMPLOYEES
OF LICENSE EXAM PREP RECREATION
PROGRAMS MUST BE OVER EIGHTEEN
AND BE FINGERPRINTED BEFORE
SERVICES ARE INSTRUCTIONS-
INSTRUCTION TO CHILDREN AND I
HEARD YOUR REASSURANCES ABOUT
YOUR INTENT TODAY I HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE THIS FAMILY. SEEN ANYTHING
IN TERMS OF AN AMENDMENT THAT
CLARIFIES CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
CHECK WORK- MAYBE IT'S HERE
SOMEWHERE IN THE POINT THAT OUT
TO ME BETWEEN NOW AND THE NEXT
COMMITTEE BUT YOU KNOW THE
INTEREST OF TIME I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT'LL BE. IT IN AN ONGOING
CONCERN FOR ME TO SEE THAT
THAT'S ACTUALLY CLEARED UP IN
THE LEGISLATION. THERE'S NO
AMBIGUITY ABOUT THE- WILL HAPPY
TO MAKE THIS CLEAR- AS CURRENTLY
IT IT'S ALREADY PART OF THE
PROCESS AND I BELIEVE IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN IF I'M- TO MY SUPER WAS
JOANNE. I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK
OUT OF TURN BUT I BELIEVE THAT.
EVERY PRESCHOOL PROGRAM HAS THE
REQUIREMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE IN ORDER TO HE HIRED TO WORK
AT THESE FACILITIES THEY HAVE TO
BE FINGERPRINTED. BUT IF YOU
LIKE TO HAVE THAT-EXTRA
LANGUAGE AND- CLARIFICATION THE
BILL WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
AT THAT WILL NOT BE A PROBLEM.
SHE DID AN AWFUL CLOSE MY ORDER
BOOK THERE. THANK YO SENATOR
CORTESE A DID YOU MOVE THE BILL
CENTER PAN. OKAY THE BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR A TRUE
BOOK WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
CERTAINLY. ORGIES. SO
RESTRICTING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE PRIVATE SECTOR LIMITS ACCESS
TO ACTIVITIES AND SPORTS
PROGRAMMING FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
WHICH IS CRUCIAL IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CRITICAL SKILLS
INCLUDING TEAMWORK COMMUNICATION
LEADERSHIP AND TIME MANAGEMENT
PARTICIPATION IN SPORTS
PROGRAMMING AND ENRICHMENT
PROGRAMS ALSO RESULT IN HIGHER
LEVELS OF CONFIDENCE AND SELF
ESTEEM FOR THE MORE PHYSICAL
ACTIVITIES PROMOTE THE PHYSICAL
MENTAL SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL WELL
BEING OF A CHILD BY SATURDAY'S
AREA REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL
PRESCHOOL RECREATION PROGRAMS
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE
BEST POSSIBLE PROGRAMMING
OPTIONS WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
THIS AGE GROUP I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER OCHO BOTH THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN.
MEDICINE SULTAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THAT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES LEYVA HI LEYVA IODORAL
ABOVE HI THE TROUBLED AYE
COURTESY AYE FURTIVELY AYE DELI
DELI I GLAZER MCGUIRE HAND BY
HAND HI VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MERRICK CONSULTANT OUR MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO NOW ALL CALL THE
ROLL ON ANY BILLS THAT ARE YOU
MAY HAVE MISSED WE WILL START
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE MAN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB NINE
ZERO SIX THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE NOT
VOTING. OR TROUBLED. THE
RECONSTRUCTION OF DO THAT AS THE
CHAIR CARE MMHM. COURTESY HI
COURTESY I THE FOR THE MCGUIRE-
IS THAT THIS BILL I THOUGHT WE
WERE ON I'M SORRY NO THE MADAM
MINIMUM CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON SB NINE
OH SIX BY CENTER PORTANTINO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB NINE ZERO SIX
MOTIONS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY CHAIR VOTING I
VICE NUMBER. CHARGES ME SKEWS ME
SO SORRY FEATURING NO VICE NOT
VOTING. PHOTOBOOK COURTESY. NOT
VOTING. MCGUIRE K. THAT BILL
DOES NOT HAVE ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET OUT BUT WE WOULD ROUTE WE
WOULD REQUEST- RECONSIDERATION
FOR THE AUTHOR. MOVING THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX THE MOTION IS
DUE PATH BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIRMAN I VICE
CHAIR HAS NOT VOTED PATROL BOAT. I'M SORRY EIGHT SEVEN SIX
SUPPORT YES HI A TROUBLED BY
THAT SEVEN ZERO. SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
THREE SB ONE FOUR EIGHT ONE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE S. B. ONE
FOUR EIGHT ONE QUESTION IS DO
PATH BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES.
CHAIR VOTING I SURE HAS NOT
VOTED OCHO ABOVE. THE TROUBLED
BY. THAT BILLS OUT SEVENS FILE
ITEM FOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM FOR SB EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIRMAN. BUT YOU'RE VOTING I
DALY. SIX THAT BILLS OUT SIX
ZERO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
NINE FIVE TO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SB NINE FIFTY TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING NINE
FIVE SURE VOTING AYE. MCGUIRE
THAT BILLS AT SIX ZERO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB ONE ONE FOUR ONE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER NE SB ELEVEN
FORTY ONE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THAT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING AYE. DALY MCGUIRE THE
BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO PLEASE CALL
A FILE ITEM SEVEN S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS THE PATH AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ONLINE VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. MCGUIRE THE BILLS
OUT SIX ZERO. FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB ONE TWO SEVEN THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
SHARE VOTING AYE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO DALLI. DALLI NO GLAZER
MCGUIRE. THE BILL DOES NOT HAVE
ENOUGH VOTES WE WILL ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION FOR SENATOR
BRADFORD. OF FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB NINE TO FOUR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THAT WITH
FORTY THEM OUT SEVEN ZERO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SOMEONE ALREADY
DONE ALL RIGHT S. B. TEN S. B.
SKEWS ME FILE ITEM TEN SB ONE
TWO TWO TWO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB TWELVE TWENTY TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIRMAN DENY
VICE CHAIR VOTING ON GLAZER. THE
BILL ALSO DOES NOT HAVE ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT SO WE WILL
GRANT YOUR RECONSIDERATION. FILE
ITEM ELEVEN SB ONE TWO EIGHT
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
SB TWELVE EIGHTY NINE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES. CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED
HER VOTING ONLINE GLAZER.
MCGUIRE THAT BILLS OUT FIVE
ZERO. THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS WAS
A LITTLE LONGER THAN WE THOUGHT
IT WOULD GO TODAY BUT IT WAS A
GREAT HEARING I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY. IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR SUGGESTS. WAS WE WANT TO
TEST AND SPECIAL HE RECORDS
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED OUR AGENDA THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.